GOOD MORNING- WELCOME
EVERYBODY HERE IN ATTENDANCE-
ALSO VIRTUALLY TO ROUTE FRTY
TWO A TO THIS SPECIAL HEARING
THIS MORNING WITH ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FINANCE AS WELL AS THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WHICH PROVIDES A SERVE
ON AS WELL AS MR DONNELLY FROM A
SECOND- I ALSO WANNA NOTE THIS
IS OUR LAST TIME IN IN FORTY TWO
A TO AN END OF AN ERA. IN THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM ITSELF KIND OF
EMOTIONAL FOR A LOT OF USHAVE
BEEN HERE THE LAST THREE DECADES
A LOT OF IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY
HAS BEEN THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM BUT- THE SHOW WILL GO ON
ACROSS THE STREET. THE MOVIE
BACK HERE IN A FEW YEARS- THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY DURING THE
FALL OF COURSE TO FOCUS ON
OVERSIGHT. AND YOU KNOW THAT THE
TOP ISSUE IN OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION WE ALWAYS REMIND
OURSELVES IS HIS PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND THIS PANDEMIC
REALLY HAS HAD AN IMPACT ON ALL
OF US AND SO TODAY'S HEARING.
WILL FOCUS ON EARLY SNAPSHOT OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING RELATE TO
STUDENT ENROLLMENT ATTENDANCE
AND LEARNING RECOVERY AFTER THE
RE OPENING OF OUR SCHOOLS. AFTER
COVER NINETEEN I WILL NOTE THAT
IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA OF HAD
SOME HICCUPS WHAT I WAS AT A
SCHOOL JUST YESTERDAY. AND THE
PRINCIPAL REPORT THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPLE
REPORTED THAT 95% OF THEIR KIDS
ARE BACK AT IT LEARNING IN
PERSON. ON TO THANK OUR
FRONTLINE EDUCATORS. AT TODAY
WE'LL HEAR. ABOUT DATA ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH OUR STUDENTS. AND
CONSIDER- STATEWIDE ENROLLMENTS
INTENDANTS TRENDS AND TAKE A-
TAKE A SNAPSHOT WILL HAVE A
DEEPER DIVE ON THIS LATER IN THE
SPRING. OF THE PURPOSE OF THIS
HEARING IS TO HEAR ABOUT THE
TRANSIT IS BECAUSE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
CONTINUE STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
CRISIS. NOT FOCUSING ON YOU KNOW
THE FROM THE SCHOOL PERSPECTIVE
ALWAYS WHICH WE WILL HEAR FROM
THAT SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS BUT
HOW THIS IMPACTS OUR STUDENTS
AND OUR FAMILIES AND FOCUSING
ON. SENIOR RECOVERY- WITH A
PANDEMIC THAT WE HAVE- RECEIVE
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
STABILIZATION FUNDS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE NOW WITH
OUR BOOMING ECONOMY WE HAVE THE
STORY GROWTH AND PROP NINETY
EIGHT. SO THE ISSUE FOCUS THE
FOCUS I THINK THE ISSUE IS HOW
WE WILL UTILIZE THESE WITH THESE
RESOURCES TO. HELP STABILIZE
SCHOOLS BUT ALSO MAKE SURE THAT
NOT ONLY OUR SCHOOLS BUT OUR
KIDS RECOVER THIS YEAR IN THE
YEARS TO COME THE PREPARING ALL
STUDENTS A TIP TIP TO US TO
SUCCEED. SO WITH THAT WE HAVE A
ROBUST- PANELS HERE THIS MORNING
AS WELL AS OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT HE WAS HERE IN
PERSON- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
STAY ON CONTRACT TODAY WITH.
WITH OUR- AGENDA AND RIGHT NOW
I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO OUR
CULTURE TODAY MISTER O'DONNELL
COME BACK TO SOME- SOME
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS. I THINK
THANK YOU- MISTER MCCARTY. AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY LEARN
MORE. FROM OUR PRESENTERS TODAY
AND I GUESS THIS IS OUR LAST
TIME. IN THIS TERM SO- OR MOMENT
WHAT THE IMPACT OF COVERT
NINETEEN- THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO PERMEATE
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR DAILY LIVES.
NO MORE SO THAN A PUBLIC
EDUCATION IT'S FUNNY AROUND THE
STATE MANY CITY HALLS ARE
CLOSED. BUT SCHOOLS ARE OPEN
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN AND SERVING
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN. THE
PANDEMIC CREATES INNUMERABLE
CHALLENGES FOR OUR K. TWELVE
SYSTEM WHICH THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MET HEAD ON WITH INCREASED
FLEXIBILITIES AND MOST NOTABLY
EXTORT INCREASES OF STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING. DESPITE THESE
ACTIONS FROM SACRAMENTO IT IS
CLEAR THAT OUR STUDENTS TEACHERS
STAFF AND THE ENTIRE PUBLIC
EDUCATION INFRASTRUCTURE THE
STRUGGLING. DURING THIS PANDEMIC
. THIS FALL I'VE SPENT SEVERAL
DAYS AS A SUBSTITUTE TEACHER YES
I GO BACK IN THE CLASSROOM
TEACHING MIDDLE SCHOOL- DAHLE
FULL DAY OKAY THE REAL THING-
MISTRAL DONNA WALKS CENTER PUTS
HIS NAME ON THE BOARD AND
TEACHERS ANY SUBJECT THAT MIGHT
BE UP THAT DAY BECAUSE- WE HAD A
SHORTAGE OF SUBSTITUTES
SUBSTITUTES FOR SURE. AND SO
IT'S ALWAYS INTERESTING TO GO
BACK TO CLASS TO REALLY SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON FIRST HAND I CAN
TELL YOU IT'S EASIER TO SIT IN
SACRAMENTO. AND TELL SCHOOLS TO
OPEN. THAT IT IS TO OPEN A
SCHOOL THAT IS TO OPERATE A
SCHOOL DURING A PANDEMIC. SO I
WILL RECOGNIZE THAT AND THANK
OUR TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND CLASSIFIED
STAFF ACROSS THE STATE. FOR ALL
THEY'RE DOING TO SERVE
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN FROM MY
OBSERVATION CLASS SIZES ARE
TYPICALLY SMALL SMALLER BECAUSE-
SOME STUDENTS ARE ABSENT FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS SOME OF THE
COVERT RELATED I WOULD IMAGINE-
BUT AGAIN IT'S AN INTERESTING
MOMENT. SOME OF THE STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED STUDENTS INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAMS. SOME HAVE MOVED.
SOME ARE NOT COMING TO SCHOOL
ALL SUMMER ONLINE. SO THERE'S A
VARIETY OF FACTORS ASSOCIATED
WITH SCHOOL ATTENDANCE. AND
REMEMBER MANY OF THE STUDENTS
LIVE IN MULTI GENERATIONAL
HOUSEHOLDS RIGHT. HI SUMMER IS
OUR STATE NOT SO PROBLEMS OTHERS
ARE STATE VERY PREVALENT. AND SO
THEY HAVE TO OFTENTIMES TAKE
EXTRA CARE. NOT TO GIVE THE
PEOPLE IN THE HOME ELEVEN
COVERED BECAUSE THEY MIGHT BE
ELDERLY THEY MIGHT BE HAVE ALL
OF ORAL HEALTH STATUS. ALSO
PEOPLE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
TODAY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
FEAR OF MANY SCHOOL LEADERS THAT
BECAUSE OF DECLINING ENROLLMENT
AND CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM A
PORTION. LEVELS WILL DROP. AND I
THINK AT THE BUDGET LEVEL WE CAN
WE CAN DO A LOT TO ADDRESS THAT.
TO ENSURE THAT- CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FUNDING OVER HISTORIC
NEXT YEAR WE WILL NOT SEE A
DROP. JUST BECAUSE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS ATTENDING CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS HAS DROPPED WE NEED TO
KEEP CLIMBING- SO THAT WE CAN
ADEQUATELY FUND OUR SCHOOLS IN
FACT WE'RE STILL ONE OF THE
LOWEST IN THE STATES ON A PER
STUDENT. BASIS WE NEED TO CHANGE
THAT THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CHANGE THAT. PLEASE PLEASE KEEP
IN MIND THAT EVERY BUDGET
PROJECTION FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
INCLUDES A SURPLUS THE L. A. O.
ESTIMATES THAT NEARLY TWENTY
BILLION. IS AVAILABLE TO
ALLOCATE FOR SCHOOLS IN THE
UPCOMING. BUDGET CYCLES.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE AN URGENT
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT CHALLENGE I
WANT TO. ASSURE YOU THAT
CALIFORNIA IS NOT FACING. A
FUNDING CHALLENGE IN FACT WE
HAVE A FUNDING OPPORTUNITY. WE
KNOW THAT THE ISSUES FACING OUR
L. A.'S ARE COMPLEX. OUR GOAL
WITH TODAY'S JOINT HEARING IS TO
UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF THE
ISSUES LEARN ABOUT EFFORTS
ALREADY UNDER WAY TO BRING
STUDENTS. BACK INTO SCHOOL AND
CONTEMPLATE WHAT ELSE OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM NEEDS TO HELP
STUDENTS SUCCEED. IN THE CURRENT
CONTEXT THE CURRENT SITUATION
ANOTHER MAYBE OTHER MEMBERS-
SOME OF A RAZOR MAJORITY LEADER
DID YOU WISH TO SHARE ANY
THOUGHTS. YES THANK YOU I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING OUR CHAIRS-
RT MISTER DONALD. FOR CALLING
THIS HEARING TODAY. AND ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF OF SUB
TWO AND THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. I THINK THAT AS
MENTIONED HOW WELL OUR STUDENTS
HAVE RETURNED TO SCHOOL MOST OF
THEM ANYWAY. THEY ARE STRUGGLING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
AND LEARNING LOSS RECOVERY AND
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. AND WE
RECOGNIZE FROM WHAT WE HAVE READ
IT THAT THESE ISSUES ARE
AFFECTING OUR BLACK AND LATINO
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY AS WELL AS
OUR FOSTERYOUTH AND STUDENTS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING WITH
HOMELESSNESS. THEY'RE THE ONES
MOST AFFECTED AND I KNOW THAT
WE'LL BE HEARING ABOUT THAT
TODAY I THINK AS WE RECOVER FROM
THE PANDEMIC OUR FOCUS MUST BE
ON HOW WE CAN BEST SUPPORT. THE
MENTAL HEALTH AND ENGAGEMENT OF
OUR STUDENTS OUR TEACHERS AND
OUR SCHOOL STAFF. I LOOK FORWARD
TO LEARNING MORE. ESPECIALLY
FROM OUR SUPERINTENDENT. TONY
THURMOND. THE L. A. O. AND OTHER
PRESENTERS WHO HAVE ANALYZE THE
DATA THAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
RECEIVED. AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING THE
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW WE CAN BEST
SUPPORT. THE RECOVERY OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE LONG
TERM. I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES ESPECIALLY.
THE COMMENT ABOUT THE NEED TO
ADEQUATELY FUND OUR SCHOOLS I AM
HEARING FROM OUR SUPERINTENDENTS
. THIS IS A SERIOUS CONCERN FOR
THEM THEY DO NOT THE ABSENTEEISM
AND WANT TO BE SURE THAT THEY
ARE PROPERLY FUNDED. SO AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS ESPECIALLY OUR
SUPERINTENDENT- FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS I KNOW THAT. IT'LL
HELP US ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW PROCEED
WITH THE HEARING I KNOW OUR
SUPERINTENDENT. HAS A TIMELINE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE ARE HERE
TO A SERVER THAT WE HAVE OUR
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTOR INSTRUCTION HERE- YOU
KNOW NO STRANGER TO THIS CAPITAL
NOR THIS ROOM HERE AT FORTY TWO
A TO SELL. WELCOME AND AGAIN
THIS WILL BE YOUR LAST TIME
COMING TO THIS- THIS RUMORED
FORTY TWO IT TOO SO. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AND YOU CAN
ENLIGHTEN US ON SOME- ENROLLMENT
TRENDS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
ISSUES TO CONSIDER AS WE MOVE
FORWARD SUPERINTENDENT. I THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN MCCARTY CHAIRMAN
ALL DONALD TO MAJORITY LEADERS
TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
TO THE STAFF- TO EDUCATORS AND
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES ALL ACROSS
THE STATE- IT'S AN HONOR TO BE
BEFORE YOU TONY THURMOND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION- AS YOU'VE
INDICATED- A ROOM THAT HAD A
CHANCE TO BE IN MANY TIMES FOR
EDUCATION HEARINGS AND HEALTH
COMMITTEE HEARINGS. AND TO NOTE
AS YOU HAVE INDICATED THAT THIS
BUILDING IS TO BE DEMOLISHED TO
BE BUILT BACK BETTER- AND WHILE
IT'S SAD TO LEAVE THIS ROOM- I
THINK THAT THE- THE METAPHOR OF
BUILDING BACK IS SOMETHING FOR
US TO THINK ABOUT- IN OUR
SCHOOLS- YOU ALL HAVE FRAMED IT
THIS IS- WITHOUT. QUESTION THE
TOUGHEST TIME THAT ANY OF US IN
THIS NATION HAVE EXPERIENCE AND
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR FAMILIES
THEY FEEL THE BRUNT OF THAT
EVERY SINGLE MOMENT- I'VE HAD
THE CHANCE SINCE SCHOOL STARTED
EVEN SINCE BEFORE SCHOOL
STARTED. SINCE AS EARLY AS JULY
TO VISIT DOZENS OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE AND OUR
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN AND THEY ARE
DOING THE IMPOSSIBLE UNDER WHAT
FEELS LIKE IMPOSSIBLE
CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT WE'VE LOST LIVES TO THE
PANDEMIC THEY RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES
RACIAL CHALLENGES AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUES THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT NINETEEN COUNTIES IN OUR
STATE HAVE EXPERIENCE FIRE.
SCHOOLS HAVE BURNED DOWN PEOPLE
OF LOS THEIR HOMES THINGS HAVE
BEEN A THE- AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THIS IS
THE TOUGHEST TIME THAT WE WILL
EXPERIENCE IN OUR LIFETIME- AND
YOU CAN NAME ANY CHALLENGE THAT
YOU WANT DOES ANYONE OF THEM
COULD BE THE TOP. ISSUE STAFFING
SHORTAGES- THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. BUT I BELIEVE THAT
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR SCHOOLS
REPRESENT MORE THAN THE SUM OF
OUR EXPERIENCES OUR STUDENTS
HAVE DEMONSTRATED AN INCREDIBLE
KIND OF RESILIENCE. OUR
EDUCATORS CONTINUE TO LEAN IN TO
GIVE THE BEST OUR FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO LEAN IN TO GIVE THE
BEST. TO OUR STUDENTS AND AS WE
ARE IN THIS MOMENT. WE HAVE TO
UTILIZE THIS MOMENT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE WILL BUILD AN
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT IS BETTER
THAN WHAT WE HAVE HAD BEFORE. IT
HAS SPOTLIGHTED MANY INEQUITIES
STARTING IN THE PANDEMIC AT THE
BEGINNING OF IT. WHEN WE SAW
THAT A MILLION STUDENTS DID NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO COMPUTING DEVICES
AND ACCESS TO THE INTERNET. THIS
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR STEPPED
IN AND MADE SURE THAT
IMMEDIATELY THERE'D BE RESOURCES
TO SUPPORT. THOSE STUDENTS TO
BEGIN THE WORK TO CLOSE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE- THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THIS GOVERNOR OFFICE OF ALL
WORK TOGETHER ON THINGS TO
ADDRESS. COLD MEDICATIONS
DIRECTLY WITH COVERT TESTING
ENOUGH VACCINES. BUT YET IN
SPITE OF ALL OF THIS WE SEE
THAT- THE PANDEMIC CONTINUES TO
EVOLVE. EVEN AS WE SPEAK TODAY
HEALTH EXPERTS ARE TALKING ABOUT
A NEW CHALLENGE. A NEW VARIANT
THAT REPRESENTS A NEW THREAT TO
US TO OUR WAY OF LIFE NOT JUST
TO OUR SCHOOLS BUT TO OUR ENTIRE
WAY OF LIFE OUR ENTIRE WAY OF
SURVIVAL. ARE SMALL BUSINESSES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. BUT WE KNOW
THAT OUR KIDS DESERVE IN MUST
STILL GET AN EDUCATION. AND SO
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO WORK
THROUGH THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
SEE IN OUR SCHOOLS WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN DO. TO BUILD SCHOOLS BETTER
THAN WHAT THEY WERE BEFORE IN
THIS LEGISLATURE AND THIS
GOVERNOR WE'RE PROUD TO BE
IMPLEMENTING MANY OF THOSE GREAT
PROGRAMS. HAVE PROVIDED
INCREDIBLE PROGRAMS FOR DOING
THAT AND IT'LL BE IMPORTANT. WE
TALK ABOUT UNIVERSAL T. K. IT
WILL BE IMPORTANT. IF YOU LOOK
AT THE BIG. ENROLLMENT TRENDS
THEY TEN TO BE GREATEST. IN THE
LOWER GRADES INDICATE THREE
PAN. AND SO THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE. BUT
HAVING UNIVERSAL TKA REPRESENTS
A SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT FOR PROBABLY MOST OF OUR
PROFESSIONAL CAREERS. AND THANK
YOU SOME IN THE MCCARTY FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. OVER
MANY MANY YEARS- AND FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
MAKING THIS SOMETHING THAT IS A
HALLMARK. IN OUR STATE BUDGET
THAT WE WILL HAVE PROGRAMS READY
FOR YOUR LAWN STATE. AND SO YES
WHEN YOU TALK TO MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE FEELING
AROUND THE CLIMBING IN ROME.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THE
CHALLENGES THEY FEEL AROUND-
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM AND STUDENTS
WHO. HAVE NOT CHECKED IN AND WHO
ARE NOT ATTENDING. EVERY PUBLIC
SCHOOL TRADITIONAL. PUBLIC AND
CHARTER PUBLIC WILL TELL YOU
THAT THEY ARE EXPERIENCING.
ISSUES AROUND ATTENDANCE AND
THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR THEIR CURRENT
OPERATING. ABILITIES THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR THE FUTURE TO BORROW THE
TERM. THAT YOU ALL HAVE USED IN
THIS AGENDA THEY ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS. FOR THE
FISCAL CLIFF GOING FORWARD
THEY'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT- AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE HELP FROM STATE LEADERSHIP.
NOT JUST TO ASK FOR FUNDING BUT
THOUGHT PARTNERS TO THINK
THROUGH HOW TO APPROACH THAT
CLIFF. AND HOW TO THINK ABOUT
INNOVATION AND HOW TO. THINK
ABOUT ENGAGING FAMILIES IN THE
STATE OUR SCHOOLS THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THE CLIENT
ENROLLMENT EACH AND EVERYONE OF
THEM. HAVE ACCELERATED THEIR
EFFORTS AROUND NOT REACH TO
SPEAK TO FAMILIES TO DO FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT OUR OWN OFFICE WE
CREATED OUR FIRST FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT DIVISION. DURING THE
PANDEMIC SO THAT WE CAN HELP
SCHOOLS THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT
HOW TO ENGAGE WITH FAMILIES.
EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
THINKING HOW DO WE DO MORE
OUTREACH HOW DO WE- HELP TO SEND
A MESSAGE ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE TO
OFFER. HOW DO WE- TALK ABOUT
WHAT WE WILL DO TO ADDRESS
LEARNING LOSS IN THE GAPS THAT
EXIST. AND THIS YEAR'S THE BY
PROVIDES OF THOSE INCREDIBLE
RESOURCES THAT YOU KNOW.
UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMMING SO THAT WE HAVE WAYS
TO SUPPORT STUDENTS FROM THE
TIME. FROM BEFORE SCHOOL STARTS
TO THE AFTER SCHOOL TIME THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT LEARNING
ACCELERATION THAT WE HAVE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. TO
SUPPORT OUR EDUCATORS WHO ARE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH OUR
STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE ACCESS TO
UNIVERSAL MEALS SO THAT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS. CAN GET A MEAL
REGARDLESS OF THEIR FINANCIAL
SITUATION OR THEIR BACKGROUND
IT'S NOT ABOUT PAPERWORK WE HAVE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS THAT. SPEAKS
TO THE CONCERNS ADDRESSED BY THE
MAJORITY LEADER AT THAT OUR
STUDENTS NEED TO HAVE ACCESS TO
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORTS AND
WITH THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
INITIATIVE. OUR STUDENTS WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE PROGRAMS I
CAN PROVIDE. MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH- SOCIAL SERVICES
BUT MORE THAN THAT
TRANSFORMATIVE SERVICES THAT
WILL CHANGE WHAT ARE SCHOOL
CLIMB IT LOOKS LIKE. THE CLIMATE
OF OUR CAMPUSES IN THE SOFTENING
OF OUR CAMPUSES IN THE ENDING OF
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
AND CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE TRAJECTORY OF ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF THEIR
BACKGROUND. AND SO WE HAVE THESE
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES BUT WE ALSO
HAVE. FOR MANY OF RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE IN UNIVERSAL. MEALS AND
UNIVERSAL PRE K. AND- AND OF
COURSE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT ALL THESE THINGS-
AS WE TRY TO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS
AS THEY- IS THE BILL BACK THEY-
ARE SCHOOL LEADERS WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT. THEY ARE WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES THEY APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT THAT HAVE COME FROM THE
STATE. AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT THEY ARE TRYING
TO MANAGE A CLIFF. THAT INVOLVES
CALCULATING HOW TO USE WHAT ARE
ESSENTIALLY ONE TIME DOLLARS
FROM THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHILE THEY TRY TO
THINK THROUGH STRUCTURAL
CHALLENGES THAT THEY WERE TRYING
TO ANSWER FROM BEFORE. THE
PANDEMIC IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA
AROUND IT DECLINING ENROLLMENT
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE'S BEEN
POPULATION DECLINE FROM BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. THAT FEWER BIRTHS-
FOLKS HAVE RELOCATED FOR OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AND LEFT
OUR STATE- AND SO THAT WE SEEN.
A SLOW GROWTH IN POPULATION AND
IN SOME CASES JUST AN ACTUAL
DECLINE. THAT THE CLIENT CLEARLY
HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND OUR SCHOOLS ARE
WORKING HARD TO REACH THOSE
FAMILIES WHEREVER THEY ARE- TO
DETERMINE HOW TO BRING THEM
BACK. IN SO THE MESSAGE THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM OUR SCHOOL
LEADERS IS THAT THEY WANT
PARTNERSHIP AS ALWAYS WITH OUR
STATE LEADERS. ON HOW TO THINK
ABOUT THAT CLIFF ON HOW TO THINK
ABOUT INNOVATION ON HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN HAVE
ACCESS. TO WORLD CLASS PROGRAMS
THAT TEACH THEM A SECOND
LANGUAGE BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
DUAL LANGUAGE PROGRAMS. ARE THE
WAY TO ACCELERATE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT THAT SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS AND MAKE THEM GLOBAL
CITIZENS OF THE WORLD ON STEAM
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES. TO
PREPARE OUR STUDENTS FOR THE
JOBS OF TOMORROW- FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STUDENTS TO
LEARN ABOUT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND MAYBE EVEN GET A
PAID INTERNSHIP. OUR SCHOOL
LEADERS AR WARNING TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON HOW
TO BRING FORWARD. THESE KINDS OF
INNOVATIONS THAT SHOW THAT EVEN
THOUGH THIS IS A DIFFICULT
MOMENT THIS IS THE MOMENT FOR US
TO BUILD AN EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT'S BETTER THAN WHAT WE'VE
HAD BEFORE. TO SERVE OUR SIX
MILLION STUDENTS AND WE HOPE TO
ALLOW THE WAY YOU'LL- OUR- AND
WE DECLARE. THAT WE'RE GOING TO
ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
LEARN TO READ BY THIRD GRADE.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON BY
LITERACY GOALS THAT OUR STUDENTS
LEARN TO READ AND WRITE MORE
THAN ONE LANGUAGE. AND THAT WE
LEARNING GAP ESPECIALLY THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE SEEN. AS
IT RELATES TO BLACK STUDENT
PERFORMANCE COMPARED TO THAT OF
OTHER GROUPS AND THAT WE'VE
NAMED A BLACK STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT TASK FORCE TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS. MANY OF YOU HAVE
BEEN A PART OF IT THANK YOU SO
MEMBER BOSTON OTHERS WHO JOIN
OUR EFFORTS. AROUND LITERACY AND
OUR GOAL TO PROVIDE A MILLION
BOOKS TO STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
IN NEED WHO WHO NEED IT. AND TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO LIBRARY CARDS AND
ACCESS TO LIBRARY SPACES IN JUST
THE NEXT. SEVERAL MONTHS WE
ANTICIPATE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
MORE STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WILL GET ACCESS. TO A
LIBRARY CARD AND SO WE SAY THIS
TO SAY THAT WHILE WE EXPERIENCE
THIS DECLINING ENROLLMENT WE
ALSO SEE OPPORTUNITIES. TO BUILD
FROM THESE CHALLENGES TO MOVE
TOWARDS INNOVATION. IN OUR
SCHOOLS HAD TO USE THE WONDERFUL
TOOLS PROVIDED BY ALL OF YOU TO
SUPPORT COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND
UNIVERSAL T. K. AND UNIVERSAL
MEALS- TO PROVIDE. A GREATER
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND- THEY ARE PREPARED TO SHARE
ANY DATA THAT ANY IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW ABOUT ANY OF THE
DECLINES IN YOUR SPECIFIC
DISTRICTS. WE DO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TODAY- ARE
DISTRICTS STAND BY TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH YOU WE'VE EVEN
ENGAGE SOME OF OUR DISTRICTS ON
HOW THEY CAN MARKET DIFFERENTLY.
TO OUR SCHOOL COMMUNITIES THEY
WANT SCHOOL COMMUNITIES TO KNOW
ALL THE GREAT OFFERINGS THAT
THEY HAVE IN ALL OF THESE NEW
PROGRAMS AND SO- WE STAND BY
TODAY FOR YOUR QUESTIONS. YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN YOUR
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW WE CONTINUE
THIS WORK THAT HAS BEGUN. TO
ADDRESS AN OFFSET ISSUES AROUND
THE CLIMBING ENROLLMENT. AND TO
SHOW THAT ONCE AGAIN WE ARE ABLE
TO BUILD AN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
THAT IS BETTER THAN WHAT WE HAD
BEFORE. ON BEHALF OF. ALL OF OUR
SIX POINT TWO MILLION STUDENTS.
THANK YOU AND I SUBMITS ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MISTER. THANK
YOU SUPERINTENDENT THAT I WANT
TO JUST FOCUS BRIEFLY. ON THE
BUDGET. PIECES IN THE FINANCES
SO. OF COURSE WORK. HERE TO WITH
THE- CA. AND IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AND WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT THE PANDEMIC IT'S REALLY
ABOUT ITS IMPACT ON STUDENTS
GETTING BACK IN SCHOOL AND
PARENTS GETTING BACK TO WORK AND
HAVING A FUNCTIONING ECONOMY
WHICH- SCHOOLS ARE OPERATING AND
HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE-
FOCUS ON STUDENTS WHO WERE
FRANKLY BEHIND BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND YOU KNOW BUILD
BACK. BETTER FOR IT FOR
EVERYBODY. THE ISSUE THAT I
THINK I'M HEARING MAYBE YOU CAN
ENLIGHTEN US. IS THAT IT FROM
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTSJUST ON THE
MONEY PIECE IT'S A DISCONNECT.
BECAUSE WE SEE. THESE REPORTS AS
FAR AS RECORD REVENUE COMING IN
TO CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW AS WE
KNOW THE WEALTHY ARE DOING VERY
WELL. IN OUR STATE SPACE IS THE
BEST LEAD AFTER THE PANDEMIC
STARTED. RECORD AMOUNT OF MONEY
COMING IN THE CAPITAL GAINS ONE
TIME SO YOU LOOK AT THAT ONE
TIME MONEY. WITH THE STATE MONEY
LAST THE FEDERAL WE'RE TALKING
FORTY BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
YOU'RE RIGHT DISTRICTS CAN'T USE
THAT FOR ON GOING AND THEY SAY
THAT- WE CAN'T IS AN ON GOING
BUT STILL WE HAVE WE HAVE NORTH
OF TWENTY BILLION AND ONGOING
JUST PUT IN PERSPECTIVE THREE
YEARS AGO MR. ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO BALLOT TO INCREASE
TAXES ON THE HIGHEST EARNERS TO
GET CALIFORNIA IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PACK FOR PEOPLE FUNDING WELL
THE LAST TWO YEARS THAT'S
HAPPENED I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
THIS NEW AND IT'S HARDER BECAUSE
TO PROJECT IN THAT TAKES AWHILE
TO SEE IT BUT APPLES TO APPLES
BUT- CALIFORNIA WE'RE NOW IN THE
MIDDLE THE PACK SO. HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU FOCUS ON THIS
DISCONNECT THAT SOME DISTRICTS
ARE LIKE THE SKY IS FALLING
THROUGH IS THAT THERE IS THIS
THE CLIFF AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
OFF THE CLIFF IS I WANT TO MONEY
WHEN WE HAVE. TWENTY BILLION A
GENERATIONAL CHANGE AS FAR AS
INVESTING IN OUR SCHOOLS WHAT
WILL BE BUT THE VOTERS WERE
PROMISED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT WHEN I WAS IN SCHOOL HERE
AND SALAS TV COMMERCIALS FOR
THAT'S GOING TO CHANGE PUBLIC
SCHOOL FUNDING NOW WE'RE KIND OF
THERE AND SO WE'RE HEARING THESE
TWO THINGS AND SO HAVE YOU GO TO
SCHOOLS LIKE I DID. I WAS AT A
SCHOOL YESTERDAY IN OUR AND OUR
SUPERINTENDENT SAID YOU KNOW WE
HAVE SOME DECLINING ENROLLMENT
HERE FOR JUST POPULATION
DECLINES IN AS WE SING ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA NOT
STABILIZATION IN SOME OF THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS HE SAID 95% OF THE
PARENTS ARE HAVE GONE BACK
ABOUT. 5% ARE DOING INDEPENDENT
STUDY BUT ARE STILL IN THE
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO THEY'RE NOT. SO
HOW DO WE RECONCILE THESE TWO
THINGS TONS OF NEW MONEY IN SOME
DISTRICTS LIKE FREAKING OUT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
I WOULD JUST SAY I WOULD ASK YOU
TO THINK ABOUT YOUR QUESTION IN
THE CONTEXT OF TO SPECIFIC
AREAS- STAFFING AND STAFFING
SHORTAGES- AND IF WE JUST USE
UNIVERSAL MEALS AS AN EXAMPLE-
UNIVERSAL MEALS IS AN INCREDIBLE
THING IS AN INCREDIBLE
OPPORTUNITY. BUT RIGHT NOW THIS
STATE JUST LIKE ALL OF THIS
NATION IS EXPERIENCING A
SHORTAGE IN SUPPLY IN ORDER FOR
SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT UNIVERSAL
MEALS THEIR COSTS ARE READY. UP
ARE GOING UP AND WILL GO UP
HIGHER IN SO THERE ARE COST
CONSIDERATIONS MATTER FACT I WAS
THINKING THE LAST TIME I SAT IN
IT EDUCATION COMMITTEE HEARING
PHYSICALLY IN THIS BUILDING WE
TALKED ABOUT WHAT YOU IN
TERMINAL DAHLE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY. THAT OUR SCHOOLS WERE
ALREADY FACING- LACK OF REVENUE
NECESSARY TO OPERATE- TO PAY
STAFF TO PROVIDE THE OPERATIONS
FOR OUR CORE OPERATIONS IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND SO WHAT HAS HAPPENED
THE PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED ALL
OF THAT. IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SUPPORT THAT
HAS BEEN PROVIDED IN THIS
ONGOING ADA- BECAUSE THE
PANDEMIC'S NOT OVER- SCHOOLS ARE
SAYING HEY WE'RE APPROACHING THE
CLIFF AND THEY'RE SAYING YOU
KNOW HOW DO WE CONTINUE TO GET
HELP GOING FORWARD BECAUSE THEY
SEE THE CHALLENGES. OF YOU KNOW
STUDENTS WHO WERE IN QUARANTINE
STUDENTS WHOSE ATTENDANCE HAS
BEEN- WHO HAD CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM YOU'LL HEAR FROM
SOME DISTRICTS TODAY THAT WILL
TALK ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES
WE'RE EXCITED TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH OAKLAND IN INGLEWOOD
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON SOME
PROGRAMS THAT WE THINK MIGHT
HELP TO. COUNTER SOME OF THE
DECLINING- OR THE CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM BUT- SCHOOLS ARE
SAYING THAT OUR COSTS ARE HIGH
THERE ARE SCHOOLS LIKE EVERY
SECTOR IN THIS STATE IN THIS
NATION ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING- IN
AVAILABILITY OF STAFF TO HIRE TO
HIRE NEW STAFF. AND WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE SALARIES THAT SCHOOL
STAFF GET PAID ON AVERAGE IT'S
LOW AND WHEN SCHOOLS ARE LOOKING
TO HIRE STAFF THEY EVEN
SUBSTITUTES THEY'VE AT RATCHET
UP. WHAT THEY PAY TO GET MORE
STAFF AND EVEN THEN THEY CANNOT
GET STAFF. BECAUSE OF A
NATIONWIDE STAFFING SHORTAGE IN
SO ONE TIME DOLLARS FOR PROGRAMS
ARE HELPFUL TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS BUT DON'T BE
QUITE. TO THE SAME NEED FOR
ONGOING OPERATIONS THAT OUR
SCHOOLS NEED TO HAVE YOU HERE
THANK YOU FOR ME YOU'LL HEAR
FROM DISTRICTS TODAY THAT YOU'VE
ASSEMBLED TO GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY
THEY'LL TELL YOU. THEY CANNOT
HIGHER CLASSIFIED STAFF TEACHING
STAFF SUBSTITUTES BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO OFFER
WAGES THAT WILL OFFSET THE
STAFFING SHORTAGE IN THIS STATE
AND IN THIS NATION. AND ALSO
INCREASE THE SALARIES OF THOSE
THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE IN
THERE IN THE CURRENT STAFFING
ROLES AND SO I THINK THAT IF YOU
JUST THINK OF THESE TWO
EXAMPLES. THEY GIVEYOU A WAY TO
THINK ABOUT WHY EVEN WITH THE
INFLUX OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
COMING- IT IS NOT. THE SAME AS
HELPING THEIR OPERATIONAL NEEDS
GOING FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS MISTER O'DONNELL YEAH
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PAYING APPROPRIATE PICTURE
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN YES OKAY I'VE
BEEN IN SCHOOLS. I GOT A
DAUGHTER IN HIGH SCHOOL SHE GOES
TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY. THE SCHOOL
IS FULLY STAFFED YES SOMETIMES
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS ALL RIGHT
CHALLENGE I THINK WE NEED TO
LOOK AT THAT I MEAN I. I HEARD
OF ONE DISTURBING THESE PAY
THERE'S PAYING A HUNDRED BUCKS A
DAY THAT PROBABLY ENDS UP BEING
LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE IF YOU DO
A FULL DAY OF TEACHING RIGHT.
WHICH IS CRAZY TO ME- NO WONDER
GOTTA COMPENSATE PEOPLE
ADEQUATELY. AND REMEMBER YOU'RE
ALSO ASKING PEOPLE TO GO INTO A
CLASSROOM WITH THE PROBABLY
CULPRIT IN MANY CASES RIGHT.
IT'S OUT THERE RIGHT SO YOU NEED
TO BE WE NEED YOU KNOW ASKING
THEM TO DO THAT AND AGAIN IT
GOES BACK TO MY STATE WHERE IT'S
ASIER FOR SACRAMENTO THEY OPEN
THE SCHOOLS. IT'S MUCH HARDER TO
DO IT AND YET THAT HAS BEEN DONE
SO I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THAT
THE PICTURE PAYING IS ADEQUATE
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN KIDS GOING TO
CLASS. HEY KIDS ARE THERE- WHAT
DO WE HAVE SOME CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM YES WE DO. WE NEED
TO INVESTIGATE THAT FURTHER AND
SEE WHERE THEY WENT- SEE IF IT'S
MORE INTERMITTENT. I DO THEY
COME SOMETIME TODAY NOT COME THE
TIMES BECAUSE A CO. IS BECAUSE
OF FAMILY SO. WHICH IN SOME SOME
SOME. SOME SOME SCHOOLS HAVE
ALWAYS EXISTED. SO GUYS ONE MAKE
SURE THAT THE PICTURE WE PAINT
IT IS FAIR AND ADEQUATE. I'M
VERY IMPRESSED WHEN I WALK INTO
SCHOOL SITE SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
KIDS ARE THERE- ABSENT AMASSED
QUITE FRANKLY THINGS LOOK PRETTY
MUCH LIKE THEY DID BEFORE COAT-
SIR THERE'S MORE PROTOCOLS IN
PLACE. HANDWASHING ECCENTRIC-
BUT AGAIN. YOU KNOW THE SCHOOLS
ARE OPEN THEY'RE OPERATING.
THANK YOU MISTER SUPERINTEND
THANK YOU AYE I CONCUR WITH
YOUR- ASSESSMENT- MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'VE HAD THE CHANCE TO
VISIT DOZENS OF SCHOOLS ON DAY
ONE. WHEN THEY OPEN AND IT IS
HEART WARMING. TO SEE WHAT OUR
SCHOOLS ARE DOING. UNDER WHAT
OFTEN FEELS LIKE IMPOSSIBLE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND- NOT ONLY THEY
PROVIDING WELCOMING SPACES
LEARNING SPACES. THEY'VE HAD TO
LEARN HOW TO DO HEALTH RELATED-
INTERVENTIONS ON THE FLY AND
OFTEN DON'T HAVE NURSES OR-
OTHER HEALTH STAFF. WHAT OUR
SCHOOLS EDUCATORS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES ARE DOING. IS QUITE
REMARKABLE BE STILL HAVE A WAYS
TO GO BUT WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
RESILIENCE. CREATIVITY IN THE
DETERMINATION. OF OUR. STUDENTS
ARE EDUCATORS AND THEIR FAMILIES
. THANK YOU ALSO WANT TO NOTE
ARE. OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
WHO'S A MEMBER OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND VICE CHAIR. AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER- BONTA.
I THINK THIS IS YOUR- NOT YET
MAYBE NOT WITH ME OTHER YOUR
YOUR FIRST BY YOUR FIRST
COMMITTEE HEARING TIME WHERE
I'VE SEEN YOU PARTICIPATE SO A
NEW MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE.
AND A VERY ACTIVE PARTICIPANT
GOING FORWARD IN EDUCATION
EDUCATION FINANCE SO. FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR MR THURMOND.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU-
SUPERINTENDENTS- YEAH GET BACK
TO WORK AND HELP US IMPLEMENT AS
WANNA SAY ONE THING THAT I WANT
TO SAY FOR THE RECORD IS THAT-
THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT- A LONG LIST BUT-
THE ONE THING THAT THAT YOU ARE
DOING AND WILL DO RIGHT NOW. IS
HELP US IMPLEMENT AS YOU TALK IN
YOUR PRESENTATION THESE AMAZING
ACTIONS THAT WE THAT WE TOOK
THIS PAST YEAR. WHETHER IT'S
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS UNIVERSAL
T. K. UNIVERSAL AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS COMMITTEE SCHOOLS
ISSUES I KNOW YOU. CHAMPION WHEN
YOU WERE UP HERE AS A LEGISLATOR
BUT NOW SUPERINTENDENT WE NEED
YOUR HELP. INTO HELPING
DISTRICTS DO THIS AND DO THIS
WELL AND YOU KNOW THE GOOD NEWS
IS WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS
OVERNIGHT. SOME OF THESE ISSUES
WE HAVE MULTIPLE YEARS. IN THE
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THEM
GOING FORWARD BUT- YOUR
INVOLVEMENT IS I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL SO- SO- THANK YOU BUT
ALSO I REQUEST THE TASK TO HELP
US. HELP US DO THIS ON BEHALF OF
SIX MILLION KIDS IN CALIFORNIA
YOU CAN COUNT ON IT MISTER
CHAIR- IS DIFFICULT AT TIMES ARE
I FIND THIS I'M INCREDIBLY
HOPEFUL FOR CALIFORNIA- CHILDREN
IN SHORT. AS SOMEONE WHO KNOWS
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO EXPERIENCE
TRAUMA AND POVERTY AS A STUDENT.
AND EDUCATION HELP TO BE THE
THING THAT LISTS ALL BOTH FOR ME
AND MY FAMILY. I BELIEVE THAT
THE SAME AS POSSIBLE FOR ALL SIX
BILLION OF OUR STUDENTS. OUR
AGENCY HAS LEARNED HOW TO WORK
UNDER VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND SOMETIMES
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES NECESSARY.
TO DO IT I MENTIONED I MENTIONED
A FEW MOMENTS AGO OUR WORK TO
SUPPORT HOW SCHOOLS MARKET. AND
WE PARTNERED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR AND
FOUNDATION COMMUNITY THAT GRANT
IN PARTICULAR FROM THE HEISING
SIMONS FOUNDATION IT. GIVES US A
WAY TO DO MORE AND I JUST WANT
TO COMMAND ALL THE STAFF AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHO ARE LEANING IN TO
DO MORE. BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
OUR SCHOOLS ARE LEADING IN TO DO
MORE AND EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO
AS YOU'VE NOTED- WE WANT TO BE
IN A POSITION TO SAY YES AND WE
HAVE HOPE. THAT THIS WILL GET
BETTER AND THESE INCREDIBLE
RESOURCES WE BELIEVE BY
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS UNIVERSITY K.
UNIVERSAL MEALS AND THE LIKE
WILL TRANSFORM. CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. OKAY THE YOU
. NEXT WILL HAVE. OUR OUR PANEL
FIRST PANEL RELATED TO LEARNING
RECOVERY AND STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
. WE WILL HAVE NOT FOR
INDIVIDUALS ALL PARTICIPATING-
REMOTELY. THE L. A. OUR
ATTENDANCE WORKS THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATION
EXCELLENCE AS WELL AS A- THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT FROM OAKLAND
OAKLAND UNIFIED. FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
EDGAR CABRAL WITH THE L. A. L.
THANK HI GOOD MORNING- TERM
ATTORNEY GENERAL DONALD MEMBERS-OF THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK YES THANK YOU GOOD MORNING AT
YOUR GO HEAD. AND ROLL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I
WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE AMOUNT OF.
FUNDING THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET ACT
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT BRIEFLY
ABOUT OUR FISCAL OUTLOOK FOR
SCHOOLS ON THAT THAT COMES FROM
A NOVEMBER OUTLOOK REPORT THAT
WE JUST PUBLISHED A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO. I'M I KNOW I'M BOTH A
MEMBER OF THE NORTH AND THE
NUMBER OF A CAR YOU BOUGHT
REFERENCED. OUR SOME OF THAT
ALREADY SO I WILL KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF I'M GOING TO HAVE
A HANDOUT THAT I BELIEVE WAS
SHARED WITH YOU ALL AND SHOULD
BE AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE. I
MEAN FOR THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING
AT L. L. DOT CA THOUGHT YOU'LL
BE IT SHOULD BE IN OUR
PUBLICATIONS- SECTION OF OUR OF
OUR WEBSITE. I'M SO THE FIRST
PIECE ON ON- PAGE TWO OF THE
HANDOUT IS OUR QUICK TABLE THAT
SHOWS THE MAJOR FUNDING FOR
SCHOOLS IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET ACT. ON THE BUDGET
INCLUDED THIRTY POINT FIVE
BILLION IN NEW K. TWELVE PROP
NINETY EIGHT SPENDING- AND THIS
WAS PRIMARILY ONE COMPANY TWENTY
TWO POINT NINE BILLION ONE TIME
BUT ALSO SEVEN POINT SIX
BILLION. AND ONGOING FUNDING
INCREASES- AS YOUR ROLE WHERE
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ASSUMES THE MAJOR REVENUE
REDUCTIONS- FOR SCHOOLS ARE
UNDER THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE
STATE WAS KIND OF THE BIG
GENERAL FUND REVENUE DECLINES
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC- BUT
ENDED UP NOT BEING THE CASE AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET-
REVENUES WERE ACTUALLY HIGHER
THAN PRETENDING MAKE. IT TO THEM
ARE GENERATED A LOT OF ONE TIME
FUNDING- THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
SCHOOLS- BUT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET. IN
TERMS OF THE ONGOING INCREASES
ARE JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME KEY
ONES- FOR PERSONAL FEAR FACTOR
WAS A FIVE POINT 007% BASE
INCREASE TO BE A TIRE AFFORDABLE. I'M WHICH WAS OUR- OF. THE
CONSUMER REPRESENTED A LOT TO
CALL CUSTOMER ADJUSTMENT PLUS
THE 1% BASICALLY. THERE WAS ALSO
ONE POINT ONE BILLION. FOR
INCREASING THE- CONCENTRATE
GRAPHIC AS PER. TO SCHOOLS
SCHOOLS. IN TURN SCHOOLS WITH
CONCENTRATIONS OF INCOME
INCREASE YOUR STUDENTS. I'M NOT
NEXT PIECE HERE ON TABLES ONE
POINT FROM THREE BILLION FOR THE
NEW EXTRA. LEARNING UP. PROGRAM
OF THE ATTENDANCE FOR PROGRAM
GET TO. A FIVE BILLION. WITHIN
THE NEXT YEARS. AND TO PER. A
BEFORE AFTER IT. SCHOOL FOR- FOR
STUDENTS PRIMARY. ARE FOR WITH
PARTICULAR. ON PROVIDING THE-
FOR. LOW INCOME LOG STUDENTS.
I'M DOING ALL A BASE SPECIALIZED
. INCREASE OF THREE HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN. I MEAN YOU CAN SEE
I'M AT THE- A BILLION AND-
ONGOING INCREASES. FOR I WHAT I
LIKE THE- THAT WAS MENTIONED OR
- THAT'S NOT A LARGE MAGNITUDE
IN THE YEAR BUT WE- INCREASED
FUTURE IS. THE CHANGED YOU KNOW
KNOWS FOR STUDENTS. I'M NOT A
STUDENT. FOR FREE REDUCED PRICE
LUNCH UNDER THE- GUIDELINES. THE
SEE IT IN TERMS OF A ONE TIME
FOR AVAIL. HELLO BILLION OF IT
WAS TO FOR DOWN. NOT REALLY NEW
MONEY THAT'S AVAIL FOR SCHOOL
THIS. BUT ARE PAID SCHOOLARE
GETTING BACK ON- ROAD DON'T. ON
THE FOR OVER THE PER. WAVE THE
STATE. IMPLEMENTED BUDGET
REDUCTIONS IN THE TWENTY ONE BUT. ANOTHER COUPLE MORE- FUNDING
SOURCES THROUGH THE THAT THAT
ARE. TO NOW. BUDGET CAN USE IT
IN ON THE FIRST IS BEFORE POINT
TWO FIVE EIGHT DOLLAR IN Y.
WE'RE CALLING COVERT NINETEEN
RELATED. THAT INCLUDES A VARIETY
OF THINGS INCLUDING- THE SPRING
UP FROM THOSE POSH LAST- IN THIS
SPRING TWENTY OR THIS YEAR IT'S
OF TWENTY TWO ONE I WAS TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUND FOR
LEARNING I JUST- TRUST LEARNING
ABOUT THE ISSUE. AND ALSO- THE
IN PERSON IS GRANT TO PUT
BETWEEN KERR JUST TO IN THE TIME
THOSE ROLL MAJOR- THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED TO AND SCHOOLS ARE
BUDGETING FOR NOW. DOT THERE
WERE ALSO TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS A AND- WORK-
FOR. WITH SOME OF THOSE. ARE AND
ARE REMAINS STABLE FOR- BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGHOUT. PROCESS
LIKE THE RESIDENTS PROGRAM- TO
CLASSIFY- OF T. PRINCIPAL. BUT
THAT THE LARGEST PIECE OF. WHAT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLAR.
FOR A FUNDING FOR. CAPTAINS
BLOCK GRANT DISTRICTS HAVE TO
PICK USE FOR BECAUSE. ON THE
NEXT PAGE ARE WE A TABLE THAT
WALK THROUGH THE FUND I THINK. I
WAS EARLIER. THERE WAS A- AMOUNT
OF FEDERAL FUNDING OF A- THROUGH
THE VARIOUS READ. ALL PEOPLE
JUST SHOWS THE LAW TWO FEDERAL
FACT. REPORT AT. IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT- FOR SCHOOL I
WOULD BEEN CUT THE FIRST PIECE
TO TWENTY BILLION. IN ONE TIME
FOR- BACK BE USED FOR A VARIETY
OF OUR- BUT THE INTENT TO
ADDRESS EITHER COLD NINETEEN.
RELATED RECENT ISSUES OR TO OUR
LEARNING SOMEWHERE FOR THE
FUNDING OF REAL FLEXIBLE. BUT
BUT FUNDING IS MISTER. THREE ONE
THOUGHT THAT'S I'M GOING TO- IN
PARTICULAR BENEFIT THOSE WHO ARE
. ON SCHOOL HIGH POVERTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS OUR A LOT OF
NOISE STUDENTS. BUT GIVEN THE
LARGE MAGNET OF FUNDING TWENTY
EVEN SOME OF THE WERE. WE DON'T
KNOW HOW DO NOT HAVE AS HIGH
CONCENTRATE OF THESE TWO RECEIVE
SUBSTANTIAL OF PUBLIC. FROM
THESE GRANTS. THEY'RE ALSO A FEW
OTHER SMALLER PIECES FOR- THAT
TO THE TWO BILLION- WITH SOME-
THE FUNDING THAT PROVIDED.
SPRING BY THE LEGISLATURE. I'M
IN A THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
TEMPORARY FUNDING FOR. SCHOOL
I'M SO BIG PICTURE- BASTING. IN
OUR- CORE. OF THE APARTMENT FROM
. SPECIAL EDUCATION. WITH THE
CREATION OF A NEW SPENDING
LEARNING PRO. IN A VERY VERY
STIFF. AMOUNTS OF ONE TIME FOR.
MOST OF THE FEDERAL. CAN USED-
UNTIL AFTER YOU'VE SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWO FOUR SO JUST TO HAVE
MULTIPLE YEARS. TO USE THE
FUNDING. AND THEN- POP LOVE PAGE
WE HAVE A SOME OF WHAT'S WHAT
ARE FISCAL OUTLOOK FIRST
COMMUNITY AND I WHAT THE COST
ALREADY SO. A BRIEF- BUT WHAT WE
DO WE DO- OVERALL. OF REVENUE
AND EXPENSES FOR THIS- IN THE
AND THEN USE THAT TO TRACK
ARRESTED OF THE- NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEED POWER. I'M IN
THE WE ALSO LOOK AT THE CALL OF
THE EXAM. EDUCATION AND SEE HOW
MUCH OF KNOW AFTER CAN FOR OF
LIVING A THE- WITH FEDERAL HOW
MUCH FUN WITHIN BE AVAILABLE-
ADDITIONAL FUND FOR NEW
COMMITMENT. I'M SO WE HAVE- UP
UNDER ESTIMATES OF THURSDAY
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR. IN
ADDITION ONE TIME FUNDING THERE
WOULD TO BE OUT TO- COVER THE-
CARE. IN THE PRIOR YEAR MCCARTY
. COULD NOT BE BE ONE TIME
SPENDING. AND THEN INTO TWO
TWENTY THREE THE BUDGET YOUR WE
HAVE TO THAT OCTOBER A QUOTE
COVERING THE CALL OF NEW COMMIT
. OR LOOK EXIST COMMITMENT BUT
ARE AGREED TO. THAT WOULD BE
NINE POINT BILLION. A FOR NEW
ACTIVITIES AND I COULD BE.
ONGOING OR ONE TIME PER SO I'M
JUST AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT THE
BILL THAT IS LARGER THAN A OF
THE- DELIVERY ARE LARGE THAN ANY
. PREVIOUS CALLS THAT WE THREE
IN TERMS OF FUNDING OF IT WITH
PROCESS. NINETY EIGHT- THIS
MONEY IS ALWAYS THE- READ THE
STORY OF THE PROFIT WILL STILL
HAVE A BUDGET- PROCESS TO GO THE
GOVERNOR WILL RELEASE THEIR-
OPPOSITION. AMERICA AND- I'M BUT
WE DO THINK EVERY THAT WE SEE
SINCE THE- THAT SINCE THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUT WAS PASSED. HAS
SHOWN IT OUT IN REVENUE. I'M
SALT THERE. CONCERN THAT.
WHENEVER THE PRO. OKAY THANK YOU
WE WILL TRY TO GET THE END.
PANEL AND THEN TO. MEMBER
QUESTIONS IN COMMENTS THE ENTIRE
FOR PANEL AND THEN. HEAR FROM
MEMBERS THE GO TO SET PANEL. SO
NEXT WE- PARTICIPATE FROM
ATTENDANCE WORKS. HETTY CHANG.
HELLO I'M AND CAN I ASK THIS TO
GIVE ME A HERE FUNCTION ON THE A
SECOND CHANCE LOS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
CAREQUALITY MCCARTY AND NATURAL
DONALD- SO- I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND PROTECT WORKS WE
WORK NATIONALLY BUT WE ARE BASED
IN CALIFORNIA SO WE HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF COLLABORATING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT. NUMBER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HERE- I WANT TO
GIVE JUST A QUICK OVERVIEW OF
CHRONIC ABSENCE AND WHAT WE'RE
STILL HAPPENING BOTH IN TERMS OF
THE CHECK. WORKING CHALLENGED
AND WHAT ARE THE KINDS OF
STRATEGIES THAT CAN HELP TO
ADDRESS IT JUST LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD REALLY QUICKLY
WHEN I MEAN WHEN I SAY CHRONIC
ABSENCE I MEAN MISSING. 10% OR
MORE SCHOOL FOR ANY REASON THAT
INCLUDES EXCUSE UNEXCUSED
ABSENCES AND SUSPENSIONS. THAT'S
10% OR MORE OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
SO WELL THAT EIGHTEEN GAVE OVER
THE COURSE OF AN ENTIRE SCHOOL
THAT'S TWO DAYS IN THE FIRST
MONTH FOUR DAYS IN THE- SECOND
SIX DAYS IN THE THIRD MONTH OF
SCHOOL. DIFFERENT FROM JUST
LOOKING AT TRANSLATE OR AVERAGE
DAILY ATTENDANCE BOTH OF WHICH
CAN MASK HIGH LEVELS OF CHRONIC
ABSENCE. LOOKING AT CHRONIC
ABSENCE MATTERS BECAUSE CHRONIC
ABSENCE IS A- PREDICTOR OF
WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE GOING TO
READ AT GRADE LEVEL IN THE THIRD
GRADE. WHAT HAVE EVEN
ACHIEVEMENT IN MIDDLE SCHOOL.
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL. AND
EVEN CONTINUAL. SECONDARY
EDUCATION. HI CAPTAINS OF THE-
AND- IT BECAUSE ANY. AND AT.
YEAH EARLY YOU HEARD- I
APPRECIATED THAT BOTH SUPER
THERMAL AND- ASSEMBLY DONALD
TALKED ABOUT THAT MOST OF OUR
KIDS ARE IN SCHOOL AND THAT IS
TRUE AND IF YOU BUT IF YOU LOOK
AT THE STATE AT THIS IS. A
CHANGE CRISIS THANK. FROM THE
CAPTAIN IN THE BEGINNING. OF A
TWO NINETEEN TWENTY. WHAT
ABSENCE WHICH IS K. THINGS
PERCENT OF ALL BY THE UNITED AND
TO ONE ONE AND THEN KIND OF GAP
THE LEVELS OF KERR AFTER IN
TWENTY ONE TO TWO. AND WHAT YOU
ARE SEEING IS AND WHILE MISSING
SO WHILE THE MEN OF KIDS ARE
SHOWING UP TO SCHOOL AND LEARN
TAUGHT. A YOU'RE SO OKAY.
SIGNIFICANT GROWING NUMBER OF.
WHO ARE TRYING UP. FROM A LAB
22% TO SET ALMOST 18% ALMOST
THIRTY PERCENT. THIS FALL.
THAT'S AN ENORMOUS INCREASE. AND
LOOK AT IT BY GRADE LEVEL THE
INCREASES ARE HAPPENING X. LORD
MAYOR. IN KINDERGARTEN AND
FIRST. ALSO VERY HIGH IN HIGH
SCHOOL. WE ARE FACING AN
ATTENDANCE CRISIS THAT EVERY
GREAT. WITH SOME OF OUR
TRANSITION GRADES MOST AFFECTED
. AND THIS IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTING OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND WHILE IT WAS. THE PROBLEM
WITH THAT MAKE IT WORSE LAST
YEAR AND IT'S MUCH WORSE THIS
CURRENT FALL. AND THIS IS DATA
FROM SCHOOL INNOVATIONS AND
ACHIEVEMENT THANK DRAW IT FROM
THIRTY OF THEIR DISTRICTS WHICH
HAVE ONGOING DATA THE STATE
COLLECTED AT THE END OF THE YEAR
TO STATEWIDE DATA I NOT YET
AVAILABLE EVEN FOR LAST YEAR BUT
THIS IS DATA ON OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND KIDS
IN CALIFORNIA. THE SURGE IN KOBE
NINETEEN CASES IS DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF KIDS
STUDENTS WHO ARE ABSENT WELL
SOME OF THAT IS DUE TO FEARS
AROUND HEALTH IT'S- QUARANTINE.
ITS QUARANTINE TEN TO FOURTEEN
DAYS THEY WERE TRYING TO IN
PERSON SCHOOLING HAVE BEEN
ENORMOUSLY CHALLENGING OF BOOKS
BECAUSE KIDS ARE AT SCHOOL WHERE
HE CAN REAL CHALLENGES AROUND
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND MANY OLDER
STUDENTS RESEARCHED TO BAN
SCHOOL WITH GROWING FAMILY WORK
RESPONSIBILITIES THESE CHRONIC
ABSENCES IN THE FIRST MONTH OF
SCHOOL ARE ESPECIALLY
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE LEARNING A
SCAFFOLD ID WHEN YOU MISS OUT ON
THIS MY SCHOOL THE BEGINNING OF
THE- YEAR. IT MAKES IT HARD TO
STAY IN SCHOOL FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THE SCHOOL YEAR BECAUSE YOU.
IT'SHARD TO CATCH UP IT'S ALSO
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR WHEN
YOU FOR INTERRELATIONSHIPS WITH
MOVES AND WITH WITH YOUR PEERS
AND WITH YOUR TEACHERS SO THAT
YOU FEEL THOSE CONNECTIONS AND
HAVE THE RESOURCE. FOR LOST
LEARNING TIME IN THE CLASSROOM
AND WE KNOW THAT CHRONIC ABSENCE
IN THE BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL
YEAR CAN CAN PREDICT CHRONIC
ABSENCE. FOR THE REMAINDER OF
THE SCHOOL YEAR. IF IT'S NOT IN
A ROW AND IT'S ALL. NOW WILL
MEANS WE NOT BLAME ARE FOR BUT
SHE WHAT. WHAT IS THE ABOUT- THE
BERRY LIKE A HOUSING CHRONIC AND
BUT YOU KNOW WE KNOW AND I'M
CREATING BUT IT'S ALSO OF ACCESS
TO CARE HEALTHCARE. WHAT IS IT
ABOUT BURGEONING AND KIDS BEING
PUSHED OUT WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE TO FULLY RE
INVASION AND BUILD THAT CAR
EDUCATION SYSTEM SO THAT EVEN IN
VIRTUAL AND- IN IN PERSON IT'S
MORE ENGAGING THAN EVER. AND HOW
DO WE ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
FAMILIES STILL MAY SUFFER SOME
MISCONCEPTIONS BUT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHICH OF
THESE REASONS ARE. HAPPENING SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY COME UP WITH
REAL SOLUTIONSFOR KIDS AND
FAMILIES. WE KNOW THAT KIDS AND
FAMILIES. STUDENTS GO TO SCHOOL
WHEN THEY SEE POSITIVE
CONDITIONS FOR LEARNING WHEN
SCHOOL IS PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY HEALTHY AND SAFE.
WHEN SCHOOL THE PLACE OF
BELONGING CONNECTION SUPPORT
WHEN THEY FEEL ACADEMIC
CHALLENGING. AND THEY'RE
SURROUNDED BY ADULTS AND PEERS
WHEN YOU SEE A LARGE LEVELS OF
CHRONIC ABSENCE. IT MEANS THAT
WERE MISSING THESE CONDITIONS
AND THAT ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
THAT WERE HAVING TO PUT A BLAST.
BACK IN PLACE HOW DO WE ENSURE
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS. ESPECIALLY
WHEN SO MANY KIDS HAVE BEEN OUT
OF SCHOOL LAST YEAR AND ARE
HAVING SPORADIC SCHOOL EXPENSES
THIS YEAR. IT'S ABOUT PUTTING IN
PLACE A TIERED SUPPORT SYSTEM.
THAT WE USE DATA TO KIND OF
IDENTIFY WHO NEEDS I DO SUPPORT.
BUT WITH THIS HIGH LEVEL OF
CHRONIC ABSENCE ABOUT IT'S ABOUT
REPRIEVE REINVESTING IN OUR
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. AND THE PLACES
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GAIN
ATTENDANCE THIS YEAR ARE THOSE
PLACES THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
INVEST. IN THEIR PREVENTION
EARLY INTERVENTION FOUNDATIONAL
WHOLE SCHOOL SUPPORT. THAT I'VE
BEEN. LOCKED IN. THE ARE AND-
THE FOUNDATIONAL BUILDING BLOCKS
ARE I THINK WE TO A HOT THIS AND
SCHOOLS ACROSS HIS AGE ARE
NEEDING TO TAKE A LOOK AT AND
MAKES WE CAN KEEP KIDS ENGAGED
AND CONNECTED. LAST ACT CHRONIC
ABSENCE. CAN LEAD TO INCREASES
IN THE DROP OUT RATE AND LOWER
WRITTEN WRONG THAT WE HAVE TO
PAY ATTENTION TO ENGAGE IN
CHRONIC ABSENCE. ENSURING
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY DURING
PORTANTINO IF WE WANT THIS YEAH
ABSENTEEISM I DON'T EXPANSION
NOW NOT NEXT YEAR. IF YEAR AND
DURING THAT. PLEASE OUR DATA
AGAIN A FIVE WHICH KILLED FIRST
AFFECTED WITH SCHOOL GREAT AND
WE HAVE TARGET OUR RESEARCH AND
OUR IMPLEMENTING WE HAVE. THE
QUESTION MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THAT CONNECTION
ENGAGEMENT NOT USING THE
OPPORTUNITY OF OUR BUDGET
SURPLUS TO SCALE INTO STOLEN
EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES. AND
WE NEED TO EXPAND THE ARRAY OF
FOLKS INVOLVED YOUNG PEOPLE
FAMILIES EXPANDED LEARNING
PROVIDERS COMMUNITY PARTNERS
PUBLIC AGENCIES SO THAT THEY CAN
PARTNER WITH EDUCATORS COULD WE
ARE HEARING LOOKED AND CLEAR
ABOUT THE STAFF YEAH TO GET SPAM
THE SET OF ALLIED WHO ARE THERE
TO SUPPORT ARE CHRONICALLY
ABSENT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND HAPPY TO ANSWER. QUESTIONS WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. OKAY THANK YOU WE
WILL GO TO OUR NAY PRESENTER NOW
. THAT NOVEL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATION
EXCELLENCE. MORNING A CHAIR
MCCARTY CHERO DONALD MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME'S
NOT NOVEL I'M THE CURRENT MEDIA
OF THE CCP. I THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE TO SHARE SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE CURRENT L.
A. PERCEPTIONS WITH REGARDS TO-
ATTENDANCE AND- EDUCATIONAL
CHALLENGES THEY ARE FACING. THE
CHILDREN ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS ON OPPORTUNITIES AND I
APPRECIATE THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENTS FOCUS ON
PARTNERSHIPS THAT'S WHAT OUR
FOCUS OF THIS PRESENTATION WILL
BE. AS A REMINDER THIS YOU SEE
IS A STATEWIDE AGENCY STATUS TO
BY THE CYST ALL ELEAZAR CHEATING
THEIR GOALS SET FORTH IN THE
LOCAL COUNT ABILITY- PLANS. AND
IN PREPARATION FOR THIS HEARING
BE PROVIDED ARE ELLIE AS WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE US
SURVEYS- BOTH WRITTEN AND IN
PERSON TO MEETINGS AND
CONVERSATIONS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES. AND
PERSPECTIVES AND CURRENT
ACCOUNTS ARE THEY ARE. MAKING IN
ADDRESSING THOSE CHALLENGES- THE
QUESTION WE WERE AT TO REALLY A
WAS HOW DOES THE COMING IN ON
THE CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM FACT
EFFORTS TO ACCELERATE PROGRESS
IN LEARNING AND I THINK IT'S NO
SURPRISE WHEN WE SAY IT IT MAKES
IT DIFFICULT- ELLIE AS HAVE
EXPRESSED THAT NOT ONLY DOES IT
DECLINING ENROLLMENT AND THE
CHALLENGES ARE GREAT- WITH
FUNDING BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM ISSUES THE
ABILITY TO HAVE STUDENTS IN
SCHOOL ON A REGULAR BASIS
COMPOUND THEIR ABILITIES TO
ADDRESS THE LITERACY ISSUES
CHALLENGES THAT THEIR STUDENTS
EIGHTEEN. SOME OF THE BEHAVIOR
OF THE REGULATE AMPLIFIED.
NEARLY PROGRAMS THAT BEING SAID
. I THINK THERE ARE MANY MANY
MAYES THINGS ARE HAPPENING. ROSS
THE STATE THAT WE FOUND THAT ARE
BOTH- AT THE STATE LEGISLATIVE
LEVEL TO THE ALLEY A LEVEL
THERE'S AN AMAZING AMOUNT OF
HARD WORK THAT'S BEING DONE BY
OUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
COUNTY OFFICES AND EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS IN THE STATE AND I THINK
IT WOULD BE REMISS IF WE DIDN'T
JUST POTS AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. AND
WHERE WE CAN LEARN FROM OTHERS
ABOUT THE SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
BEING MADE IN ADDRESSING SOME F
THESE CHALLENGES. SO IT STATE
LEGISLATIVE- PERSPECTIVE THERE
ARE ONLY AS- COMMUNICATED FOUR
MAIN THEMES THEY SAID YOU KNOW
THEY THEY REALLY WOULD ALLOW.
THINK ABOUT. PATIENT FOR THEM IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CURRENT
INITIATIVES AS THEY BECOME
ESTABLISHED. AS YOU REFLECT BACK
ON CURRENT OR PAST STATEWIDE
INITIATIVES SUCH AS- THIS
SCALING UP INTO OFFICE. WHEN WE
PASS THAT BACK IN SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN WE ALLOCATED ABOUT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO THAT AS A
RESULT OF THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TASK FORCE REPORT. IT TOOK ABOUT
ONE AND A HALF TO TWO YEARS
BEFORE THAT INITIATIVE REALLY.
GAIN TRACTION AT THE L. A. LEVEL
THAT WAS UNDER- DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS OBVIOUSLY THE CURRENT
CONDITIONS MAKE THOSE-
CHALLENGES EVEN MORE OBVIOUS.
BUT THEY WANTED GRAYSON PATIENTS
WITH INITIATIVES BECOMING
REALITY. THEY WANTED- THAT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE I UNDERSTAND
THE CURRENT. ISSUES ARE THAT THE
CURRENT ISSUES. REQUIRED DEEP
COLLABORATION PROBLEM SOLVING
AMONGST STATE LEADERS AND
EDUCATORS AND THAT TAKES. TIME
AND COMMITMENT. THEY WANTED OUR
STATE LEGISLATORS TO KNOW THAT
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN THEY ARE THE TO
CENTER OF DONALD'S POINT- WHEN
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO KEEP KIDS IN SCHOOL AND
THEY'RE HAVING. SUCCESS IN A
MYRIAD OF PLACES BUT THEY ARE
CHALLENGED OBVIOUSLY- OBVIOUSLY
THOSE CHALLENGES WILL BE TALKED
ABOUT THROUGHOUT THE MORNING.
AND THEN ALWAYS THINK ABOUT
INITIATIVES FROM THE POINT OF
EQUITY AND THE WAY THEY AFFECT
SMALL AND RULED LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. SOMETIMES
IT'S CHALLENGING AS THEY THINK
ABOUT UNIVERSITY K<c.cyan> ACCESS.</c>
TO FACILITIES FOR PRE K. THE
SCHOOLS EXPAND MY UP. DOES TO
KEEP IN MIND. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT'S HAPPENING THE
EDUCATION POLICY LEVEL ARE
OPPORTUNITIES TO THINK ABOUT
CAPACITY BUILDING AND BUILDING
THE CAPACITY OF CAPACITY
BUILDERS AND THE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT AND SEE CURRENT
RESOURCES AND PROGRAMS TAKE A
FACT. THE FOCUS ON STAFF
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION US
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE THINKING
ABOUT THAT I MEAN THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THEIR
INSTITUTES OF HIGHER ED I CAN
THINK OF ONE EXAMPLE. FRESNO
COUNTY OFFICE OF ED HAS AND IS
PREPARING AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
TEACHER PIPELINE THAT BEGINS IN
KINDERGARTEN THAT'S INCREDIBLY
INNOVATIVE- INCREDIBLY HEAVY
LEFT AND INVOLVES A LOT OF
PARTNERS BUT THEY'RE THINKING
THAT FAR AHEAD. AND ALSO YOUR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS AND EXPANDED
LEARNING AND CHOP EARLY
CHILDHOOD FUNDING INITIATIVES
THOSE ARE PREDICATED ON WHOLE
CHILD DESIGN PRINCIPLES AND THAT
REQUIRES A RETHINKING FOR THEM
WITH A FOCUS ON TEACHING AND
LEARNING IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
THAN THEY HAVE DONE IN THE PAST
. WITH COUNTY OFFICES THE IDEA
OF INVESTING IN SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING MENTAL HEALTH. ONE OF
THE- HIGHLIGHTS WAS THE CAL HOPE
PRODUCT PROJECT OUT OF-
SACRAMENTO COUNTY OFFICE OF
THAT. THAT INVOLVES ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTY OFFICES AND AN
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR KELLY ACE. WHO ARE THINKING
ABOUT. THE OF THE WAYS TO
MITIGATE INSTRUCTIONAL BARRIERS
FOR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHEN
IT COMES TO INTEGRATING
SUPPORTS. FOR SOCIAL EMOTIONAL.
AND MENTAL HEALTH. INTERVENTIONS
YOU ALSO HAVE A FOCUS ON. FROM
THE MERRY OUTOF ELEAZAR WHO ARE
THINKING ABOUT DATA IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. THEIR FOCUS ON
THE LCF STUDENT GROUPS THAT ARE
HAVING THE MOST DIFFICULTY
ATTENDING SCHOOL E. I HEARD IT
OUT FROM THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER.
YOUR HOMELESS AND FOSTER
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
STUDENTS OF COLOR SKIP
UNDERSTANDING WHERE THE STUDENTS
ARE KNOWING THAT THE TENSIONS
THAT THEIR FAMILIES ARE FACING
AND TRYING TO MITIGATE THOSE
ISSUES ARE INCREDIBLE SUCCESSES.
AND OBVIOUSLY AT THE L. E. A.
LEVEL. AND THAT THE TEACHER AND
LEARNING LEVEL. TEACHERS ARE
HAPPY FEEL INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE. TO ACCELERATE PROGRESS
AND I THINK THAT THE MESSAGE
THAT WE'RE HEARING IS WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN. FOR
USING THE INTENSIVE
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORT STAFF
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO TUTOR
OUR STUDENTS BEFORE. DURING
LUNCH AND AFTER SCHOOL YOU HAVE-
AND THE NUMBER OF THE--ENGAGEMENT OPPORTUNITIES WITH
THE INSTITUTES OF HIGHER ED. IL
TO STAPLE TEACHING FORCE USING
THEIR STUDENT TEACHERS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. YOU HAVE A
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND MULTI AGE
COMING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS
SOCIAL MOTION. LEARNING AND
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THEY ARE DE
THINK ABOUT TO THE MITIGATE.
KEEP THE STAFF THEY HAVE. AND
READ AND RETAIN. OUR FUTURE
STATE SO THAT THEY CAN FOR ON
THE IN THE OF THEIR STUDENTS AS
THEY GO FOR. SO WITH THAT BEING
SAID I THINK THERE ARE JUST.
FOUR RECOMMENDATIONS I WOULD
THINK- AND PROVIDE THAT THE CCP
WILL BE FOCUSED ON AS WE GO
FORWARD. ONE IS HELPING ALLEY
GATES THINK STRATEGICALLY ABOUT
THE CURRENT INITIATIVES THAT ARE
IN THE PIPELINE YOU HAVE SEVEN.
STATEWIDE PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
INITIATIVES THAT ARE HIGHLY
FUNDED- REQUIRE INTENSIVE AMOUNT
OF TIME TO THINK YOU KNOW
LEARNING AROUND EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES AND INTERVENTIONS. OUR
JOB IS TO HELP TRANSLATE THOSE
FOR COUNTY OFFICES AND ELEAZAR
THE WAY THAT'S MEANINGFUL. WE
KEEP THE FOCUS ON LEARNING
INSTRUCTION TEACHERS TO SUPPORT
THEM. IN THE WAYS THAT TO YOU
HOW TO USE. THE RESOURCES AND WE
SUPPORT THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT BY
THINKING ABOUT HOW DO WE PROBLEM
SOLVE AND HAVE SOLUTIONS. FOR
THE USE OF ONE TIME FUNDS IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS THOSE INNOVATIVE
PRACTICES THAT DEVELOP OTHERS
ONE TIME FUNDS INTEL ON GOING
FUNDING. IN A WAY THAT SUSTAINS
THOSE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THE
WAY THAT THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE GOVERNOR VISION. AND YES
ARKAN TO FOCUS ON. ORDINANCE OF
AND- WITH THE FOR ON THE ALTHEA
STOOD GROUPS THAT ARE MOST IN
NEED. AND MOST OFTEN ARE. HAVE
STOMACH VARIOUS CHEATING. BOSS
UP THERE AND- ALLOW FOR QUESTION
. AT THE START OKAY THANK YOU
SIR WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU NOW
WE'LL HEAR FROM. AT KYLA JOHNSON
SURE MEL FROM THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. SHARE
DONALD J. R. MCCARTHY AN
HONORABLE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEMBER. MY
NAME IS DR CARLA JOHNSON THE
CROWDS TO. OPEN UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE IN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WITH TRENT
OF STUDENT ENROLLMENT
ABSENTEEISM IN OUR DISTRICT.
MICHAEL THIS MORNING IS THAT
CLEARLY ILLUSTRATE THE
COMPLEXITIES AND SUBSEQUENT
EXPERIENCED BY MY DISTRICT IN
MANY OTHER DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AS A DIRECT RESULT OF
THE CODE. NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. I DID UNIT DAY DOES
PASSED BY AS WEALTHY HERE FULL
OF DATA SUPPLY FACT DONE. MANY
OF THE COMMENTS I WILL BE WITH
YOU THIS MORE. OUR DISTRICT HAS
LONG ACTED AS A SEARCH CAN BE
SCHOOLS DISTRICT SINCE AROUND
TWENTY FOUR. ENSURING ASKED HAVE
CONSISTS ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION WELL FOCUSING ON THE
WHOLE CHILD. THIS APPROACH HAS.
SWELLED TO RESPOND TO THE COLE
AND DINNER. IN MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY WHEN THE PHYSICAL DOORS
ARE SCHOOL DISTRICT INDEFINITELY
CLOSED WE PRIORITIZE OUR
IMMEDIATE RESPONSE EFFORTS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY STUDENT IN OUR
DISTRICT ACCESS TO A LAPTOP. WHY
FIVE AND TECH SUPPORT. WE
PARTNERED WITH THE CITY
COMMUNITY AND PHILANTHROPY TO
LAUNCH OAKLAND AND DIVIDE IT AND
INITIATIVE TO GET DEVICES AND
INTERNET INTO THE HOMES THAT
EVERY- USQ STUDENT AND NEAT. WE
WENT FROM 12% 299% OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS QUIPPED WITH THEIR OWN
LAPTOP. INTERNET CONNECTIVITY.
WITHOUT THE EFFORT OF OUR WERE
HAVE HAD AN OP TAX LEARNING
YEAR- YOU SEE ALSO PROVIDED OVER
FIFTEEN MILLION MEALS TO OUR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES DURING THE
PANDEMIC BECOMING THE HUB OF
FOOD SECURITY FOR THOUSANDS OF
OPEN CHILDREN AND FAMILY. WE
ALSO OPENED SEVERAL IN PERSON
AND VIRTUAL LEARNING HELPS JUST
SEARCH CARPETED STUDENT GROUPS
ENHANCED ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT. WELL IT WAS
HAS IN THE CAR ENROLLMENT THIS
FROM TWO DECADES DUE TO A NUMBER
OF LOCAL ACTORS. BLASTED NEARLY
ELEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS THIS
CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR IS UNIQUE.
AND SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAVE DROPPED BY A
TOTAL OF ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE STUDENTS.
ALARMINGLY NEARLY ELEVEN HUNDRED
OF THOSE STUDENTS ARE IN GRADES
TKA THROUGH THIRD GRADE. AND 91%
OF OUR TOTAL ENROLLMENT LOSSES
ACCOUNTED FOR BETWEEN ATK IN
EIGHTH GRADE. A TOTAL OF ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN STUDENTS MEETING WE ARE
WITNESSING A DISPROPORTIONATE.
NUMBER OF EARLY LEARNERS. WELL I
PROJECTIONS CONCERT AND WE LOST
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED MORE STUDENTS
EXPECTED THIS IS A MAJOR LOSS
FOR OUR INVOLVEMENT. CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM THIS YEAR HAS NEARLY
DOUBLED SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC. AND THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR 71%
OF OUR STUDENTS SATISFACTORY
ATTENDANCE MEETING AT 210095% OF
SCHEDULED SCHOOL DAYS FOR
BETTER. AS OF THIS YEAR TO DATE
ONLY 47% OF OUR STUDENTS NOT
SATISFACTORY AND- DURING THAT
SAME TWO YEAR PERIOD- CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM JUMPED FROM 17% TO
NEARLY 30% MOREOVER CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM RATES FOR OUR TARGET
GROUPS HAVE DOUBLED IN SOME
CASES TRIPLED COMPARED TO OTHER
PEER GROUPS ARE LATINO AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER SPECIFICALLY MAKE UP
85% OF ALL SEVERE CHRONIC
ABSENCES IN THE DISTRICT. WE
KNOW THAT THE ROOT CAUSES OF
CRIME ABOUT CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
ARE MANY AND COMPLEX AND THESE
ISSUES WERE EXACERBATED AND
CONTINUE TO DO SO DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN ADDITION TO THE
EXTRAORDINARY WORK OF OUR SCHOOL
SITE ATTENDANCE IN COORDINATION
OF SERVICE TEAMS WE ALSO HAVE
RECENTLY RELEASED A TWO MILLION
PROPOSAL REQUESTS FOR PROPOSALS
TO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE THE
EXPERTISE RELATIONAL NETWORKS
AND CAPACITY TO LOCATE AND
SUPPORT. OUTREACH AND RE
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS OF OUR
STUDENTS. WE ARE NOT GETTING UP
ON ANY CHILD WE PLAN TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON PROVEN STRATEGIES
PROGRAMS AND INCENTIVES TO
IMPROVE ATTENDANCE- UST RE
OPENED ITS DOORS TO INCREASE
LEARNING LAST SPRING. WE WERE
ALSO THE FIRST LARGE URBAN
DISTRICTS TO BEGAN AND IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SCHOOL YEAR. THE IMMEDIATELY
PLANNED FOR BE EXPANDED LAUNCHED
A SEARCH WARRANT ON TRUTH
ECONOMY ARE INDEPENDENT STUDY
PROGRAM EVEN WITH SOME
CHALLENGES THAT THE TIMING AND
LIMITATIONS EIGHTY ONE THIRTY.
OVER ONE THOUSAND STUDENTS FROM
AROUND THE WORLD IN SG TEE
ACADEMY MAKING. HIGHEST ENROLLED
SCHOOL IN OUR DISTRICT.
ATTENDANCE IS ULTIMATELY
DETERMINED BY SUBMISSION OF
COMPLETED COURSE WORK RESULTING
IN INACCURATE EIGHTY EIGHT. THIS
COMPLEXITY IS FURTHER COMPOUNDED
FIRE DISTRICTS STUDENT VACCINE
POLICY TAKING EFFECT ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TO. A POLICY
REQUIRE ALL NON VACCINATED
STUDENTS TO TRANSITION FROM ONE
PERSON TO JOIN OUR TRUTH ONLINE
PROGRAMMING. THIS IS THEN WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ANOTHER
CHALLENGES. CHALLENGE BUT WE
OVERSAW. I ALSO SHARE THE INFO
OF THIS ONCE IN A LIFETIME
MOMENT WE ARE ALL EXPERIENCING
WILL BE FELT FOR AN ENTIRE AREA
. AND ARE PLANNING TO MITIGATE
CHASKA THE NEW REALITIES AT THIS
POINT WHERE THERE ARE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CONSIDERATION TO ENSURE THE
STRENGTH AND PROMISE OF
CALIFORNIA'S K. TWELVE SYSTEM.
MY FIRST SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE TO PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR OF HOLD HARMLESS AS THE
START OF A MULTI YEAR STOP
READING APPROACH. TO INCREASE
SPACE ALTHEA NINETEEN
ALTERNATELY MOVED FROM EIGHTY
EIGHT TO ENROLLMENT BASED
FUNDING SYSTEM. THAT'S WHAT
ENSURE FUNDING FOR OUTREACH
ENGAGEMENT AND SUPPORT STUDENTS
NEED TO ENROL AND REGULARLY
ATTENDS SCHOOL. MY ARGUMENT
INSTANCE BUT BASS MANY OTHER
LARGE URBAN WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE LOCAL FLEXIBILITY FOR
HOW WE COLLECT ABA WITH
INDEPENDENT STUDY AND ULTIMATELY
COLLECT REVENUE. YES I BELIEVE
WE MUST BE FOCUSED ON BOTH
MEDICATING OUR CURRENT
CHALLENGES AND EXPLOITING THIS
MOMENT DESTRUCTION TO REIMAGINE
THE FUTURE OF SCHOOLING. WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS A GROWING MARKET
FOR K. TWELVE ONLINE LEARNING
AND FOR MORE FLEXIBLE LEARNING
MODELS THAT PROVIDE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR WITH MORE
WORK BASED OPPORTUNITIES SUCH AS
APPRENTICESHIPS AND CAREER
PATHWAYS THAT PREPARE THEM FOR
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. THIS
IS A NATIONAL AREA AND TRUST
HIGH SCHOOL REDESIGN AND
CALIFORNIA CAN LEVERAGES MOMENT
BY INCENTIVIZING REDESIGN
NETWORKS AMONG SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. BACK
IN LEAD THE SECTOR AND
INNOVATION SUCH APPROACHES WILL
HELP TO RE ENGAGE STUDENTS AND
ULTIMATELY BOLSTER. IT IS. I
RECKON BECAUSE A PROVISION THAT
ON THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS MODEL
AND PROVIDES INCENTIVES FOR
DISTRICTS TO MAKE BAKER AND ARE
UNDER UTILIZED. FACILITIES
AVAILABLE TO ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES TO
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES INCREASING
DISTRICT REVENUE STRENGTHENING
CROSSSECTOR COLLABORATION AND
STREAMLINED AND INTEGRATED AND
EFFECTIVE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AND
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. IN CLOSING I WANT TO
COMMEND OUR STATE FOR HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS AND THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL STRATEGY MENTAL HEALTH
AND UNIVERSAL PRE K. AND
EXPANDED LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
ALL OF THESE ARE NEEDED MORE
THAN EVER TO MAKE OUR STATE
EDUCATION SYSTEM THE BEST IN THE
COUNTRY TO SUPPORT OUR FUTURE
CIVIC LEADERSHIP WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ECONOMIC EDGE AND
QUALITY OF LIFE. YES THIS MOMENT
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS SHORT TERM
AND FUNDAMENTAL LONG TERM
CHANGES TO STRENGTHEN OUR
SCHOOLS FOR ALL CHILDREN. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE WITH YOU THIS MORNING IT'S
BEEN A PRIVILEGE TO BE PART OF
THE SOLUTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SUPERINTENDENT- NOW.
GO TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR ANY OF THE FOUR. SPEAKERS ON
THIS PANEL. THIS REF. THANK YOU-
SUPERINTENDENT I'D LIKE TO ASK
YOU THE FIRST QUESTION SINCE
YOU'RE STILL UP ON OUR SCREEN.
ONE OF THE LAST THINGS YOU YOU
TALKED ABOUT- ON YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE IS TO USE IN
ROMANS TO THE ADA. HOW
SPECIFICALLY DO WE GET TO THAT
POINT HOW HOW CAN WITH THEM OW
CAN WE USE IN ROMAN RATHER THAN
A DA- HOW DO I MAKE THAT SWITCH. WHAT PART OF THE RECKONING. I
THINK THAT THAT'S MORE OF A
LONGER TERM CONVERSATION AND
THAT'S NOT AN EASY I'M SYSTEM
SWITCH TO MAKE- I DO THINK WHEN
WE LOOK AT THAT TOLD ME THAT
THIS CHANGE SHOWN SO ELOQUENTLY
IN TERMS OF WHICH PARTICULAR
DISTRICTS ARE NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. BY HOW WE FUND SCHOOLS
TENDS TO BE OUR DISTRICTS TO
SERVE OUR MOST VULNERABLE I'M I
THINK BEING ABLE TO HAVE SOME
SHORT TERM. AS STRATEGIES AROUND
HOLD HARMLESS TO PROVIDE
ADEQUATE TIME THAT THOUGHTFUL
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HOW TO MAKE
THAT. TRANSITION I WOULD BE MY
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU
ANOTHER YOU MEANT IS A SPECIAL
PROVISION SO SCHOOLS CAN USE
EMPTY BUILDINGS. ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT EMPTY BUILDINGS WITHIN THE
SCHOOL THE SCHOOL DISTRICT-
EMPTY BUILDINGS. OUTSIDE IN THE
CITY THE COUNTY OWNED. WHAT
BUILDING. WHAT ME- SCHOOL
DISTRICT I'M JUST SEEN THE LEVEL
OF DECLINING ENROLLMENTS- AND
NOW WE DON'T REALLY IN OUR
DISTRICT- HAVE BEEN UNDER
UTILIZED FACILITIES I'M BRINGING
INNOVATION IN TERMS OF HOW
DISTRICTS CAN BRING IN
ADDITIONAL REVENUE AND THINK
ABOUT MANY AT THE SERVICES AN
ORGANIZATION PARTICULARLY WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT THE EVOLUTION OF
MOVING TOWARDS A COMMUNITY
SCHOOL MODEL I'M REALLY THINKING
ABOUT FULLY ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DO THAT IS
CRITICAL AND YOU CAN'T DO THAT
WITHOUT HAVING THE SERVICES OF
MENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES I WENT
PREVENTION- AND THEN BEING ABLE
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAST
DISTRICTS SPACE- THAT MAY BE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT IT'S A WAY DISTRICTS
CAN BE REVENUE. AND MAKING SURE
THOSE SERVICES ARE CLOSER
PROXIMITY TO THE SCHOOLS. TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES. THANK YOU
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THIS CAR
WOULD BE YOU OR- ONE OF OTHER-
PRESENTERS. THE IT THE ABA
IMPLICATIONS- THE DROP IN EIGHTY
EIGHT- IT IS ARE CAUSING STEP
FINANCIAL PROBLEMS IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITHOUT A WITHOUT A
QUESTION WHAT ARE THE SHORT TERM
FINANCIAL- IMPLICATIONS AND LONG
TERM IMPLICATIONS AND HOW CAN WE
ADJUST. THE LCF OF FORMULA TO
SOFTEN THAT IMPACT DO YOU HAVE
SUGGESTIONS ON THAT. MAYBE MR
CABRAL FROM THE L. A. U.
DISTRAUGHT I CAN I CAN TAKE THAT
AND I THINK WE WILL TALK ABOUT.
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE IN OUR NEXT PANEL AS
WELL BUT IF YOU THINK I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE WAY
THAT THAT. WORKS WITH THERE
ISN'T IS BUILT IN A ONE YEAR
HOLD HARMLESS IN THE WAY THAT
ATTENDANCE ALREADY- AND HAS LONG
BEEN USED SO FOR THIS SPECIFIC
FISCAL YEAR- BUT WE DIDN'T
COLLECT THE PAYMENT DATA IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE COLLECT IT
WE DIDN'T DO THE SORT OF TYPICAL
EIGHTY COLLECTED BECAUSE
STUDENTS WERE NOT. IN THE
CLASSROOM SO FOR THIS YEAR
DISTRICTS ARE RECEIVING EITHER
AT THE HIGHER EITHER WHAT
THEY'RE ATTENDANCES THIS YEAR IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OR OTHER
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
ATTENDANCE SO THEY'RE PREPARED
TO MAKE A TENANTS LEVEL SO.
BECAUSE OF THAT THERE IS NO
SPECIFIC SORT OF COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RELATED IMMEDIATE
IMPACT TO SCHOOLS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THIS YEAR NEXT YEAR
THOUGH WHEN WE GET TO TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE NOW THAT YOU'LL BE
IN A SITUATION WHERE THE TWO
YEARS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO OR TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE ARE NOW AFFECTED
BY THE PANDEMIC AND IF
ATTENDANCE IS NOT RECOVER IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO THEN
THAT'S WHEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WOULD START TO SEE SOME OF THE
MAJOR REDUCTIONS SO THAT'S NOT.
THAT'S GOING TO BE A PART RIGHT
NOW WE DON'T EXPECT THAT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE IMMEDIATE EFFECT ON
ANY- ANY DISTRICTS SPECIFIC
HEALTH EFFECTS FUNDING AMOUNT-
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS IT DOESN'T
AFFECT BECAUSE CHARTER SCHOOLS
DO NOT HAVE THE WHEN YOUR WHOLE
TIME WITH. I DON'T BUT- THAT'S
MORE OF A MOVING FORWARD THIS
REGION IN TERMS OF HOW DO I DO
DO THE SOFT LANDING A TO GET AS-
I MENTIONED EARLIER WE ARE
PROJECTING THAT THERE WOULD BE.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
PROPERTY FUNDING THERE'S A
VARIETY OF THINGS THAT YOU COULD
DO WITHOUT PROPERTY FUNDING IF
YOU WANTED TO- TO PROVIDE MORE
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS ONE IS TO
JUST PROVIDE LARGER BASE
INCREASES WITH THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY PER STUDENT IS LARGER AND
THAT HELPS EVERYBODY KIND OF
SEAT INCREASES THE FUNDING EVEN
AFTER THEIR. ATTENDANCE IS
DECLINING. THANK YOU. I WILL IF
I MIGHT JUST ADD A LITTLE NAP
CON THERE ONLY AT SIX STATES THE
COUNTRY THAT USED AVERAGE
ATTENDANCE FOR AS THE BAY FOR
ALLAH STAY FUNDING RESOURCES
SCHOOL- CALIFORNIA KENTUCKY
TEXAS- BEAT THERE IS A FEW- AND
THERE ARE A ARE AMONG THEM THERE
HAVE BEEN A PRESIDENT ILLINOIS-
ACTUALLY WHEN TONY SMITH WHAT'S
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT SHIFTED
FROM AVERAGE THAT THE TENANTS
FUNDING TO ENROLLMENT BASED
FUNDING. ARE ENROLLMENT BASED
FUNDING IS BASED ON COUNTS TAKEN
A COUPLE TIMES A YEAR AT THE
POSTED DAILY ATTENDANCE THERE
ARE SOME PROS AND CONS FROM
THESE TWO DIFFERENT APPROACHES I
WOULD ACTUALLY SUGGEST THAT THIS
IS SOMETHING WORTH LOOKING AT
BUT IT REQUIRES SOME RESEARCH ON
IT MIGHT BE POSSIBLE TO LEARN
FOR EXAMPLE FROM THE EXPERIENCE
ABOUT KNOWING. ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED. AS THEY SHIFTED THEIR
APPROACHES. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU WE HAVE MISTER KILEY
AND THEN SOME MEMBERS BONTA IN
O'DONNELL KILEY. I THANK YOU I
JUST A QUICK QUESTION FOR MR
CABRAL I YOU MENTIONED THE
SCHOOL REOPENING GRANTS THAT
WERE PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE'S DELEO DONE ANY
ANALYSIS OF HOW EFFECTIVE THOSE
WERE IN- ENCOURAGING OR
ENABLING- DISTRICTS TO. RE OPEN
FOR IN PERSON INSTRUCTION.
NUMBER PROBLEM WOULD LOOK THAT'S
PERFECTLY I KNOW THAT- WE HAVE
NOT SEEN THE FINAL AMOUNT SO I
THINK I THINK GIRLS I'M NOT SURE
NAY DEPARTED THE DEPARTMENT BUT-
WE WERE TOURISTS. BUILT AN
AUTHORED BY MY THIRD JUST SOME
TIME. ENSURE THAT SORT OF THE IT
IF- IF THERE NEED TO BE SOME.
GRANT MONEY RECORD. THAT THEY'VE
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TO
ENSURE THAT THAT'S THE CASE WHY
I'M NOT SURE THAT THAT'S
HAPPENED WITH ME THAT WE. CAN
CONTINUE. YEAH BE GREAT IF WE
CAN GET THAT SORT OF AN- OF WHAT
THE FUNDS ARE. SIR OUT THE
PURPOSE OF GET STUDENTS BACK IN
THE CLASSROOM QUICKLY. OKAY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
. I THANK YOU SO MUCH I CAN JUST
AT ANECDOTALLY SHARE AS- A
PERSON WHO IS THE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER FOR ALAMEDA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND A NONPROFIT PROVIDER
IN OAKLAND WHERE ARE AMAZING
SUPERINTENDENT KYLA JOHNSON
TRAMMELL OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I WAS OPERATING IN THAT
COUNTY OF ALAMEDA- TO MAKE
COLLEAGUE AT MISTER KILEY A 100%
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THAT
COUNTY. I ENDED UP RETURNING TO
SCHOOL IN THE SPRING BECAUSE OF
THAT BECAUSE OF THE ACT GRANTS
THAT WERE PROVIDED THROUGH THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO AND IN
INCENTIVIZE SCHOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO DO SO- I JUST WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO JUST HIGHLIGHT SOME OF
THE TESTIMONY THAT WE HEARD FROM
OUR- FROM OUR PANEL HERE TODAY
AND ONE IS JUST TO RECOGNIZE AT
PARTICULARLY AT A SUPERINTENDENT
KYLA JOHNSON FROM AL- THE FACT
THAT OUR SCHOOLS DURING COVE IT
BECAME A HUB FOR FOOD SECURITY.
A HUB FOR DIGITAL CONNECTIVITY
AND ESSENTIALLY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH HUB CONTACT TRACING
PROVIDING VACCINATIONS AND
TESTING FOR WHOLE COMMUNITIES AT
THE IMPACT OF THAT A FROM AN
IMPLEMENTATION STANDPOINT ON ON
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS ARE TEACHERS ARE
EDUCATORS OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
PROVIDERS THAT IS SOMETHING I
THINK THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
UNDERSTAND FULLY FOR YEARS TO
COME. I AM ALSO INCREDIBLY
STRUCK BY THE DATA PLANE
PROVIDED IN THE C. C. E. REPORT
THAT SAYS THAT THE MENTAL HEALTH
EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC ARE
EXPECTED TO LAST NINE YEARS
WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THAT A. B.
THAT A LOT OF THE ISSUES RELATED
TO DECLINING ENROLLMENT HAVE TO
DO WITH OUR ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO MEET OUR STUDENTS WHERE THEY
ARE IN THE MOMENT THAT THEY'RE
IN RIGHT NOW WHICH BRINGS US TO
REALLY THAT FINANCIAL
PROPOSITION. THAT WERE PRESENTED
WITH WHEN WE HAVE WHEN WE HAVE
THE ISSUE OF OUR STUDENTS. AND
OUR COMMUNITIES RELIANT OUR OUR
SCHOOL. TO BE ABLE TO PRO CARE.
SERVICES AND MENTAL HEALTH
PUBLIC HEALTH PHYSICAL HEALTH.
AT THE END ACADEMICS WHILE ALSO
FACING DOWN THE IMPACTS OF A
PANDEMIC FOR WHICH WE ACTUALLY
DON'T KNOW. AT OVER OVERTIME AT
AND ALL OF THAT WE'RE PUTTING
INTO THE SPACE OF. OF HAVING
STUDENTS THAT. WERE COMING TO
OUR SCHOOLS WITH INCREDIBLE
CHALLENGES THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS I KNOW FOR INSTANCE IN
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
ARE WORKING FULL TIME JOBS AS
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHILE
THEY'RE ALSO TRYING TO DEAL WITH
AND GETTING THEMSELVES EDUCATED.
AND AT AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
COMMEND AS SUPERINTENDENT
JAMELLE IN PART IN PARTICULAR. I
FOR YOUR WORK MISTER CHANG FOR
YOUR CONTINUED AT FOCUS ON THE
IMPACT OF CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
OVER TIME AND REALLY ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO. TAKE TO HEED THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE PUT
FOR BEEN PUT FOR PARTICULARLY
AROUND AT RECONSIDERING THE WAY
IN WHICH WE- ARE PROVIDE OUR
FUNDING RESOURCES BY CONSIDERING
A MOVEMENT FROM EIGHTY EIGHT.
MODEL TO ENROLLMENT MODELS AND
ALSO JUST RECOGNIZING THAT AS WE
DO NEED TO THINK CONSIDERABLY
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR. OF HOLD
HARMLESS FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. I KNOW THAT OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN ALAMEDA
UNIFIED OAKLAND AND SAN LEANDRO
IN MY DISTRICT ARE COUNTING
EVERY SINGLE PENNY. I OF ONGOING
FUNDS THAT THEY HAVE AVAILABLE
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS WHEN THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING THE MOST
INCREDIBLE- THAT IT. IMPACTS OF
MAKING SURE THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE COMING TO SCHOOL READY AND
ABLE TO LEARN ON AN ONGOING
BASIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO MEMBER OF
DONALD- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRS
WANT TO COMMENT ON A QUESTION A-
A SUMMER REYES PROUD OF AND THAT
HAD TO DO WITH THE FUNDING AND I
THINK THE RESPONSE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WAS THE CORRECT ONE-
FROM MR CABRAL THAT IS BUILD
MORE MONEY INTO THE BASE. EVEN
MORE MONEY ON GOING MONEY COMES
IN DON'T SENATE IN NEW PROGRAMS
DON'T RECREATE THE CRAB ROLLS
CATEGORICAL BUILD IT INTO THE
BASS ALLOCATION UNDER THE LCF IS
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS ONE OF
THE REASONS WE'RE IN THIS- THE
SITUATION IS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
HAVING FEWER CHILDREN. HEY THERE
ARE GOING TO BE IF YOU WERE
STUDENTS GOING TO CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS SCHOOLS BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE HAVING FEWER CHILDREN. AND
THAT'S A VERY LONG TERM-
SITUATION WHICH NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. SO WITH THAT COMING
BACK TO YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- I JUST WANT TO
KNOW TO THAT AND WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THE SNACKS AND MR CABRAL
TALKED ABOUT THE STUDENT THAT
CLIFF IS- IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT-
EIGHTY EIGHT ENROLLMENT. WE JUST
HAD A PARTICIPANT EARLIER FROM
ATTENDANCE WORKS TALK ABOUT
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM ONE THING.
EARLY OUR KIDS RELATE TO SCHOOL
BLAME IT ON THAT. ROUGH MORNING.
YES WE ALWAYS DO. AND I GOT A
LITTLE NOTE SAYING FROM OUR
SCHOOL YOUR KIDS ARE TURKEY SO
TECHNOLOGY AT ITS BEST RIGHT.
AND SO IN SOME DISTRICTS OF KIDS
DON'T SHOW UP IN A CALL THE
PARENTS SHOULD FOCUS AND GET THE
KID IN SCHOOL ONE. BECAUSE THEY
MAY LOSE RESOURCES BUT TO THAT
CAN IS TO BE IN SCHOOL TO HELP
THAT COULD DO WELL IN LIFE. SO
IF YOU JUST FOCUS ON ENROLLMENT
WILL DISTRICTS GO AND HUSTLE TO
GET STUDENTS BACKIN SCHOOL. I
DON'T KNOW I WOULD THINK THAT
THEY THEY SHOULD AND THEY WOULD
NOW THAT'S THE MORALLY
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO FOR IT
FOR EDUCATORS AND I KNOW THAT
MOST DISTRICTS YES THEY DO USE
IN ROME AND SO. AS WE THINK WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT THAT GOING
FORWARD MAYBE THERE'S A MIDDLE
GROUND THERE SOMETHING- BUT-
YES- WILL CONTINUE NOW WITH OUR
NEXT- PANEL WITH A SPECIFIC
FOCUS ON THIS AND ROMAN CLEF
WHICH AS MR O'DONNELL THAT.
NOTED WAS IS JUST ARE YOU KNOW
OUR BIRTH RATES IN CALIFORNIA-
AS WELL AS- YOU KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE PANDEMIC
WHICH IS KIND OF AN ACUTE ISSUE
RIGHT NOW BUT I THINK WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON THIS FROM THE LARGE
PERSPECTIVE SO WITH THAT- NEXT
PANEL YOU KNOW PLEASE DON'T-
DISRUPT THE HEARING SO- THE
SERGEANTS CAN MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THE PARTICIPANTS- YOU KNOW
STOP THE HECKLING IN THE BACK OF
THE ROOM SO WITH THAT LET'S
PROCEED NOW WITH OUR PANELISTS
AGAIN LMAO- THICK MAT CINEMA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED. I HAVE. EVER
WHAT LEAD SINGER OF ANALYST'S
OFFICE GET MAKE IT HAD A THANK
HAND OUT. A VERY SHORT THAT'S
CALLED. BASED FUNDING SCHOOLS
THAT JUST A TWO PAGER THAT WE
USED TO HAVE TO WALK THROUGH ON
THE BASICS OF ATTENDANCE AND
TALK TO OUR- WE APART FROM
OUTLOOK ASSUMPTIONS. JUST AS A
POINT OF TO START OFF THE
CONVERSATION. I'M SO FIRST ON
PAGE ONE WE TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT- ATTENDANCE BASED FUNDING
AND HOW IT WORKS IN CALIFORNIA-
I THINK A LOT OF THIS HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED SO I'LL
KEEP IT BRIEF- BUT THE PRIMARY
FUNDING FORMULAS. FOR STATE
FUNDING FORMULA FOR SCHOOLS RELY
ON ATTENDANCE OUT OF THE WAY TO
ALLOCATE FUNDING SO THAT
INCLUDES- PRIMARILY WORK MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA. BUT ALSO OUR
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
FORMULA AS WELL. ARAMBULA THE
PER STUDENT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PER STUDENT GRANTS IN IN OUR
PERSON BASED CRIMINAL DEFENSE
IT'S REALLY. BASED ON THE YOU
KNOW PER AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE OR ONE UNIT ABOUT
AVERAGE. DAILY ATTENDANCE AND-
ON A STATEWIDE. AND WITH THEM.
BUT FIVE PER OF STUDENTS WHO.
ARE THERE'S A LOT OF NAY 5%
ATTENDANCE RATE SO DISTRICTS AS
THE- USUALLY 95% OF THAT AMOUNT
. I'M BUT BEEN MORE DISCUSSION
ABOUT INDEPENDENT STUDY I MEAN-
IN THE LAST YEAR BE OF THAT THE
ABOUT PER. FOR FAMILIES WHO DO
NOT WANT TO BACK TO THE
CLASSROOM- I THINK- WITH MENTOR
HERE THE HEARING BY THE THAT
ATTENDANCE CALCULATED IS BY-
THAT. TAKING THE ASSIGNMENT AND
WORK OUR WORK AT. FINE STUDENTS
AND CA THAT TO A TIE VALUE WORKS
OF EXAMPLE- THERE'S AN IDEA.
STEP BY WORTH WEEK WITH AND I
STUDENTS SUBMIT THAT. THAT'S HOW
THEY RECEIVE ON SO THERE'S A
VERY DIFFERENT APPROACH BUT
CONVERTED TO USE OF SOME OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. I'M SO THAT THAT'S
- HAS COLLECTED EVERY YEAR FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS I'M USUALLY
GOES THROUGH. THE SPRINGTIME
TYPICALLY IT'S LIKE APRIL
FIFTEEN THIRTY ONE WHEN
DISTRICTS STOP COLLECTING ITEMS
FOR FUNDING PURPOSES AND THAT'S
USED. TO DETERMINE YOUR
ALLOCATION AMOUNTS. THE IS A ONE
YEAR HOW MUCH OF I'M SURE YOU'RE
PER SCHOOL. NOT FOR BECAUSE THE
SCHOOL THIS IN THE WHOLE
HARMLESS. I'M ESSENTIALLY A ONE
YOU'RE OFFER IN CASE. I'M PARTY
FUNDING OF THE- GIVES. AND ONE
YEAR. TO PREPARE FOR THAT ARE.
THEY THEY KNOW WHAT TENANTS. AND
THEY CAN THEY CAN- START TO
BUILD IN THERE BUT IT'S A PLAN
FOR HOW THEY'RE GONNA TRUST
THOSE REDUCTIONS IN FUNDING.
DURING THE PANDEMIC THERE WERE
SOME OF. TO ATTENDANCE. SO IN
NINETEEN TWENTY. THAT THERE IS
EMERGENCY LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PASSED IN MARCH TO- TO ADDRESS
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THE
PANDEMIC. AND SO FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY. ATTENDANCE WAS
COLLECTED FOR TWENTY PURPOSE
ONLY THROUGH THE MONTH OF
FEBRUARY. SO ANY NINETEEN
TWENTY. EIGHTY MEMBERS ARE JUST
USING THAT UP TO. THAT POINT-
THERE WERE A FEW DAYS. AFTER IN
IN THE MONTH OF MARCH WHEN
STUDENTS WERE. NEVER STOP
CLASSROOMS WERE OPEN I THINK
THERE ARE TWO STUDENTS WERE.
STAYING HOME SO THAT THAT DATA
IS NOT CORPORATE SO TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY DATA- YEAH ONLY
GOES THROUGH FEBRUARY. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THERE WAS NO
TRADITIONAL EIGHTY EIGHT
COLLECTED- BUT THERE WAS NO
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENT THE
INSTRUCTIONAL- TIME REQUIREMENTS
WERE DIFFERENT DIED TWENTY ONE
SO IT WAS NO. WE'RE NOT SORT OF
COMPARABLE DATA FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. FOR FUNDING PURPOSES
DISTRICTS ARE FUNDED BASED ON
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY A
MONTH SO- SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
AND BEYOND FUNDING WE USE JUST
TO TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY MONTHS
TO DIRECT. OUR IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO OF THIS LAST PROJECT
FIFTY DIFFERENT YOU RETURN BACK
TO ITS PREVIOUS POLICY. OF
USING- ARE YOUR CURRENT YOUR OF
FUN TO DETER- YOU'RE A EIGHT-
BECAUSE AGAIN THERE WAS NO
CHEMICAL. INTO TWO ONE IT'S
REALLY YOU'RE LOOKING AT TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY DATA FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO DATA WHICHEVER IS
HIGHER SO. TO THE EXTENT THAT
DISTRICTS ARE BEING DECLINED
PENDANTS THIS YEAR THAN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY IT'S GOING TO BE
THE EIGHTY THAT'S USED TO
DETERMINE FUNDING. ON THE SECOND
PAGE WE HAVE- A CHART PICKED HAS
OUR OUTLOOK ATTENDANCE
PROJECTIONS AND I THINK WE USE
THESE LOOK MAINLY AT THE
STARTING POINT. FOR FURTHER
CONVERSATION SO THAT. YOU HAVE
A- YOU CAN VIEW OUR BASELINE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE AND I'LL TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. THE MAJOR
UNCERTAINTY AROUND THESE ARE RUN
THESE AND WHAT KIND OF ISSUES
WE'RE LOOKING AT MOVING FORWARD
IT'S WORK. HI TRACKING WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH THE TENDONS. UNDER
THREE MAJOR DRIVERS OF ABOUT-
THE CHANGES IN ATTENDANCE IN OUR
IN OUR OUTLOOK AND THOUGHT. IT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO JUST WALK
THROUGH ALL THE TALK ABOUT HOW
THOSE AFFECT ATTENDANCE OVER THE
LONG RUN. THE FIRST ADAM AS IT I
THINK I'M- MISTER DONUT
MENTIONED YEAH IT IS THE-
DEMOGRAPHIC DECLINES IN THE
SCHOOL AGE POPULATION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT. EXIST A PART OF.
THE PANDEMIC THAT. YOU'RE IN AND
IS DRIVEN PRIMARILY BY BY A
LOWER BIRTH THE CALIFORNIA I
BELIEVE WE HAD- YOU KNOW
DECLINES IN BIRTH. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
SO WE'VE SEEN A LONG STANDING TO
CLIMB. IN IN A MOMENT
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF BECAUSE
OF THAT. AND SO UNDER OUR OUR
FORECAST WE- WE CONTINUE TO
ASSUME THAT THERE'S GOING TO BE
A DECLINE IN THE SCHOOL AGE
POPULATION. AND I WILL RESULT IN
A REDUCTION BY. TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS. THE
FACT. COMPLY THAT IS MORE
UNCERTAIN PEACE AND I THINK A
BIG PART OF WHAT- EVERYONE IS
TRYING TO. ON WHAT WHAT WHEN
MEANS IN THE LONG RUN IS THE IF
I. OF THE PANDEMIC ATTENDANCE-
WHAT WE CALL ON PAN RELATED. IN
THE- WE DO KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
FOR TWENTY TWENTY WE DID NOT
COLLECT EIGHTY EIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE A- TWENTY TWENTY ONE A-
DATA. WE ALSO- I KNOW THAT THE
TIME TO WORK THINGS WERE. SOME
FROM. THERE IS NO STATE. A DATA
YET BUT THERE WILL BE SOME
PRELIMINARY DATA. RIGHT RIGHT
THE DEPARTMENT USUALLY MAKES
PUBLIC. IN LATE FEBRUARY. EARLY
MARCH. THAT WILL GIVE US A SENSE
OF STATEWIDE- EIGHTY EIGHT BUT
WE DON'T HAVE THAT YET WE ALSO
DON'T HAVE- STATEWIDE ENROLLMENT
OF PUBLICLY AVAILABLE- DISTRICT
HAVE COLLECTED IT BECAUSE
OCTOBER WITH THE FROM TO STATE-
BUT THAT'S NOT BEEN. CLEANED UP
BY THE DEPARTMENT AND IT MADE
PUBLICSO WITHOUT THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ANY SPECIFIC TWENTY ONE
THIRTY TWO- INFORMATION. TO GET
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHTY THE ONLY THING
WE HAVE IS. FROM THE PANDEMIC
STATEWIDE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IN MOMENT SO. LOOKING AT THE
DATA WE DIDN'T SEE A TWO AND A
HALF PERCENT DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT- WHICH IS MUCH BIGGER
THAN. DEMOGRAPHICALLY DRIVEN
DECLINES OF RECENT YEARS
TYPICALLY HAVE BEEN MORE LIKE.
YOU KNOW I TENTH OF A PERCENTAGE
POINT DECLINE- SO. WHAT WE HAVE
ASSUME THAT THAT IS A CRITICAL
THE NINETEEN RELATED DECLINE AND
WHEN YOU LOOK AT. THE IN HOME
AND THE CLIENTS THEY ARE IN.
ABOUT 40% OF THE DECLINE IN THE
MOMENT. COMES FROM T. K. AND
KINDERGARTEN. AND AGAIN THESE
ARE STATEWIDE NUMBER SO IT
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT REFLECTING
SORT OF STUDENTS. MOVING FROM
ONE DISTRICT TO ANOTHER BECAUSE
OTHERWISE IT WAS A SHOPPING
DISTRICTS- ENROLLMENT AND NOT IN
OTHERS. THE REFLECT THE OVERALL
JUST FEWER STUDENTS IN THAT
SYSTEM NOW. WE'VE ALSO LOOKED AT
OTHER DATA LIKE- PRIVATE SCHOOL
AND HOMESCHOOL ENROLLMENT- AND
PUT. THE LITTLE INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE ON MIGRATION-
IN AND OUT OF THE STATE. NONE OF
THOSE THINGS SUGGEST THAT EITHER
OUR STUDENTS ARE FEELING THE
PUBLIC SYSTEM. OR THEY ARE MORE
OUT OF STATE. SO ARE SOME
SENIORS THAT DOES. ARE PARENTS
WHO DECIDE THAT THEY DON'T. TO
PUT THEIR KIDS IN. A CAN OCCUR.
WHEN THEY WERE GOING TO BE A
PRIMARY- IN REMOTE. ON WE KNOW.
THE OCTOBER MOMENT THERE THAT WE
HAVE IS JUST. POINT TIME- DURING
SOME THIS. COURT YOU MILITARY.
YOU SEE HOW WHAT A MOMENT LOOKS
BY THE END OF THE YEAR THAT
THERE THAT WOULD. HEALTHCARE SO
WE'RE NOT SURE HOW MUCH LISTED
IN. CAME FOR ABOUT WHEN SOME
SCHOOLS OPEN THE SPRING BUT
THAT'S THE DAY THAT WE HAVE TO
OUR ASSUMPTION THERE IS. THAT
THOSE STUDENTS WHAT. ABOUT THE
EVENTUALLY COME BACK OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS HE WAS SORT OF
THE ATTENDANCE. RECOVER AS THOSE
STUDENTS COME BACK THERE IS AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION ABOUT HOW
BOSTON'S COMEBACK AND WHAT.
WHERE THEY ARE ARE THE STUDENTS
WHO DIDN'T GO TO KINDERGARTEN.
AND FIRST GRADE WHICH THAT MIGHT
LEAD THEM SIGNIFICANTLY BEHIND
OR THE COMING IN OF
KINDERGARTNERS JUST. SORT OF UP.
TO FIFTY ZERO. BUT OVER TIME OUR
OUR ASSUMPTIONS HERE ARE THAT
THOSE. THAT BUT THOSE SORT OF.
LONG TERM DEMOGRAPHIC TRENDS DO
CONTINUE AND THAT'S WHAT DRIVES-
EIGHTY EIGHT- BUT THE LAST PIECE
HERE IS- IS. THAT WHICH IN OUR
CHART HOUSE LIKE GREAT THERE'S
LIKELY BART AMOUNTS TO REFLECT
THAT IS THE- IMPLEMENTATION OF
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN SO. I'M AND. YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE CHART YOU HAVE
A- AS OVERTIME AT THE PRO. IS
PRETTY THEN. AND IN TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX. OUR PROJECTIONS
TENANTS GET TO BE A- BIT. OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY. THE PRE
CONDEMNING ABOUT BUT THAT'S
PROBABLY BECAUSE YOU. CREATED IT
- FULLY A- THIS. WALL GRADE AS-
IN. WE PROTECT AND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS. IF THIS IS SO
- IF YOU EVER MOVE TO GET FROM
THE CARS. FROM OUR OVER. I'M A
FUNCTIONS THERE ARE. CONTINUING
BUT- THE DEMOCRATS DECLINES- A
PERSON OVER SO YEARS- AGAIN IS
WHAT. WITH A BUT I THINK WE HAVE
TERMS OF WHAT WHAT WHAT CAN WE-
OR ABOUT TO TWENTY ONE. ONE
TWENTY TWO. WILL CONTINUE TO
MONITOR THIS INFORMATION ASAP-
INFORMATION CHANGES WHEN WE DO
OUR UPDATED OUTLOOK PROJECTIONS
WILL MORE CORPORATE EFFECT. I'M
GONNA STOP THERE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS WANT BUT
IT'S PROGRESS. SHE'S THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE A- LINDEN DR LINDA DARLING
. WAS TO BE ON A- THIRTY I THINK
I SAW. MAYBE AN ICON OF HERS ON
THAT SCREEN A SECOND AGO SO SHE
MAY BE READY TO PRESENT. SHE HAD
A HARD TIME OF ELEVEN THIRTY TWO
PRESENTS SO OF. IF I DR LINDA
DARLING HAMMOND IS ON YOU MAY
PROCEED. SHE'S PRESIDENT STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. CAN YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU OUR LIVE-
THAT'S TERRIFIC REGISTER HERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD
MORNING- DONALD SURE REGARDING
MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE IN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AS YOU SAID I'M
LITERALLY HAVE A PRESENCE THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION- AND I
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING. BOB
CLEARLY WE ARE AT AN INFLECTION
POINT. IN THE HISTORY OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THE STATE AND WHILE
IT IS A TIME OF ENORMOUS CHANGES
AND STESSES IT'S ALSO A TIME OF
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO REAP THANK
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM SO TRULY
MEETS THE NEEDS OF. CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN THE STATE- I WANTED
TO START BY- NOTING THE LONG
TERM TRAJECTORY IN THIS- IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS YOU KNOW
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
CALIFORNIA WAS A LEADER IN THE
NATION AND THE WORLD IN
EDUCATION. R. A. LONG SLIDE
FOLLOWED PROPOSITION THIRTEEN-
JOHN MERROW THE FILMMAKER CALL
THAT THE SLIDE FROM FIRST TO
WORST AND BY THE- TIME WE GOT TO
TWENTY TEN. A CALIFORNIA WAS YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE LOWEST SPENDING
ROSE TO CHEATING STATES IN THE
NATION WITH ONE OF THE HIGHEST
RATES OF- UP SHE PULLS. HER
ADMINISTRATOR TEACHER COUNSELOR-
AND SO ON AND IT'S BEEN IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
AND THE FORMER FIRST GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN AND GOVERNOR-
NEWSOME HAS REALLY BEEN CALLING
THE STATE CRAFT. IN REMARKABLE
WAYS AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
CAN OF THINK ABOUT WHERE WE ARE.
USED TO BE WHERE ALL WE WANT TO
GO ALL THE TOTAL FUNDING FOR
EDUCATION FROM ALL SOURCES
INCREASED FROM SIXTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS. IN TWENTY
ELEVEN TWELVE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR BILLION. IN. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO NEARLY DOUBLING.
IN JUST TEN YEARS OF THIS SIXTY
BILLION WAS ADDED IN THE LAST
THIRTY JUST THREE YEARS MOST OF
IT- IN THE LAST YEAR- WITH THE
IMPENDING CHILD CENTERED
SUPPORTS. THAT OF THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED THAT WILL
UNFOLD UNDER THE YEARS TO COME I
YOU KNOW ABOUT THESE THERE WAS.
YOU KNOW BILLION DOLLARS FOR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS FOUR BILLION DOLLARS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH. SUPPORTS NEARLY
TWO BILLION FOR AFTER SCHOOL AND
SUMMER PROGRAMS ANOTHER BILLION
DOLLARS IN SUPPORT FOR
ADDITIONAL SET A STAFFING. FOR
THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION FOR
UNIVERSAL MEALS ON TOP OF THE
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES IN THE LCS
FORMULA. I AND THE POINT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE IS THAT WE HAVE YET
TO IMPLEMENT. THESE INVESTMENTS
ARE OR TO FEEL THEIR EFFECTS. IN
OUR SCHOOLS SO IT'S GONNA BE
CREDIT WE IMPORTANT. THE COMING
YEAR AND THE YEAR TO COME THAT
WE SPOKE ON ALL INPUT. THAT WE
BRING THESE ARE. TO LIGHT WAYS
THAT ARE SUPPORTER OF CHILL.
FAMILIES EDUC AND SCHOOLS THAT
WE REMOVE. BARRIERS THAT MIGHT
STAND IN THE WAY OF SUCCESS AND
WE ARE MAKING HEADWAY IN
PROGRESS WE'RE BEGINNING TO
BUILD BACK BETTER- SO WE WANT TO
BE SRE THAT WE'RE- STRATEGIC IN
HOW WE APPROACH. THIS YEAR ALL
OF THE UNCERTAINTIES THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING THAT I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN HEARING ABOUT- THE
UNCERTAINTIES ABOUT ENROLLMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE OR NATIONAL
PHENOMENON- OF. FUNCTIONING
CALIFORNIA DECLINING BIRTH RATES
THAT WERE ALREADY UNDER WAY
STATE MIGRATION TO THE COST OF
HOUSING AS WELL AS THE PANDEMIC
SOME HAD THE ABILITY GROUPS- BUT
ALSO IN HOUSEHOLDS HIT WITH
INCOME AND SECURITY. SOME YOUNG
PEOPLE HAD TO GO TO WORK OR CARE
FOR YOUNGER SIBLINGS SO THAT
THEIR PARENTS COULD WORK. BUT AS
WE SAW AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
SCHOOL YEAR MANY FAMILIES WANT
TO RETURN TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT
ARE SAFE. WELCOMING AND
SUPPORTIVE SOMEONE TO RETURN
VIRTUALLY BECAUSE THE REMOTE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT IS ACTUALLY
WORKING WELL FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
BUT THE NUMBERS ARE GOING TO
DEPEND ON MANY VARIABLES
INCLUDING OF BOTH THE COURSE OF
THE PANDEMIC AND THE DEGREE TO
WHICH PUBLIC SCHOOL OPTIONS ARE
MADE APPEALING. TO PARENTS AND
FAMILIES. I JUST WANNA- AS I
MENTIONED BEFORE POINTS ARE
GOING TO MAKE- I WANT TO MENTION
THAT ALSO THE BILL BACK BETTER
ACT. WHICH HAS PASSED THE HOUSE.
WELL IT IS COMING TO THE SENATE
IN WASHINGTON DC I INCLUDES AN
ADDITION TO OUR T. K.
INVESTMENTS FOR THE COMING YEAR.
FOUR HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS IN
SUPPORT FOR STATES FOR CHILD
CARE AND UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL FOR
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS SO AS
WE THINK ABOUT HER MOMENTS WERE
THINKING ON THE ONE HAND. ABOUT
THE FLUCTUATIONS AND SOME TO
CLIENTS BUT ALSO THE VERY
SUBSTANTIAL ONRAMP. FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND UNIVERSAL TICE IN
CALIFORNIA AND FOR THREE YEAR
OLDS THAT WILL. BE SUPPORTED BY-
FOR FUNDS. AS WELL AS THE STATE
FUNDS THAT ARE ALREADY IN THIS
TO. ALTHOUGH YOUNG PEOPLE SWELL
WITH PRIDE LAST IN YOUR TO COME
. SO WHAT CAN WE DO- JUST ARE
FACED TO LET AS YOU KNOW WITH
THESE CHEN. TO ROMANS WEAR STAFF
. EVEN IN THE MIDST OF SHORE.
THAT MAKE. STAFF SO HARD TO FIND
DO WE CLOSE SCHOOL BUILDINGS
EVEN IF THAT EXACERBATES OUR
MOMENT PROBLEMS. BECAUSE
DISAPPOINTED PARENTS COULD LEAVE
. YOU AS WE EXPECT PRESCHOOL
ENROLLMENTS TO FIND WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THE PROBLEM BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE SHORT TERM ISSUES.
OF THE DESTRUCTION AND THE LONG
TRADITION. OF SUPPORTING
LEARNING RECOVERY AND DEVELOPING
A SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR ALL OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. SO
THERE'S SEVERAL THINGS THAT. ARE
ON THE AGENDA I THINK BUT TO DO
FIRST IN TERMS OF SMOOTHING THE
PATH. TO THE FUTURE- WE KNOW
THAT- IT'S- UP TO STATES ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY ARE FINDING
WAYS AS AS WE UNDOUBTEDLY WELL
TO SMOOTH. THAT PATH OF OUR
RECENT INVESTMENTS ARE PROVIDED
A SHORT TERM QUESTION. A WHILE
ENROLLMENT ADJUSTMENTS BECOME
CLEARER AND FOR THOSE DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE THE CAPACITY
INFRASTRUCTURE IS SOMEONE I'VE
TALKED TO A NUMBER OF.
SUPERINTENDENTS OF LARGE
DISTRICTS. WHO WOULD OF BE IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMMING EFFECTS
INCENTIVIZED TO CREATE THAT
EARLY ON RAMP TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
I THINK THAT I THINK IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO USE TIME
AND RESOURCES. STRATEGICALLY
RIGHT. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO.
USE THE HUGE OF ONE TIME. FOR
THE FEDERAL. AS AS THE STATE TO
ENABLE THE COHORT OF STUDENTS TO
CATCH UP AND ACCELERATE. WE'RE
ALREADY SEEING LEARNING GAINS
OCCURRING THIS FALL IN MANY
DISTRICTS- BUT IT WILL NOT WORK
FOR MOST TEACHERS TO LOOK IT UP
ALL THE GRADE LEVEL STANDARDS
AND MARCH THROUGH THEM. WITH THE
STRICT PACING GUIDE AND EXPECT
THAT TO WORK FOR MOST OF THEIR
STUDENTS. SO SEVERAL THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT FOR USING
TIME STRATEGICALLY. A ONE IS TO
REALLY FOCUS ON TEACHING THE BIG
IDEAS AND THE CONTENT AREAS AND
USING TECHNOLOGY TO LEVERAGE
GREATER LEARNING. LAST YEAR WHEN
THE PANDEMIC HIT THE LEGISLATURE
ASKED THE STATE BOARD TO DEVELOP
GUIDANCE USING TECHNOLOGY
EFFECTIVELY TO TEACH THE MOST
CRITICAL STANDARDS AND LITERACY
AND MATH. AND WE HAVE A JUST
RECENTLY SENT AN INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL THE SOURCE TO THE FIELD
THAT DOES EXACTLY THAT OUTLINES
THE BIG IDEAS IN THE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS OF RESOURCES FOR
TEACHING THEM. AND DOCUMENTS THE
BEST USES OF TECHNOLOGY TOOLS-
AND I'M ALREADY GETTING FEEDBACK
FROM EDUCATORS AROUND THE STATE
OTHER THAT'S HELPING THEM THINK
ABOUT HOW TO USE THEIR TIME.
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND THEIR TOOLS
MORE EFFECTIVELY. THE THING IS
THAT WE CAN CREATE A SENSE OF
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS. THAT MEET
STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE AND
ACCELERATE THEIR PROGRESS OF THE
BENEFITS OF HIGH INTENSITY
DURING ONE TO ONE OR IN SMALL
GROUPS ARE EXTREMELY LARGE ONE
TUTORS ARE WELL TRAINED- AND
THOSE CAN BE TEACHERS OR PARA
PROFESSIONALS. THERE'S A BIG
LITERATURE ON THIS NOW ON PAGE
FOUR OF MY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THAT I HOPE YOU HAVE. IN FRONT
OF YOU YOU CAN SEE THAT. WE HAVE
VERY SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE OF HOW
TO ACHIEVE LARGE GAINS ARE FOR
STRUGGLING READERS OFF FOR
STUDENTS WHO NEED TO CATCH UP IN
MATHEMATICS- FOR EXAMPLE THE
LAST TEN YEARS. EVERY DAY IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING DURING THIS
LAST YEAR THE PANDEMIC FOUNDER
STRUGGLING READERS DOUBLE THE
GAINS I ALMOST FORGOT TO THE
AVERAGE READER IN JUST A
SEMESTER. OF FOCUSED ATTENTION-
THERE'S A SPANISH SPEAKING. OF
THAT PROGRAM TO BE HANDLED
WRAPPED WHICH HAS HAD SO A PRESS
GAINS. A. I. R. SAID THAT IT
PRODUCED IN OF A MAN WHICH
RARELY SEEN EDUCATE FROM. OF ANY
. ARE WE- RESOURCES THAT YOU L.
LAST YEAR THE BUDGET. A TWO
POINT PROFESSIONALS. FOR THE
MORNING RECOVERY PROGRAM. I
ENCOUNTERED A THAT UNIVERSE SO
ALL JUST. CAN OUT HOW TO GET
PARA PROFESSIONALS AND TEACHERS
TRAINED UP TO VERY VERY
PRECISELY. PICKUP WHERE STUDENTS
ARE AN ACCELERATE THEIR
PROGRESS- AND WE I HAVE REASON
TO BELIEVE THAT THAT SB-
ENORMOUSLY SUCCESSFUL IN MANY
DISTRICTS ARE DOING THAT. WHAT
THEIR FEDERAL FUNDS AND WITH THE
FUNDS THAT HAVE COME FROM
WORKING RECOVERY FROM THE STATE.
WE ALSO CAN BE INVESTING IN
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL LEARNING IT
SUPPORTS AS MANY DISTRICTS ARE
DOING AS WELL AS MENTAL HEALTH
RESOURCES- AND WE KNOW THAT
THESE WILL IMPROVE BOTH BEHAVIOR
AND ACHIEVEMENT. NOT ONLY IN THE
MOMENT BUT OVER THE LONG HAUL OF
FROM THE RESEARCH THAT'S BEEN
DONE. AND SO WE- THAT'S A PLACE
THAT WE CAN INVEST THAT WILL
TRANSFORM LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS
IN SCHOOLS. AND THE LIVES OF THE
STUDENTS TO EXPERIENCE THOSE
PROGRAMS AND VIOLATE TO INVEST
INTENSELY. IN STAFF RECRUITMENT
RETENTION AND TRAINING TO
ELIMINATE TEACHER SHORTAGES
SUPPORT LONG TERM EXPERTISE AND
STABILITY. BOTH THE FEDERAL ARPA
FUNDS AND THE MAJOR INVESTMENTS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR. MADE LAST YEAR IN THE
EDUCATOR WILL. CAN BE USED TO
RECRUIT PREPARED FOR. PIPELINE
FOR HIGH NEED FIELDS AND SCHOOLS
TO BOOST CONFIDENCE THAT.
RECRUITMENT RICHARD BONUS ARE. A
CALL. WARTS TEACHER TO LOWER
SCHOOL. WHERE THEY CAN OFFER
EXPERTISE. AND ALSO MENTORING TO
NOVICE TEACHERS SO THAT THEY
BECOME EFFECTIVE THEY STAY. FOR
THE LONG TERM AND WE FOUND AND
JUST TO STUDY OF THIS PAST FALL
THE LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
THAT DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO STABILIZE STAFFING. HAVE
USED ALL OF THESE TOOLS AND
THEY'VE BEEN BUILDING UP THEIR
OWN HIGH RETENTION TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS- AND SETTING
THEMSELVES UP FOR SUCCESS IN THE
LONG HAUL SO THAT THEY WON'T
CONTINUALLY HAVE TO EXPERIENCE.
THOSE KINDS OF SHORTAGES OF A
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS ARE USING
ALL OF THESE INVESTMENTS AND MY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY I DESCRIBED
THE- SENATE ACTIVITIES OF LONG
BEACH UNIFIED. OF THAT HAVE PUT
ALL OF THOSE ELEMENTS IN PLACE
AND ARE MAKING GOOD PROGRESS.
WITH THE STUDENTS THAT ARE
COMING BACK AND THOSE THAT ARE
PLANNING TO COME ON BOARD IN THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD SPACE. AND
FINALLY BEGIN YOU SPACE
STRATEGICALLY- IN BOSTON THE
QUESTION OF DO WE NEED TO CLOSE
SCHOOL BUILDING BECAUSE OF
DECLINING ENROLLMENT BUT AT THE
SAME TIME. WE JUST PUT IN A LOT
OF OUR FUNDING FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS THAT WILL UNFOLD OVER
THE COMING YEARS A THIRD OF THE
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA WILL BE
ELIGIBLE. FOR FUNDING THAT
ALLOWS THEM TO CREATE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES HEALTH CENTERS ON
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORTS SOCIAL
SERVICE SUPPORT BEFORE AND AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ADULT EDUCATION
TO CREATE. A COMMUNITY. OF
PUBLIC. ABOUT WOULD- BENEFIT
FROM THE SCHOOLS BEING A TO
LEASE ADDRESS. JUST COMMUNITY.
ALLAH HELP PROVIDERS ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. THAT ARE FINE
THEMSELVES. OUT OF MANY MORE
COMMERCIAL VENUES THE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED LAST
YEAR TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE WILL ALSO
IDEALLY PLACED MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS. ONSITE AT SCHOOLS.
OFFERING GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL
COUNSELING ADVISING FOR STAFF.
THAT SPACE CAN BE WELL USED A
LEASING SPACE TO MENTAL EALTH
PROVIDERS COULD TRANSFORM ACCESS
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. WHO REALLY
STREETS DATEABLE BUSINESS
PRACTICES THAT ARE STUDENT
CENTERED- AND FINALLY REACH
SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
SUPPORT THE LEARNING MODELS THAT
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WATCHED. A
LOT AND I JUST WOULD KNOW THAT
WE CAN RECOGNIZE IN THIS MOMENT
OF THAT IT'S TIME TO RETHINK THE
FACTORY MODEL SCHOOL DESIGNS
THAT WERE CREATED A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO. AND USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT WILL
LEARNING MODELS THAT STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WANT OUR CURRENT
SCHOOL MODELS WERE REATED
DURING THE ERA WHEN HENRY FORD'S
ASSEMBLY LINE. WAS THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGY ONE BUREAUCRACY WAS
THE MODERN FORM OF ORGANIZATION
AND WHERE YOU EUGENICS DETERMINE
HOW TEACHERS WERE TO BE TESTED.
HOW CHILDREN WERE TO BE TESTED
TRACKED AND TREATED. THEY WERE
NOT PARTICULARLY DESIGNED FOR
CLOSE RELATIONSHIPS FOR TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY FORMS OF DEEP
LEARNING FOR ALL CHILDREN. OR
FOR EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND OUR
IRAQ EDUCATORS HAVE BEEN PUSHING
ON THE EDGES OF THIS INHERITANCE
SYSTEM. FOR A LONG TIME ABOUT
THESE ASSUMPTIONS OF THE OLD
MODELS ARE DEEPLY INGRAINED IN
OUR SYSTEMS THAT WE'VE
INHERITED. AND THEY DO INFLUENCE
THINGS ABOUT HOW WE ORGANIZE
CLASSROOMS STEPPING STEEP TIME
TEACHING TEXTBOOKS AND TESTING.
US SO WE'RE HEARING FROM A LOT
OF DISRICTS THAT WANT TO REALLY
REINVENT THE WAY THEY- OFFER
SCHOOLS A USING CHECK. OF FOR.
ALL ALL MORE AND MORE WHERE IT'S
APPROACH. OF WHERE THEY- FOR
EXAMPLE STOOD. BLENDING ALL OR
WITH A JOKE COURSES- ALONGSIDE
IN PERSON CLASSES AND OFFSITE
APPRENTICESHIPS AND INTERNSHIPS
ARE THEY MIGHT DO THOSE THINGS-
IN ONE DAY OR IN SEVERAL DAYS
OVER THE COURSE OF THE SCHOOL
WEEK. OF APPLYING THEIR LEARNING
IN MEANINGFUL WAYS CONNECTING
WITH STUDENTS IN OTHER SCHOOLS
ARE CONNECTED WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSES THAT ALLOW THEM
TO GET A JUMP START ON THEIR
COLLEGE CAREER- AND SO WE NEED
TO THINK FLEXIBLY ABOUT THE USE
OF TIME AND SPACE FOR LEARNING.
SO WE DON'T INADVERTENTLY MAKE
IT DIFFICULT FOR PARENTS OF
STUDENTS TO GET WHAT THEY NEED
FROM PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND WE GET
ALSO AT THIS MOMENT. DEVELOP
PATHWAYS TO THE FUTURE- AND
EFFICIENCY. BY ALIGNING EXCITING
AND EXPERIENCE ALL HIGH SCHOOL
PATHWAYS OF DUAL CREDIT COURSES.
OUT WITH CAREERS IN FIELDS THAT
ARE IN HIGH DEMAND SUCH AS
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND ENGINEERING
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES ALL TEACHERS.
INCLUDING OUR MUCH NEEDED
PATHWAYS TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION TO MEET THE NEEDS WE
WILL HAVE. FORTY KIDS TEACHERS
AND OF FOR THOSE THREE OR FOUR
YEAR OLD PRESCHOOL DOLLARS THAT
ARE COMING IN SO YOU CAN IMAGINE
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TAKING
DUAL CREDIT COURSEWORK AT A
PRACTICE YOUR PLACE BUT THAT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. TO BE
LEARNING AND EARNING WHILE
GAINING AN INITIAL CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT WHILE STILL
IN SCHOOL ADDING ANOTHER PERMIT
WELL IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
WORKING PART TIME AS A
SUPERVISED TEACHERS THEY-
EVENTUALLY WENT. HERE SHE IS
READY TO PLANNING A CREDENTIAL
THAT BUILDS ON THE STACKABLE
PERMITS IN A WIDE UNIVERSITY
PROGRAM. IT SHOULD BE POSSIBLE
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO PURSUE THEIR
PASSIONS IN A WIDE RANGE OF
PROGRAMS AND CREATE STRONG
VIABLE PATHWAYS TO THE FUTURE.
AND WE NEED TO USE THIS MOMENT
IN PART TO MANAGING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL SYSTEM A. THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO MARSHALL ARE
OUR- AND RESOURCES TO THAT
EDUCATION FUTURE OUR CHILDREN.
THAT IS SUPPORT AND SUCCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE DOCTOR
LYNN DARLING FOR ALWAYS IN A
FOR. TESTIMONY YOU VERY MUCH I
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO ON
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER. WHICH IS-
MICHAEL PHYNO CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AFFECT MATT MISTER FIND
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAJORITY LEADER AND
MEMBERS I'M MICHAEL FONG CEO THE
STATE'S FISCAL CRISIS AND
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE. YEAH
FACTUAL FORECASTED DECLINING
ENROLLMENT IS THE GREATEST THIS
FINANCIAL AND FISCAL- RISKS BUT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
YOU'RE EXPERIENCING MOSTLY
RELATED- AS WE DISCUSSED THIS
MORNING IS THE TOPIC OF
DECLINING AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE OR ADA HOWEVER ADA'S
INFLUENCE IN TWO WAYS FIRST BY
THE DECLINING ENROLLMENT IF YOU
WERE STUDENTS OBVIOUSLY THE
PEOPLE RADIATE SUCKING ARE YOU
CALLING ATTENDANCE RATES
SOMETIMES IS REFERRED TO AS
YOUR- ALL MY COMMENTS WILL FOCUS
DECLINE IN ROME. AS WHITES THE
CLIENTS IN A TENER RATE
THEMSELVES CAN BE GREAT LEGAL BY
ALLEN I'M SURE THAT STILL ENROLL
HER VEHICLE PROPERLY SIR MARC
SAID AND EIGHTY ATS MARC. WE CAN
EXPERIENCE IN THE CON A ROLE FOR
NEXT PERIOD TOM DICK AND IS NOT
NEW AS THE KNOW HIGHLIGHTED-
EARLIER. AND IS NOW A
ANTICIPATED. WHAT DO NEW IS IT
APPEARS TANK HAS EXCEL. THE RATE
OF. WE CAN'T GET MAKE IT 60% OF
OUR WERE DECLINE BLAST YOU ALL
ONE OF THE FIFTY EIGHT POUNDS IF
THE STATE AUDIT DECLINE. IN IN
ALL. LOWER BIRTH RATES APPEAR TO
BE IN FACTOR AS THE CHAIN IN MY
- AND IN THE HIGH THE LTO.
EARLIER COMMENT. BASED CAN BE
THE L. DO NOT FOR ALL. THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE MISSING STILL THAT WE
BELIEVE WE HAVE THIS FALL. EARLY
FALL TWO THOUSAND ONE ON A
ROLLING DATA TRY APPEAR TO
REFLECT ADDITIONAL. WELL
EXPECTED LEVELS OF RECOVERY FROM
LAST YEAR'S DRAMATIC IN MOMENT
WE KNOW THIS FROM OUR SURVEY
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION FOR
FIRST MONTH OF ATTENDANCE-
SURVEY DISTRICTS AND TALK WITH
HER. YEAH AS THE ELEMENT WE
DON'T HAVE A IT. USING VIDEO
AFTER ESTIMATES FOR THE NEXT
DECADE THE STATUS BAR TO HAPPEN
NOW BECAUSE OF CLOSE TO NINE.
WITH NINETEEN COUNTY LOSING THAT
ARE RIGHT. THAN THE STATE. OUR
MOST POPULOUS COUNTY LOS ANGELES
IS FORECASTED TO DROP BY
APPROXIMATELY 20% IN SCHOOL AGED
IN HOME. BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC
CARE A. EIGHT HARMLESS.
DISTRICTS WITH TWO CONSECUTIVE
YEARS OF ROBERT KLEIN'S AND NOT
YET FELT THE FISCAL IMPACT FEWER
STUDENTS. IT WILL BE IMPACTED BY
THE ACCUMULATED DECLINE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. QUICKFIRE TWO YEARS OF
DECLINE. WE CALL THIS THE
FUNDING CLIP AND IT'S BEEN
REFERRED TO EARLIER THIS
MORNING. IN OTHER COMICS. I'M
NOT AN ADVOCATE FOR SIMPLY
DELAYING THE IMPACT BY ADDING
ANOTHER YEAR HOLD HARMLESS BUT I
AM AN ADVOCATE FOR CHANGING THE
WORKERS TAKES ABOUT CLIP. LOOK
MORE LIKE A GRADUAL SLOPE AND I
THINK THAT CAN BE DONE
RELATIVELY EASILY. ON THE SHORT
TERM THERE ARE NOT FISCAL EQUITY
FOR THIS RESULTING THE DECLINE
IN ROME. WELL THE A. O. AND OF
FINANCE CAN SPEAK TO THIS WITH
MORE. THE STATE IS PART TO
REMAIN A PROBLEM I EIGHT ONE. WE
GUARANTEE IS NOW IN BY A
DECREASE. IN CASE LOWER. AS SUCH
MINIMUM CARE TO YOU GROW DESPITE
THE DECREASING EIGHTY EIGHT.
THIS PROVIDES THE ADMINISTRATION
A LEGISLATURE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
FIND EIGHTY A HIGHER RATES OR
INVESTING IN MITIGATION
STRATEGY. THAT SUPPORTS A
GRADUAL SLOPE. A FUNDING
IMPACTED A LOCAL LEVEL. AS
OPPOSED TO THE DEVASTATING CLIP
IT'S FINALLY FORECAST. I'M A
LONG TERM DEPENDING ON A VARIETY
OF FACTORS IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
EITHER PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
TESTS TO OR THREE BIG GOVERNMENT
GUARANTEE AND LOWER CASE WORLD
WOULD BE A CONSIDERATION THE
STATE LAW. THE FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS EXPERIENCING DECLINES
ARE SIGNIFICANT. BUT USE A
SIMPLE SCENARIO TO ILLUSTRATE
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LOCAL
REVENUE AND EXPENDITURES. IF AN
ALLEY A HAS A DECLINE OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO K. THREE
THREE STUDENTS HAVE A CLASS SIZE
OF TWENTY FOUR TO ONE. THE LOST
REVENUE APPROXIMATES. ONE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER TEACHERS TO
LAYOFF WOULD BE FIVE. FOR A
SAVINGS OF APPROXIMATELY. THREE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE THOUSAND.
ADD A FEW DOLLARS PER STUDENT
FOR SUPPLIES AND A POTENTIAL
EXPENDITURE SAVINGS WOULD ONLY
BE ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR JUST THIRTY
SIX CENTS FOR EACH DOLLAR OF
RUBBING LOS. THIS SCENARIO SEEMS
MAXIMUM THE BISHOP SAID BUT ALL
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY STUDENTS
ARE TO SAY GREAT SPACE YEAH AND
AT THE SAME SCHOOL. MORE
REALISTIC WOULD BE TO SPREAD
THOSE HUNDRED TWENTY STUDENTS
OUT OVER MULTIPLE BRAIDS AND
MULTIPLE SCHOOLS AND WHEN YOU DO
DOUBT THERE IS NO PRACTICAL
IMPACT. ON TEACHERS STAFFING
LEVELS BECAUSE THE LOSS OF ONE
OR TWO STUDENTS PER GRADE SCHOOL
DOESN'T SUPPORT. A REDUCTION IN
TEACHERS RESULTING IN PAINTINGS
ARE SAVINGS FOR EACH DOLLAR. OF
REVENUE LOSS. IN THE SHORT TERM
DISTRICTS WILL INCREASE THE
DEFICIT SPENDING AND DEPLETE
RESERVES ON THE LONG TERM
REDUCTIONS IN SUPPORT ANCILLARY
SERVICES WILL BE REQUIRED. IN
ADDITION TO REDUCTIONS OF DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS SUCH AS
TEACHERS INSTRUCTIONAL AIDES
COUNSELORS SETTLE. AS YOU
APPRECIATE THIS ILLUSTRATION.
OUR OR SIMPLE PRODUCT BUT NONE
THE LESS THIS ILLUSTRATION SHE
WAS VERY CONTRARY TO THE FUNDING
ENVIRONMENT WORKER WE HAD AND IT
MAKES LEAVES IT MAKES
CONFRONTING ARE THAT.
IMPLICATIONS OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT
FOR OUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. WHAT QUESTIONS SHOULD
YOU S. POLICY MAKERS ASKED IF
YOU CONSIDER SHORT TERM POLICY
DECISIONS. I HAVE SEVERAL THAT I
WOULD RECOMMEND THE FIRST IS THE
QUESTION WHERE ARE THE MISSING
STUDENTS. I'M HAVE WE SIMPLY
RECAP OF THE CHAIRS ON THE DECK
BOARDED A PANDEMIC FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED STUDENT ENROLLMENT. YOUR
QUESTION IS WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO ANSWER YET WE CAN SEE FIRST
LOOK AT THE DATA. THAT IS
TALKING GOES ON AND A DEEPER
DIVE- THEY'LL BUILD A DATA
DEEPER DIVE ANALYSIS. THESE ARE
DEFINITELY QUESTIONS YOU CAN ASK. AND ANSWERED. WHAT SHORT AND
LONG TERM FROM. NINETEEN AND
OTHER. WOULD SAFETY BURKE. THAT
WE STILL HAVEN'T ON. POTENTIAL
SEE OR BEEN CONFRONTED WITH. I
DON'T THE MOMENT. TO A GRAD SLOW
. WELCOME TIME. THE WHOLE. YOUR
LONG TERM OF THE BILL STANDARD.
PROVIDE HONDA UNDER THAT AND ARE
TRY TO. ANNEX TEAM. OF UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN BEING
AND- WHAT ARE THE ENROLLMENT
TRENDS IN THE PRIMARY GRADES
COMPARED TO OPERATE ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY WE ARE DEFINITELY
SEEING TRENDS VERY MEANING THESE
DIFFERENT BRAIN SCANS. IS THERE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. RESETTLEMENT ARE
FUNDED FOUR YEAR OLDS BEYOND THE
CURRENT TWENTY. WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR LOCAL
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IN A PLACE
IN OUR AREA AND CORRESPONDING
ENROLLMENT DECLINE. WE HAVE THE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ONCE
APPROPRIATE EIGHT. I THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER FINE VERY
INFORMATIVE AS ALWAYS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER AND
WE'LL TAKE QUESTIONS AFTER THIS-
NEXT BIGGER AND OUR NEXT SPEAKER
IS MANDY CORBIN ASSOCIATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE CINEMA
COUNTY OFFICE. OF EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING MR MCCARTY MISTER
DONILON COMMITTEE MEMBERS I KNOW
THE CARBON HUH SO ****
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE RURAL
HEALTH AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES AT THE CINEMA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY. I WAS ASKED TO
TALK ABOUT THE SYSTEMS WE'RE
IMPLEMENTING AND CINEMA COUNTY.
TO SUPPORT STUDENT WELL BEING
HOW THE SYSTEMS COLLECT DATA TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS EMOTIONAL
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND HOW
THIS INFORMATION MAY INFORM THE
CHOICES. MADE REGARDING FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE WELL EING OF
STUDENTS DURING THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACED. DUE TO
DECLINING ENROLLMENT. I BELIEVE
I HAVE THE BILL TO SHARE. THANKS
FOR BEING PATIENT- X. RAYS I'M
GOING TO GO ACTUALLY- FAIRLY
QUICKLY- MY SLIDES BECAUSE WHAT
WE REALLY WANT TO SHOW ALL OF
YOU IS ARE THE DATA THAT WE
COLLECT- I DO WANT TO GIVE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT- I KNOW
THAT ALL OF YOU ARE AWARE OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE- DISASTERS WE'VE
HAD HERE IN CINEMA COUNTY
MULTIPLE FIRES BLOOD COULD
NINETEEN AND NOW DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. HELLO WE EXPECTED
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. TO
DECLINE JUST UNDER 17% AND- AND
I BELIEVE IN THE LAST. TWO YEARS
WE HAVE THEM. SECOND AND FOURTH
IN DECLINING ENROLLMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO WE
WILL HAVE TO MAKE VERY CAREFUL
CHOICES HERE IN CINEMA COUNTY TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS ALMOST FULL
ON IT AND BEHAVIOR LEVINE. THAT
IS THE KEY TO STUDENT SUCCESS
AND OUR SCHOOLS- THIS CHEN
TALKED ABOUT THAT QUITE A BIT
EARLIER WELL WHAT ARE THE KEY
INDICATORS FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
LONG TERM AND I DO WANT TO
MENTION ON THE SLIGHTEST IMAGINE
I'M GONNA GO FAIRLY QUICKLY
THROUGH THESE FIRST ONES ON AT
THE BOTTOM OF THIS PARTICULAR
SLIDE THIS IS ACTUALLY DOES OZ
SIX KEY TAKEAWAYS AND BEAMS ON
FROM A STUDENT ENGAGEMENT SURVEY
THAT WE DO IN OUR COUNTY WHICH
I'M GONNA TALK ABOUT TOWARDS THE
END OF MY PRESENTATION. WHICH IS
YOUTH TRUTH- THIS IS USED IN OUR
COUNTY AND TWENTY SIX OF THE
FORTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARM IT
JUST UNDER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
SCHOOL SITES. SO IT GIVES US A
PRETTY GOOD- BROAD
REPRESENTATION. OF WHAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE THINKING FEELING
AND EXPERIENCING ABOUT-
ENGAGEMENT IN ATTENDANCE AND
LEARNING IN THEIR SCHOOLS. JUST
TO GIVE YOU AN OVERVIEW OF DATA-
YOUTH TRUTH SURVEY OF APRIL
2021406% OF THE STUDENTS AND
ARGENTINA REPORT CONSTRUCTS
OFTEN OR ALL THE TIME. ARE OVER
A HUNDRED- OBSERVER THOUSAND
STUDENTS ON THAT IN OUR COUNTY
REPORT SERIES WHICH IS THE GREEN
SUICIDE. WE ARE MUCH THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF FOR BOTH OF
US SO SUBTLE IDEATION AND ALSO
VISITS TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM FOR
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. 34% OF CINEMA
COUNTY STUDENTS BELIEVE THERE'S
BETTER SCHOOL ARTS PROGRAMS OR
SERVICES THAT CAN HELP IF
THEY'RE FEELING STRESSED UPSET
OR HAVING PROBLEMS- BUT ONLY 32%
OF STUDENTS REPORT HAVING AN
ADULT SCHOOL. ON THE A. PHILIP
THAT THEY CAN TALK TO I'M SORRY
FOR JUMPING AROUND HERE- THE
OTHER. DATA INSTRUMENT BUT I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT SO I
START WHICH IS- AN ONGOING. YEAH
I WAS TOLD WE USE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO OUR
STUDENTS- OFTEN THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH. TO HELP US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO OUR
STUDENTS AND THEN WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO MAKE INFORMED CHOICES
ABOUT. EXPENSES I THINK REALLY
THE REASON WHY I WAS INVITED TO
TALK SOME ABOUT THIS TODAY IS
THAT- SADLY I THINK WE'RE AHEAD
OF THE CURVE HERE IN CINEMA
COUNTY AND- STANDING HOW TO
MEASURE AND UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO OUR STUDENTS.
SWEETNESS I'M ACTUALLY JUST
GONNA SKIP AHEAD TO EARN BECAUSE
I WOULD REMARKABLE PEOPLE'S TIME
. SO IF THE COMMITTEE COULD
LOOK- AND I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
CAN SEE THE SLIDE- THIS IS A
SLIDE- BASED ON SO I START
INFORMATION THAT WAS COLLECTED
SO I START IS A- TWENTY
QUESTION- SCREENING DEVICE THAT
ACTUALLY WE'RE NOW ELECTRONIC.
ALL WE CAN SEE THE SAMPLES- IN
THE WAKE OF A DISASTER OR
ANYTIME WE WANT TO FAMILIES AND
STUDENTS- AND GET THIS WITH
THIS- SCREENER ANSWERED AND WE
CAN FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH OUR KIDS WE CAN. GET THE
INFORMATION BY CLASSROOM SCHOOL
SITE DISTRICT AND COUNTY WIDE-
THIS IS BEEN PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL FOR US- DURING ON. THE
LAST PART OF THAT. SO IF YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SLIDE- THIS
ACTUALLY HAS ABOUT A THOUSAND
RESPONDENTS- WE HAVE ABOUT 38%
OF OUR KIDS WE CAN NO RIGH OFF
THE BAT ESPECIALLY AS SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. AND DIRECTING
RESOURCES- AND MONEY- YEAH WE'VE
GOT 38% OF THE KIDS THEY'RE
THEY'RE DOING OKAY- BUT WE'VE
GOT. HALF THE KIDS THAT ARE IN
THE RED. AND SO THEN IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PIE CHARTS DOWN BELOW WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO OUR KIDS- WE'VE GOT
YOU KNOW HERE JUST UNDER 5% OF
KIDS ON THE RECORDING THAT IT
HAD DEATH. OF FAMILY FRIENDS
HERE'S- DEATH ABOUT PAT A WEIRD
AND ALSO ABOUT 5% ALONE THE IS A
- TO. DISASTERS HERE WE CAN LOOK
AT THAT WE HAVE 20% OF THESE
KIDS- ARE. ACTIVATED FELT
TRAPPED EARNED SO THIS GIVES US
GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO OUR KIDS. THIS IS
ANOTHER CHART WAS DONE RECENTLY
HI THIS IS A SMALLER GROUP OF
STUDENTS FROM ONE ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN WEST SENECA COUNTY AND
THAT WAS IMPACTED BY BOTH FIRES
AND FLOODS AND COOK AT NINETEEN.
ON IN REGARDS TO COULD NINETEEN
THIS PARTICULAR AYE TWENTY
QUESTIONS I START WAS ADJUSTED
TO INCLUDE THOSE QUESTIONS WE
WANT TO KNOW ABOUT IT- SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU LOOK AT. THE
FIRST ONE TO THE STUDENTS ARE
SCARED TO HELP LIST- DID YOU
HAVE TO EVACUATE THIS PARTICULAR
ON ELEMENTARY SCHOOL YOU CAN SEE
THAT 70% OF THE CHILDREN WERE
EVACUATED ON AND THIS AS I
MENTIONED THE QUESTIONS OF THIS
PARTICULAR SCREENER CAN BE
ADJUSTED. TO WHAT'S GOING ON- WE
COULD ADJUST THE QUESTIONS TO
THINGS LIKE SCHOOL CLOSURE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT WILL ALSO
FEATURE- THERE WERE PARTICULARLY
. CONCERNED IN OUR COUNTY ABOUT
SCHOOL CLOSURES ULTIMATELY OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS TEACHER
LAYOFFS. AND WHAT THIS WILL DO
TO THE RELATIONSHIPS OF THE
CHILDREN FEEL WITH THEIR SCHOOL
SCHOOL CLIMATE SCHOOL CULTURE.
SO THIS IS A VERY- MUCH SMALLER
GROUP AGAIN AND WE CAN LOOK HERE
THAT A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THE
STUDENTS ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED THIS HELPS US TO DIRECT
OUR RESOURCES AGAIN- I WILL SHOW
THIS PARTICULAR SLIDE DOWN FOCUS
ON THIS. FROM THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE. AND FOR ALL OF YOU
ARE THINKING ABOUT OUR ENTIRE
STATE- AND WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
OUR KIDS. SO THE SLIDES THAT I
JUST SHOWED YOU- WEAKENED AND
GEO MAP. THE DATA THAT WE-
DRAWDOWN BASED ON THIS
PARTICULAR INSTRUMENT. SO WE CAN
SEE THAT OF THE SCHOOLS THAT ON
THIS PARTICULAR SLIDE BASED ON.
WE'VE GOT A 100% OF THE KIDS
THAT HAVE SOME INDICATOR THAT
SEND THE BREAD- WE CAN LOOK AT
THE ONE SCHOOL AND I UP AND
REMOVE THE SCHOOL NAMES- BUT-
THE ONE A PARTICULAR CHURCH
WHERE WE DO HAVE SOME STUDENTS
THAT ARE FUNCTIONING AND AGREED-
BUT IF WE WERE. DOING THE DATA
FOR THE WHOLE COUNTY THEN FROM
WILL COUNTY OFF PERSPECTIVE AND
A PARTICULARLY FOR A LARGER
DISTRICT ARE LARGEST DISTRICT OF
SANTA ROSA CITY SCHOOLS ON THEIR
SUPERINTENDENT AND OTHER FOLKS
WOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AT WHICH
SCHOOLS HAVE. THE HIGHEST
INDICATORS OF NEED AND THEN THAT
HELPS US TO DIRECT OUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND COUNSELING
SERVICES PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT RESOURCES AND THEN-
THE PURPOSE FOR SHOWING YOU THE
OTHER CHARTS EARLIER WAS TO LOOK
AT THE QUESTIONS IN THE
INDICATOR SO WHEN WE TALK TO OUR
STAFF. ABOUT YOU KNOW FOR ASK
QUESTIONS FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT
TEACHER LAYOFFS WILL CLOSURE
THAT WOULD HEP US TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THAT JUST
STUDENTS OF THE TRIAGE TOOL
THOUGH I START TO GET USED FOR
ADULTS- IT IS ALSO IT'S AN
INSTRUMENT THAT'S BEEN USED BY
FEMA OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ON
OTHER STATES- PLACES AFTER
HURRICANES. SO IT GIVES US QUICK
INFORMATION SO THAT WE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT DIRECTING OUR
RESOURCES ALSO GIVES US
LONGITUDINAL. INFORMATION ON.
BUT I WANT TO TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT
USE TRUE- AS I MAY. THIS USED BY
TWENTY THREE OF OUR FOR DESTROY
- UNDER AND SCHOOL SITES. THIS
IS THE YOUTH TRUTH DATA IN PART
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY- OUR OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IS USING. OF OUR- MONIES THAT
YOU HAVE DIRECTED OUR WAY TO
OFFSET THE COST OF THIS FOR ALL
THE SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS AND
CINNAMON. WANT TO USE THIS
INSTRUMENT. THIS PARTICULAR YEAR
OF. WE SURVEYED HI JUST UNDER
TWELVE THOUSAND STUDENTS- SO
THESE ARE THE HERE AGAIN THIS IS
A INSTRUMENT THAT CAN. TO THE
SITUATION- I DID WANNA TALK JUST
BRIEFLY ABOUT A THREE SLIDES I
WANT YOU TO ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
DATA CAN BE. AGGREGATED AND THEN
RE AGGREGATE BY A GRADE-
ETHNICITY- SOCIAL ECONOMIC
STATUS- SO THESE ARE IMPORTANT
FACTORS THAT WE USE WHEN WE'RE
MAKING DECISIONS A PARTICULARLY
AT THE COUNTY OFFICE LEVEL ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO DIRECT OUR
RESOURCES TO ASSIST DISTRICTS-
SEND PERSONNEL ON OUT INTO THE
SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT THEM- SO THIS
PARTICULAR SLIDE SHOWS- BASED ON
CODE. HOW STUDENT CENTER COUNTY
OF THOSE TWO THOUSAND OUR
FEELING ABOUT- YOU KNOW THEIR
LIFE AND HAVING THOUGHTS OF
SUICIDE AS I MENTIONED ARE
COUNTY IS VERY HIGH-
STATISTICALLY COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL. AVERAGE OF STUDENTS.
IN A LOT OF SIGNAL. DISTRESS
RELATED- MENTAL HEALTH EMOTIONAL
HEALTH SLIDE ON MEASURES FIRE
IMPACT- STATE OR IS THAT- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE PREVIOUS SLIDE
HOLDEN- STUDENTS THAT ARE HAVING
SIGNIFICANT THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE
CASE BACK OVER THIS TWENTY
PERCENT FIRE IMPACT NOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENCE- CHILDREN HERE OUR
COUNTY WE'RE GOING ON NOTE FOR
FIVE YEARS NOW OF THINKING ABOUT
FIRES. STUDENTS AND WESTERN
CINEMA COUNTY FIRES FLOODING CO
THAT BEING OUT OF SCHOOL ON AND
NOW WE ARE FACING WE DID HAVE-
TWO HIGH SCHOOLS MERGED. IN THE
SUMMER COUNTY. HI A LOT ABOUT
AND FEELINGS ABOUT THAT DURING
DIFFERENT- TO EDGE THE- CLIMATE
BRINGS TO GET. A LOT OF
EMOTIONAL- OUR TEAM FROM THE
COUNTY OFFICE PROVIDES A LOT OF
SUPPORT AT THAT PARTICULAR
SCHOOL ON BECAUSE- IT COUNSELING
STAFF PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE VERY QUICKLY- AND
NOT STUDENTS. GO INSIDE THERE
AND WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE FUNDING THAT YOU HAVE
DIRECTED ON TO THESE SERVICES- I
JUST WANTED TO KIND OF WRAP UP-
WITH OBSTACLES TO LEARNING THAT
STUDENTS HERE ARE IDENTIFYING.
AGAIN WHEN WE ON THE OTHER. ON
PRESENTATION WITH THE EARLIER
PANEL TALKING ABOUT ATTENDANCE
AND ENGAGEMENT AND WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS AND HAVING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO FIND OUT WHAT THOSE
ARE AND WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO OUR
STUDENTS- THIS IS ANOTHER SLIDE
FROM YOU'VE TRUTH THERE ARE
THERE MANY DATA POINTS WITHIN
YOU THE TRUTH- BUT THESE WERE
THE ONES THAT I CHOSE TO SHOW
YOU TODAY. ON YOU CAN SEE THAT
ON. CINEMA COUNTY HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ON COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. SURVEY DURING
A SIMILAR TIME- FEELING ANXIOUS-
YOU KNOW. CAUSES THEM TO HAVE
DIFFICULTY WITH LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES. AND 20% HIGHER
THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE-
ACTUALLY DISTRACTIONS AT HOME OR
LESS- THAT THIS WAS MORE SO I
WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THAT JUST.
THAT EXCITED THAT STUDENTS FEEL
AND- I THINK JUSTIN'S THREE HERE
IN SUMMIT COUNTY AGAIN. THINKING
ABOUT THAT- IF AND MISTER FIND
WITH KNOWS THE EXACT STATISTICS
BUT I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
EXPECTED TO HAVE THE THIRD OR
THE FOURTH HIGHEST. DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS AGAIN JUST UNDER SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. IN SO BE MINDFUL. FOR
HOW WE SPEND OUR DOLLARS. AND
CONTINUING TO DIRECT THEM AT
THOSE KEY INDICATORS THAT I
START. BUT THE STUDENTS
INDICATED WHICH HAD TO DO WITH-
YOU KNOW FEELING BELONGINGNESS
AND HAVING A RELATIONSHIP. WITH
SOMEONE AT SCHOOL. WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
HOW WE DIRECTOR DOLLARS AND-
HAVING DATA. IS IMPORTANT DO
THAT- JOHN ANDERSON WHAT ARE
BARRIERS WATERS FEEL WORST
EXPECT ALSO HOW THIS FITS
EXACTLY FOR YOU- I WAS ASKED TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT IT. AND HIGHER
I APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DATA- I BELIEVE THAT
YOU WILL HAVE A- COPY OF THE
ENTIRE. PRESENTATION TO ACTIVE
ON THE ALWAYS HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT HOW ABOUT THE
WORK BEING DONE HERE IN CINEMA
COUNTY. REGARDING STUDENTS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I THANK YOU
MISS CORBIN FOR YOUR DETAILS
YOUR YOUR DATA- IN REALISTIC
PICTURE OF WHAT'S GOING ON OUT
THERE THANK YOU THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GO ON TO OUR- OUR LAST
SPEAKER FOR THIS PANEL THEN WE
WILL TAKE QUESTIONS. IS LAMONT
JACKSON INTERIM SUPERINTENDENT
FOR THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. THANK YOU SO MUCH SIDE
YEAH. YOU MAY PROCEED THERE
ABOUT ALL. CHAIR MCCARTY I AM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AS
MENTIONED- MY NAME IS DR LAMONT
JACKSON. AND THE CROWD INTERIM
SUPERINTENDENT. AT SPENDING A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND I
HAVE HELD MANY DIFFERENT ROLES
IN OUR DISTRICT. I INCLUDING
BEING A STUDENT OF OUR DISTRICT.
ARE GRADUATE- ALONG WITH BEING A
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE. A
CERTIFICATED TEACHER A PRINCIPAL
OUR CHIEF HUMAN RESOURCE
OFFICER. AREA SUPERINTENDENT AND
DIE. AND NOW THE MOST IMPORTANT-
ROLE I WAS PASSED TO- LEAD OUR
DISTRICT THROUGH- THIS AND
DAMAGE- AS YOU KNOW THERE'S ANY
UNIFIED'S DISTRICT IT'S THE
SECOND LARGEST DISTRICT. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A SERVING
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS- OUR STUDENT POPULATION
IS VERY DIVERSE- WITH UP ALMOST
60% OF OUR STUDENTS OF COURSE
BOTH ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED-
AND- TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDES LUMINARY. UPDATES IN
TERMS OF THE IMPACT ON ON THE
DAMAGE BUT I DO WANT TO START BY
SAYING THANK YOU TO CHAIR
MCCARTY. THERE ARE. DONALD R.
AND STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
BERMAN- UP BEING IN SCHOOLS. I
WANT TO GET THANKS TO OUR
LEADERS. WHO ARE TEACHERS ARE
CLASS APTAMERS OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR FAMILIES ARE INCREDIBLE WORK
THAT THEY'RE DOING DESPITE THIS
INCREDIBLE CONTACTS THAT THAT WE
ARE AND SO- I WANT TO SAY OUR
STUDENTS ARE SHOWING UP AND
SHOWING OUT. I THINK IN
INCREDIBLE WAYS AND AS WE HAVE
HEARD A TESTIMONY TODAY- WE HAVE
A GREAT- JOURNEY AHEAD OF US-
BUT I'M SO. HOPEFUL- IN IN THE
SUB THAT THAT WERE FROM MY LIFE
. AND OUR GOVERNOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IN TERMS OF OUR- DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS I WILL SAY THAT
THIS IS NOT A NEW PROBLEM AND MR
CABRAL MENTION THIS IT'S PAST
MONEY. I'M THAT. THIS IS NOT NEW
BY THE EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. IN THE SEVEN YEARS
PRIOR TO- THE PANDEMIC- STARTING
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. WE SAW
DECLINING ENROLLMENT- AND ON
AVERAGE- WE WERE SAYING LESS
THAN ONE PERCENT. IN TERMS OF
AVERAGE DECLINE. WHEN WE COMPARE
THAT TO OUR PROJECTED ENROLLMENT
HOWEVER DURING THE PANDEMIC- WE
HAVE YOU KNOW THIS PANDEMIC
CHATS LED THIS A PRECIPITOUS
DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT DURING
THAT TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL
YEAR- WE SAW ALMOST 3% TWO POINT
9% DECLINE. IN ENROLLMENT AND
AGAIN BAD MIRRORS WHY MR BRAWL
MENTIONED THIS TRANSLATED INTO A
LOSS OF ALMOST. THREE THOUSAND.
ARE LESS THAN PROJECTED. THIS IS
START THIS IS A STARK CONTRAST-
TO OUR- YOU KNOW HALF A PERCENT
DECLINE IN THE PREVIOUS YEARS. I
AM NOT YOU KNOW AS WE SAW
DECLINES ACROSS THE GRADES BANDS
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT WE
DID SEE A GREATER WINDS IN OUR
LOWER GRADE THAT WAS MENTIONED
AS WELL AS EARLY TESTIMONY. OR
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR- WE ANTICIPATE ABOUT ONE
POINT SEVEN PERCENT. DECLINE IN
ENROLLMENT- WHICH WHILE THIS
IMPROVES OUR- ARE MOVED FROM TWO
POINT NINE ALMOST THREE PERCENT.
IT IS LIKE NEVER GET AWAY HIGHER
THAN OUR HISTORICAL AVERAGE OF
THE. IN SUMMARY OF WHAT WE THINK
ABOUT THAT THE PANDEMIC. I HAS
RESET OUR ROMANCE- DECLINE
SUBJECT THREE- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW THIS IS WHY
THAT THE- HELP ARE LESS. I
DURING A PANDEMIC PROVIDED US
WITH US IT'S VERY UP FISCAL.
STABILITY TO CONTINUE SERVING
OUR STUDENTS- AND EXPANDING THE
THAT THE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR STUDENTS TO NOT ONLY RETURN
BY TO ENGAGE AND SELLER. SO FOR
THE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL YEAR- THE PHASING OUT OF
THE HOLD HARMLESS THIS COULD
MEAN I'M FOR OUR DISTRICT.
ALMOST FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS- IN OUR BUDGET- AND
WHILE THIS IS CERTAINLY IT MAY
SEEM AN SIX AND BONTA CONSOLE-
IN TERMS OF THE CONTEXT OF
DISTRICTS BUDGET- THIS REALLY
HAS AN IMPACT ON STAFF. IT'S
WERE BENEFITTED FROM THESE A ONE
TIME OUT. I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT
SENDING A UNIFIED HAS CHOSEN TO
IMPLEMENT MEDICATIONS- THAT W
KNOW HAVE HELPED TO ENSURE OUR
STUDENTS REMAIN HEALTHY. AND
SAFE AND DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND NOW THESE ACTIONS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS REMAIN IN SCHOOL- WHICH
IS WHY ARE WE ARE REQUIRING
UNIVERSAL MASKING INDOORS AND
OUTDOORS. I AS WELL AS- BAXEEN
REQUIREMENT. THAT WILL BE COMING
UP BY. STARTING OUR OUR SECOND
SEMESTER. FOR ALL OF OURS AND
STAFF ARE WE ABLE THAT THE ACTS
ARE GOING TO MAKE OUR SCHOOLS
SAFE- AND YOU KNOW REALLY GIVE
FAMILY'S COMFORT. AS THEY LOOK
TO RETURN TO OUR SCHOOLS. OUR
NEXT I WANT TO FOCUS ON OUR- A
DUPLICATE ACCOUNTS- IN THIS
PANDEMIC AT CERTAINLY IMPACTED
US I IN TERMS OF OUR
UNDUPLICATED NUMBERS- AND THIS
REALLY CAPTURES. OUR STUDENTS
WHO ARE LOW INCOME ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS ARE FOSTER YOU. AND
UNDER THE L. C. ABOUT A SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MAY RECEIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS- WHEN THEY'RE- I'M
DUPLICATE ACCOUNTS. ARE AT LEAST
FIFTY FIVE PERCENT- LICORNE
ROMAN UNFORTUNATELY ARE
UNDUPLICATED COUNT IS AT
STEADILY DECLINING. I DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR
ARE UNDUPLICATED ACCOUNT STOOD
AT FIFTY NINE PERCENT- FOR THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR WE ANTICIPATE- IT'S GONNA
BE AROUND FIFTY FIVE POINT SIX
PERCENT- THIS IS. WHAT THIS WILL
MEAN FOR US IS LESS FUNDING. I
TO SUPPORT OUR OUR GREATEST.
NEED STUDENTS. AND DURING THE
PANDEMIC- WE WORK TO ENSURE THAT
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS WORK BAD.
AND UNIVERSAL A MEAL- PLANS-
WERE IN. PLACE OUR GROCERIES
MORE AVAILABLE AND- THIS IS WHY
WE DID APPRECIATE THE UNIVERSAL-
MEALS SCHOOL MALES- BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT OUR OUR COMMUNITY IS
NEEDED S. AND WHILE THIS
UNIVERSAL ASPECT- OF SCHOOL
MEALS. MEANS THERE'S- NO LONGER
AN INCENTIVE FOR FAMILIES TO
SUBMIT THE FORMS NEEDED FOR US
TO TRACK OUR AND DO DUPLICATE
ACCOUNTS. WHICH IS CRITICAL TO
OUR LCS ARE FINDING IT SO- I
WANT TO ENCOURAGE US TO THINK
ABOUT THIS- AND SO THIS IS
CERTAINLY A TRADE OFF THAT WE
FACE- AND- IT'S CERTAINLY.
SHOULD BE COMMENDED- THAT WE
HAVE THIS POLICY- WE CERTAINLY
WANT TO URGE THE STATE TO
CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO
IDENTIFY- FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS- AND WE'RE WE'RE TRYING
TO THINK OF WAYS TO DO THIS SITE
WE DON'T HAVE. ANY CONCRETE
ACTIONS AT THIS TIME- IN OF OUR
- STUDENTS OR X. OUR COMMUNITY
IN THIS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER AS
WELL- THE DYNAMIC BUT I JUST
MENTIONED- ARE THE CATALYST AND
TO WATCH AND IT WHERE ARE OUR
ART STUDENTS GOING- THIS IS VERY
COMPLEX I THINK- AS AS BEEN MADE
IN EARLIER TESTIMONY. IN THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE CAN POINT
TO THE HOME VALUES AND THE COST
OF LIVING INCREASES- AND THESE
INCREASES HAVE BEEN SUBSTANTIAL
OUT WHICH MEANS THAT THERE ARE
LESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND YOUNG
PROFESSIONALS- TO LIVE IN THE
CITY- BUT BEYOND THIS- I WOULD
SUGGEST THAT SOME OF OUR-
ANECDOTES AND PRELIMINARY
ANALYSIS- THREE MAJOR CATEGORIES
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR DECLINING ENROLLMENT- THE
FIRST IS THE TRANSFERRED TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS- I THINK THIS IS
A- YEAH. THAT WE FACE-
PARTICULARLY- WHEN WE LOOK AT-
THE MANDATES THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE. AGAINST BALI- TRANSFERS
TO OUR- OTHER PRODUCTS ARE
BETTER AND THEY THE SURROUNDING
COUNTY. AND ALSO STUDENTS WHO
ARE TRANSFERRING OUT OF THE
STATE- ANY OF THESE- YVERDON AT
EACH OF THE DEPARTMENT MOMENT
YEAR OVER YEAR- THIS MEANS LESS
FUNDING- AND AGAIN. IT'S GOING
TO UP. FACE CHALLENGES ON US AS
WE LOOK TO MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL
PARTS OF THE- I'M FINALLY I WANT
TO. TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR
ROUTE RECOVERY PLAN AND- AT SOME
OF THESE COMPONENTS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER BUT- UP WE
HAVE PRIORITIZE LEARNING
ENRICHMENT- AND OUR INVESTMENT
IN EARLY EDUCATION AND MENTAL
HEALTH. ARE THE PAST THIS PAST
SUMMER- WE HAVE PROVIDED OUR
STUDENTS WITH THE DOORS LOCKED
I'M- AND WEBER ERRING ADULTS-
ARE. INTO A PROCESS THAT WE ALL
LEVEL OF SAN DIEGO. LOVE LOVE SB
A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH. TO
LOOK AT- LEARNING SUMMER
LEARNING AND ADDRESSING THE
LEARNING LOSS THAT MANY PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT AND THEN THE
ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
PREPARE STUDENTS ACADEMICALLY.
AND SOCIALLY EMOTIONALLY I TO BE
WITH YEARS- INCITING- OUTSIDE
ACADEMICS AT THESE ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES INCLUDED FORMING ARTS
CAMPS. ASK BRYANT'S AMPS AND
MANY STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN HOW TO STIR
UP FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME. HI
IN TOTAL WE SERVED UP ALMOST
THIRTY THOUSAND OF OUR STUDENTS
AND SAW A 15100% INCREASE IN
ENROLLMENT OVER THE BOOK NUMBER.
INSTEAD OF A UNIFIED I BUSINESS
WAS ONLY THE BEGINNING. A KEY
PRIORITY FOR US WAS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF UNIVERSAL
TRANSITION- AND ARDEN- THIS
UNIVERSAL TKA WAS. INCREDIBLE
AND WE- THE WORK OF WITH THE
LARGEST. EGGMAN AND THANK YOU TO
WATCH YOUR MCCARTY UPPER COMING
DOWN VISITING WITH US THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP TARGETS. IN
BENDIGO- WE'VE BEEN PLANNING
I'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTED A UT K.
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS. AND WE
LAUNCH THIS PROGRAM AND WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS ALL OF OUR
SLOTS AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS WERE
. AND DOT SO WE HAVE ABOUT-
ELEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN OUR A
UNIVERSAL T. K. PROGRAM AND-
CERTAINLY THIS HAS NOT- YOU KNOW
REDUCED OR ELIMINATED OUR HIGH.
AVERAGE THE IN STUDENT
ENROLLMENT UP BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
HAS- LINDA DARLING HAMMOND
MENTIONED. IT PROVIDES AT THE ON
RAMP UP OUR STUDENTS TO GET INTO
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM I HAD TO STAY
IN OUR SCHOOLS. AND SO- WE
CERTAINLY SEE A STRONG DEMAND IN
EARLY- LEARNING IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND DOES CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD
TO EXPANDING TO. MEET THE NEEDS
OF ALL OF THE STUDENTS ARE ARE
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND THAT WITH
FEDERAL FUNDS LIKE TO EXPAND
YOUR THREE YEAR OLDS TO PROVIDE
EARLY LEARNING TO ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS WHO WANT TO BE IN OUR
SCHOOLS- AND SO LOOKING FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING AND MEETING THE
GOAL OF OUR OUR STATE'S UTK GO.
I'M FINALLY- AS MENTIONED
EARLIER AND- THE SHORTAGE OF
TEACHERS AND CLASSIFIED STAFF
NEED TO BE. YOU TOO ARE
RECOVERY- AND WE HAVE.
ESTABLISHED ONLINE ACADEMY. WELL
BEFORE I ENDEMIC. OUR TO FIND
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO.
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF
RECEIVING A DIPLOMA UP THROUGH A
VIRTUAL ACADEMY AND- WE HAVE
EXPANDED THAT TO BE THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS WHO WISH TO REMAIN- OFF
CAMPUS OUT OR AT THE RETURN OF
LEARNING- YELLING THIS TO AN
ENTIRE SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS BEEN
CHALLENGED- AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A NEED FOR INDEPENDENT
STUDY- ONGOING. I'M PARTICULAR
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR BACK THE
BANDAID THERE THERE WILL BE A
NEED. OUT THERE WILL BE AN-
AGENT TRUMP AFFECT- AND
SUPPORTING. THIS IDEA- I WOULD
SAY I'M MUCH LIKE OTHER
DISTRICTS- WE ARE HAVING IT
ALLEN DEFINING. I AND LINDA
DARLING HAMMOND MENTIONED- WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT I BLINDS WE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH UCSD. ABWEHR WE
LOOK TO- HEY FOR- AND
INCENTIVIZE- OUR OUR STUDENTS TO
BECOME EDUCATORS I TO ALLOW THEM
TO GO TO A LOCAL UNIVERSITY- AND
ACHIEVE THEIR GOAL OF BECOMING A
TEACHER SO THE- ARE THEM. AND
INCREASE THE NUMBERS OF A
TEACHERS THAT WE CAN- FROM-
THERE ARE SOME AREAS WHERE THE
STATE AND IMPROVED IN EASE THE
BURDEN- TO OFFER INDEPENDENT
STUDY- WALLEM MAINTAINING HIGH
STANDARDS AND QUALITY OF
EDUCATION. AND ALSO- YOU KNOW
FUNDING PROGRAMS UP OR PER
TEACHER PIPELINES. I'M GONNA END
BY- THAT AS YOU CONSIDER
INVESTMENTS IN OUR CALIFORNIA'S
. STUDENTS ARE NEXT YEAR THAT
THAT WE REALLY CONSIDER. ABILITY
AT DANA BLOODY RIGHT IT'S THE
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE OR
NOT- THIS SENTIMENT WHAT MADE.
IT WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR US TO
TOP BUT THOSE DOLLARS IN OUR
FAITH FUNDING- AND ALLOW US TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS OUT MENTAL
HEALTH SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL
BEING I ACT- REAR. OP OP THANK
YOU SO MUCH. BUT THANK YOU ARE
SUPER JANET JACKSON VERY
INFORMATIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WITH THAT WE'LL GO TO Q. AND A
FOR THIS- LAST PANEL- FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I'M
GONNA START OUT WITH ONE ANSWER
IS FOR A MISTER FINE. ARE YOU
STILL HERE MR FUND. YES CAMPUS
SOME NOTES- BUT I CAN'T FIND
THEM SO I'M JUST GONNA SHOOT OFF
THE COVER. ARE YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE CLIP TO MAKE TURNING THE
CLIFF INTO A SLOPE. AS FAR AS-
THE FISCAL CLIFF WITH REGARD TO-
DECLINING ENROLLMENT- WHAT ARE
THE ALTERNATIVES FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. TO MAKE IT- TO
CREATE A SLOPE INSTEAD OF A
CLIFF. I IMAGINE. BUILDING UP
THE BASE WOULD BE ONE OF THEM
MAYBE YOU COULD COMMENT ON THAT
OR MAYBE SOME OTHER
ALTERNATIVES. TO CREATING THAT
SLOPE THAT YOU DISCUSSED. SURE
WELL I. SO THERE ARE SPECIFIC TO
THE TOPIC OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT- WELL ONE OF THE
IDEAS THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSION WITH WITH- VERY
STAFF- WOULD BE THE USE OF A-
THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE. OR
EIGHTY EIGHT. ARE FOR TEMPORARY
PERIOD OF TIME SIX FIVE YEARS-
SHOULD THE FORMULA WOULD LOOK
MORE LONG- THE HIGHER AT THE
CURRENT YEAR. SO THAT WE CAN
HELP I CANNOT FOR GROWTH
DISTRICTS. FOR THE PRIOR THREE
YEARS. ROLLING AVERAGE ABA. FOR
NEXT YEAR TWO TO THREE ABOUT-
CHANGE THE CLIFF TO. GRADUAL
SLOPE ARE BECAUSE THE PRIOR
THREE YEARS WOULD BE. NINETEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AS A
PROXY FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO S. AS MR
BALL OUTLINED EARLIER IN THE
COULD NOT PROCESS. THE REASON
FOR THE THREE YEAR AVERAGE IS WE
CURRENTLY USE THAT METHODOLOGY
ARCTIC TO COMPUTE THE ARTICLE
TODAY PEOPLE PERCENT EACH VISIT
FOR YOU AVERAGE IN PART TO
STABILIZE THE YEAR TO YEAR
CHANGES IN THE NUMBER. IT'S ALSO
CURRENTLY THE PROCESS BEING USED
TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL I
THINK THERE ARE MERGING SEA
FUNDING ALLOCATION. I DON'T
RECALL THE EXACT TITLE OF THE
FORMULA BUT. IT IS ALSO. USING A
YEAR AVERAGE. IS BEING ABLE TO
AT ON. IN OUR- GOING TO CALL TO
STAY. THEIR FUNDING THIS PERIOD
TIME AS WELL. ALL IT DOES ACOSTA
OKAY BUT AGAIN I'M TEST ONE OF
PROP NINETY EIGHT WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT IS LIKELY AFFORDABLE
THE REASON FOR THE TEMPORARY
COULD ALSO BE PART MORE
PERMANENT BUT THE REASON FOR THE
TEMPORARY WE WOULD SUGGEST MAYBE
FIVE YEARS AFTER TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN. ARE THE REASON FOR
THAT IS IT WOULD BUT IF WE LOOK
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YOUR FORECAST. AND IF WE AGREE
THAT THE PANDEMIC IS XCELERATED
GOT FORECAST- DAN. PROBABLY
ACCELERATED BY WITH ROUGHLY HALF
WHICH MEANS THAT OVER A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD. WE WOULD SHIP HELLO
MARK- NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO
DURING THAT SAME PERIOD OF TIME.
IS THE IMPLEMENTATION. OR
TRANSITIONAL CAN UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN ALWAYS
BEGIN TO SEE THE BENEFITS- ON
THE FINANCIAL SIDE IF YOU WILL
OF THAT INTERPRETATION. SO THAT
WOULD BE ONE IDEA WITHOUT
CHANGING THE ALSO YEAH- WE ALSO
HAVE. TO YOU KNOW HAS. VERY
SWEET CAN TO IT BUT- BUT SUCH
NEED COMPILE IS AVERAGE DAILY
TO- ADVERSELY TO THAT- THE IDEA
OF- NEED TO ROLL IT BASED ON WHO
WITH ALL THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS-
WHILE THAT'S WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION- THAT LONGER TERM.
AND SIMPLY MOVING TO ENROLLMENT
BASED DOESN'T SOLVE THE ISSUE
BECAUSE- BECAUSE THE CLIP THE
MAJORITY OF THE CLASS APPEARS TO
BE A LOSS OF STUDENTS NOT A
LOSS- ATTENDANCE- AND YES IT
DOESN'T SOLVE THAT IMMEDIATE
ISSUE SO THAT WOULD BE ONE IDEA-
THAT- FOR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE THAT- AND THEN
FOR A FIRM FOR MISTER JACKSON
FROM SAN DIEGO UNIFIED COULD YOU
JUST TALK TO US A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR ONLINE SCHOOL HOW
DOES THAT WORK AND STUDENTS- POP
INTO THE ONLINE SCHOOL THEN GO
BACK TO THEIR- TO THEIR QUOTE
UNQUOTE REGULAR SCHOOL HOW DOES
YOUR ON MY SCHOOL WORK IS A K.
TWELVE. TO K. TWELVE QUEUES TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. THANK
YOU ZERO DOWN OH I YEAH SO. I'M
WE HAVE- BUMPERS AROUND WHEN
STUDENTS CAN. ENTER AND EXIT-
THE ONLINE- OR WHAT WE CALL A
VIRTUAL ACADEMY. AND SO. I
STUDENTS. WHO HAVE CHOSEN NOT TO
RETURN BECAUSE OF- THE PANDEMIC-
WHETHER THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MEDICATIONS THAT ARE IN PLACE-
OR WHATEVER THEIR THEIR FAMILIES
DECISIONS ARE- WE HAVE STAFF. AT
THIS SCHOOL. I'M WORKING WITH
OUR OUR LABOR PARTNERS JUST LIKE
WE WOULD STAFF- ARE IN PERSON
SCHOOLS. AND THAT STUDENTS DO
YOU HAVE- SOME ONLINE. I THERE
ARE SOME- OPPORTUNITIES FOR. IN
PERSON CHECK INS IF THEY CHOOSE
TO DO SO. AND WHEN STUDENTS
CHOOSE TO RETURN THAT THEY CAN
RETURN TO THEIR- A SCHOOL OF
RESIDENT. I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
ASKED- THERE ARE STUDENTS TO-
SOMETIMES MADE SHOES OR CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES MOVED INTO PARTS
OKAY TO ME. I WOULD LOOK AT
THOSE ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS-
BUT GENERALLY WE LOOK AT GRADING
PERIOD SO THAT THERE IS-
ENTRANCE. AND EXIT INK- IT HAS
MOVED THEIR CAPACITY. THAN JUST
POPPING IN AND OUT. THANK YOU
OTHER QUESTIONS REMAIN IN A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MR KILEY. I
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION FOR-
THE- MS CORBIN- I WANT TO JUST
GO BACK TO THESE SLIDES ON.
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE WITCHER ARE
REALLY ALARMING AND- MAYBE
LOOKING AT THE ONE THAT IS- IT
CATEGORIZED BY COPE WITH THE
FACT COULD YOU JUST EXPLAIN THE
SIDE A LITTLE MORE LIKE WHAT
WERE THE STUDENTS ASKED EXACTLY
. IF IT'S LOCKED. YOUTH TRUTH
SURVEY AND WHAT IT ASKS IS- AS
RELATED TO. MOBILITY HAVE YOU
DURING THIS PAST YEAR OUR-
SUICIDE- THERE IS. OBVIOUSLY
IT'S OVER TIME AND THERE IS A
QUESTION ABOUT ARE YOU ACTIVELY-
I THOUGHT SINCE THE SIDE THAT'S
A DIFFERENT INDICATOR FOR US
CLEARLY AND WE DO A THREAT
ASSESSMENT THAT STUDENT- BUT
THIS SAYS THAT YOU KNOW FOR YOUR
OLDER JUNIOR HIGH AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TO IDENTIFY.
AFTER THEY HAD THOUGHTS OF
SUICIDE AS IT RELATES TO COME
THE NINETEENTH AND EARLY HELP
FOR US IS TO LOOK NOT ONLY AT
THE DATA PROVIDED BY USE TRUTH
THAT IS DONE ANNUALLY BUT TO USE
I START AT SCHOOLS THAT HAVE HAD
SOME TYPE OF CRISIS- HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED. BY DISASTER AND GIVES
US ON IN VERY FAST INDICATORS ON
BIG NOT SO WE DISAGGREGATE THAT
DATA BY STUDENT. SO THEN WE CAN
LOOK AT THIS QUESTION. THAT
VEHICLE SERVICES I DON'T KNOW
QUICKLY ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ON
THAT SURE THE CONCERN AS OKAY SO
STUDENT QUITS YES THEY CANNOT
OUR THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE ON THERE
AND JOHN HOW DO WE GET THEM IN
SUPPORT OF GREAT. SO WE HAVE.
MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT
REALLY BUT WE HAVE A MULTI
DIMENSIONAL WAY. STUDENTS ENTER
THREAT ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU
THAT'S HELPFUL AND JUST IN TERMS
OF THE SORT OF SIGNIFICANTLY
MODERATELY SOMEWHAT I MEAN HOW
IS THIS ASKED LIKE WHERE THEY
ASKED SHOULD WE BE ADDING UP 23%
PLUS 12% PLUS 11% FOR THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS WHO ABOUT ANY SORT
OF THOUGHT OF IT OR IS. THAT YOU
KNOW IS ONE SORT OF A INCLUSIVE
OF THE OF THE LOWER DEGREES OF.
CONSIDERATION WHAT IN SOME WAYS
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU WITH
THE CONCEPT OF ADDING IT UP I
MEAN WE SHOULD BE CONCERNED THAT
WE HAVE. IN FIVE AND SO IT'S
REALLY HOW FREQUENTLY ALL SIX
SUICIDE THIS PURPOSE. SO IS THAT
TWELVE LIKE 12% DOES THE 23%
INCLUDE THE TWELVE PERCENT- OR
WERE THESE KIND OF ASKED TO
SEPARATE QUESTIONS DO YOU
SIGNIFICANT THEIR- RIGHT THEIR
SEPARATE SO JUST LIKE ANY SURVEY
THAT YOU WOULD TAKE WE'RE ASK
YOU SOMETHING ON A SCALE OF. ONE
TO FIVE- THIS THERE WILL BE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO SAY SOMEONE
A CERTAIN NUMBER OF PEOPLE SAY
MODERATELY. AND A CERTAIN NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO STATE YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANTLY SO THOSE ARE
UNDUPLICATED RESPONSES ACTUALLY.
I SHOULD. THANK YOU AND THEN I'M
JUST A QUESTION FOR. AS
SUPERINTENDENT JACKSON WITH THE
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED ARE YOU
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES THAT YOU
ONE OF THE CAUSES OF REDUCED
ENROLLMENT IS- IS PARENTS WHO-
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH SOME OF THE
POLICIES THAT THE DISTRICT HAS
ADOPTED. I THINK YOU MENTIONED
ONE OF THE THAT STUDENTS ARE
TRANSFERRING TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE MANDATES
YOU HAVE WHAT MANDATES ARE YOUR
FRIEND TO. SO WE LOOK AT OUR-
ARE MEDICATIONS THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE WHETHER IT BE- TESTING-
WHETHER BE THE MASS MANDATE
WHETHER BE- PUSHING AND
ENCOURAGING. OF FOR VACCINE-
WHAT WE NOTICE IS THAT A LARGE
MAJORITY OF OUR FAMILIES. ARE
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT GETTING
SICK ON OUR CAMPUSES- AND TAKING
THAT HOME. I TO- FAMILY MEMBERS
OR L. AND SO. SOME SOME DISAGREE
WITH- YOU KNOW THE MASKING THAT
WE HAVE IN TERMS OF. OUTDOOR
MASCOT AND SO. THOSE COULD BE
SOME REASONS WHY CHOOSING TO
LEAVE. THANK YOU AND SINCE YOU
BROUGHT UP IN WITH THE OUTCOME
ASKING THAT ISN'T REQUIRED BY
THE STATE AND ALL THE STUDIES
I'VE SEEN SHOWN IT DOESN'T
REALLY HELP WITH STOPPING
TRANSMISSION OF THE VIRUS. BUT
YET YOU'RE SAYING IT'S CAUSING.
OFFICE FOR THE DISTRICT IS
YOU HAVE THE POLICY. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN WE LOOK AT-
YOU KNOW CODE IN KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE ONE OF THE THINGS
WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR NUMBERS
COMPARED TO MANY OF THE DESERT
STORM WE PAID ATTENTION. UP WE
HAD YOUR- RATES OF INFECTION IN
CASES- AND- THE SPREAD SO I
THINK- THE MEDICATIONS THAT WE
HAD IN PLACE- WE'RE DEFINITELY
KEEPING OUR OUR KIDS SAFE AND I
WOULD SAY. I MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES MOST OF OUR FAMILIES
WERE REALLY IMPRESSED WITH THAT
I THINK IT TO YOUR POINT- SOME
FOLKS TO SEND WHILE YOU'RE GOING
BEYOND THAT- AND SO I DON'T I
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE HARD DATA
YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SURVEYS AND SAY THAT. I'M I'M
JUST MAKING. A NOTE THAT SOME
PEOPLE ARE NOT HAPPY IN THAT
COULD BE A CAUSE FOR PEOPLE TO
MAKE A DECISION SHOULD CHECK OUT
IT. I SEE AND I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK OF YOU
AND EVERYONE IN THE DISTRICT
AND- I'M ALWAYS LOOKING TO LEARN
MORE THOSE DID YOU HAVE ANY
INORMATION SHOWING THAT THE-
OUTDOOR MASK POLICY IN
PARTICULAR HAS LED TO LOWER-
TRANSMISSION- I WOULD SAY.
SUGGEST THAT IT'S NOT ONE- A
MITIGATION STRATEGY BUT A
COMPREHENSIVE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES. SO I DON'TKNOW THAT
WE COULD WE COULD PULL OUT ONE
COMPONENT- AND SUGGESTS THAT. I
WILL MAKE NOTE THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE PAYING CLOSE
ATTENTION TO IS. ONE WE DO HAVE
THE REDUCTION OF OUR OUR CASES.
HOW DO WE- BACK SOME OF THE
MEDICATION. AND MAYBE NOT HAVE.
THE OUTDOOR MASKING SO THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE PAYING ATTENTION
TO OR- WE'VE HAD- MASKING FOR
OUR ATHLETIC PROGRAMS AND-
THINGS OF THAT NATURE FOLLOWING.
OUR PARTNERS- ARTS ARTS SCIENCE
PARTNERS AND OUR MEDICAL
PARTNERS. AT UCSD SO WE ARE
LOOKING AT THESE- MITIGATION
STRATEGIES TO SEE WHERE WE CAN-
BACK FOR EXAMPLE THE COLT FORTY.
I HAD OUR ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS-
YOU KNOW IS THAT MANDATED NO BUT
FOR CONTACT TRACING HAS BEEN
VERY BENEFICIAL. AND I WOULD SAY
IF WE LOOK AT OUR RATES- THERE
IS SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER AND WERE.
YOU KNOW AS I SAID THE SECOND
LARGEST IN IN THE STATE. OF THE
LARGEST IN THE COUNTY- AND WHEN
YOU LOOK AT OUR RATES. I WOULD
SAY COMPARATIVELY- THEY HAVE
BEEN REDUCED- BUT I. AGAIN GOING
BACK TO YOUR MAJOR POINT OF. I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE GET ALL OUT
ONE PARTICULAR MEDICATION I
THINK IT'S MORE OF A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE. OF
MITIGATION STRATEGIES. THANK YOU
. YOUR THIS BONTA. THANK YOU
CHAIR I BELIEVE THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR MR FINE AND JUST
WANTED TO GO BACK TO YOUR
HIGHLIGHTING OF THAT HAVE THE
COST OF THE OTENTIAL COST
SAVINGS I THINK YOU SAID THIRTY
SIX SENSE. OF SAVINGS FOR EACH
DOLLAR OF REVENUE LOST THAT IN
AN OPTIMAL STAFFING SITUATION-
MS PENNIES ON THE DOLLAR- AT OF
FOR EACH DOLLAR REVENUE LOST- IN
THAT KIND OF LIKELY MORE-
REALISTIC PERSPECTIVE WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT THE THAT THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS AT A LOST ACROSS
SEVERAL GRADES JUST TRYING TO
KIND OF SQUARE THAT- WITH ANY-
SUGGESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THE EMINENCE NOTION
OF NEEDING TO FOCUS IN ON SCHOOL
CLOSURES. AS THEY'RE LOOKING AT
IT DURING COLD ED AT AS THEY'RE
LOOKING AT AND TRYING TO BE ABLE
TO MANAGE SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET OUT LOSS IF
THEY ARE GOING TO BE FACING OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS AT I
THINK AT THE OUR SUPERINTENDENT
FROM SAN DIEGO INDICATED THAT
THERE ARE LIKELY GOING TO
EXPERIENCE A FIFTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT- I KNOW
THAT- SUPERINTENDENT KYLA
JOHNSON TRAMMELL THAT INDICATED
THERE WAS PROBABLY ABOUT A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR OR MORE
BUDGET DEFICIT THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE FACING SOUTH. THIS
TRIED IF- SPEAKS IF YOU COULD
SPEAKS. TO THE IDEA OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES RIGHT NOW AT THE MIDST
COALBED- IT GIVEN THE DECLINING
ENROLLMENT THAT PEOPLE ARE
LIKELY FACING IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND THE AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT A DOCTOR
DARLING HAMMOND LAID OUT WHICH
WHAT WE REALLY FOCUS ON MUCH
MORE INTENSIVE INTERVENTIONS.
FOR STUDENTS. NUMBER BONTA
REPLIED CALIFORNIA TIME OUT LIKE
A TEMPORARY CLOSURE DUE TO
QUARANTINE OR WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT- SUCH A REDUCTION IN
STUDENTS AND LOCAL SCRIPTED BABY
NO LONGER GOING TO OPERATE THAT
PARTICULAR SCHOOL SITE GOING
FORWARD. IN THE IMMEDIATE IN THE
IMMEDIATE MOMENT LOOKING AT
SCHOOL CLOSURE AS ONE AWAY TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE THAT LIKELY AT
DECLINE THE IMPACT. OF THE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT OVER TIME.
THANK YOU- ALL SO FIRST OFF I
THINK ALREADY THAT ANY SCHOOL
CLOSURE PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT DECISION BUT A
GOVERNING BOARD HAS TO MAKE THE
LOCAL DISTRICT- OUR SCHOOLS ARE
CENTRAL TO THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES- AND THAT'S
JUST A VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION
RIGHT WE DON'T. WE DON'T LIKE TO
MESS WITH BUS SCHEDULES AND BUS
ROUTES AND WE DON'T LIKE TO MESS
WITH HER SCHOOL BOUNDARIES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THOSE ARE ALL
VERY DIFFICULT HIGHLY CHARGED
ISSUES- LET ME SAY THIS I. IT I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT HE DECLINE
THAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW.
BILLS IN AND OF ITSELF THE
REASON TO GO CLOSEST SCHOOL ARE
IN A NEIGHBORHOOD AND SHE CAN BE
KIDS AROUND AND REDISTRIBUTE
BACK. IT MAY BE THAT THIS
DECLINE IS THE LAST. YOU'RE A
TEN YEARS OF DECLINE- AND THAT
WOULD BE THE CASE IN A NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS AND THEREFORE IT MAKES
FINALLY THE ISLAND IT'S PROBABLY
THE PERIOD OF TIME WHICH PUSHES
ON TO THAT CONSIDERATION- I.
THERE'S AN IDEAL PROCESS WITH
REGARD TO CLOSING SCHOOLS IF YOU
GOT THAT NUMBER ONE- I THINK YOU
JUST LOOK AT THE WHOLE DISTRICT
COULD NOT. BE A NEIGHBORHOOD
THAT WOULD APPEAR TO BE. ARM ALL
THE- TARGETED LACK OF BETTER
WORD TARGETED CLOSER TO YOU LOOK
AT THE WHOLE DISTRICT YOU
ANALYZE THE HOME NEEDS OF THE
DISTRICT INCLUDING- THE EXPANDED
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE BOARD
PRESIDENT- SPOKE ABA COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND OTHER THINGS OTHER
TYPES OF PROGRAMS- POTENTIAL
SPACE FOR- STAFF DEVELOPMENT-
EIGHT AND OUR TEACHER
CORPORATION I'M AT A LOCAL
LEVEL- BITS OF TYPES OF
PROGRAMS- OFTEN THEY'RE FIGHTING. FOR SPACE- YEAH THE OTHER
THING THAT I IS A TO CONSIDER
HERE IS WHEN YOU WHEN YOU.
STUDENTS AND CAN CLOSE A GIVEN
CLASSROOM. THAT PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITY WELL PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITY- TO FOR UNIVERSAL
TKO AS WE ARE EMBARKING ON THE
APP IT PROVIDES OPPORTUNITY FOR
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL WHICH ARM
WRESTLING DARLING HAMMOND
POINTED OUT- ON WITHOUT COMING
OUR WAY. ATTENTION TO THE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION PROVIDES
OPPORTUNITY FOR SPECIALTY
PROGRAMS ATTRACTED PROGRAMS ARE
STEM STEAM. ARE ALL TIGHT OUR
DUAL LANGUAGE IMMERSION ALL
TYPES OF ACADEMIC PROGRAMS THAT
I'M COULD ACTUALLY ATTRACT ALL
STUDENTS TO THAT SCHOOL AND SO I
THINK THE LOWEST IS ALMOST IN
LESS OF THE OPPORTUNITIES. THAT
A FEW OPEN CLASSROOMS IN WHAT
LIKELY BEING. ANY YEARS OF
IMPACTED SPACE- GRACE TO A
SCHOOL DISTRICT SOME OF THOSE
WILL BE INCREASED EIGHTY EIGHT.
SOME OF THOSE WILL INCREASE
ENROLLMENT SOME OF THOSE WILL
POSSIBLY PROVIDE A GREATER
OPPORTUNITY FOR- LEARNING- AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SERVICE- OUR
FOR OUR STUDENTS. OUR CLOSING A
SCHOOL YUP COSTS BECAUSE THE
SCHOOL ARE RELATIVE MINOR SAY AN
ELEMENT SCHOOL PROBABLY THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR A YEAR RANGE
BECAUSE THE BULK OF THE COST OF
OPERATING THE SCHOOLS WITH YOUR
TEACHING STAFF HERE STRUCTURAL
AIDS AND YOUR VARIABLE STAFF
ARMED AND THEY'RE GONNA MOVE A
STUDENTS RIGHT IF YOU CLOSE GOAL
EIGHT AND MAY HAVE SCHOOL AGE
KIDS TO SCHOOL B. AND C. THEY'RE
GONNA MOVE WITH THE KIDS TO
SCHOOL BEING C. AREN'T ZERO ONLY
SAVINGS IS OUR PRINCIPLE ON
OFFICE MANAGER I HAD TO STILL BE
ON THOSE ONE PER SAKE. FIX NO
MATTER WHAT THE SIZE OF THE
SCHOOL IS TYPE OF STAMPEDE SO
IT'S RELATIVELY MINOR THE
GREATEST REVENUE. POTENTIAL OF
CLOSE IS ONE YOU ENTER IT INTO
YOUR UP WHEN YOU. MANAGER
ENTERED INTO LEASE RIGHT. ARE OR
- IF YOU WERE TO GO THE WAY UP
AND- SELL WITH SIGNS ON OPPOSITE
THAT ONE TIME ONE TIME FUNDS
WHICH ARE. LIMITED IN WHERE YOU
CAN USE THAT WHICH ARE ARE WILL
BE A GETTING STARTING ON. I
BELIEVE NEXT YEAR WELL AFTER WE
CATCHING REAL BOB ARMIES THAT
SPOT. ALL SO I. HOPEFULLY I
DON'T YOUR- NUMBER BONTA L.
THANK YOU MISTER PRIME TO DIDN'T
. OKAY OKAY GOOD ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS YEAH MR MCCARTY YEAH I
THINK MISTER FINE SPOKE ABOUT
THIS BREWING BETWEEN GO BACK TO
MR CABRAL WITH THE L. A. L. ARE
YOU THERE AT YOUR- YEAH FROM
HERE YEAH SO DO YOU HAVE ANY-
RECOMMENDATIONS OR IDEAS HOW WE
COULD LOOK AT HOW WE DO EIGHTY
EIGHT IN CALIFORNIA. WITH
ATTENDANCE ISSUES RELATED TO-
ENROLLMENT AND ACTUAL ATTENDANCE
AND YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD I
KNOW YOU OF COURSE YOU MENTIONED
THAT THE HOLD HARMLESS THAT
WE'VE BEEN ZEROED IN ON FOCUSED
ON DURING THIS PANDEMIC BUT
GOING FORWARD. ANY SUGGESTIONS
OR RECOMMENDATIONS YOU MAY HAVE
FOR US. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I
WOULD HAVE MADE A FEW ISSUES
THAT I THINK HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED. I'M INCLUDING IT THE
BIG ONE BY US OF A NUMBER OF
MCCARTY I'M SO I DON'T WE I
DON'T. I DO NOT RECALL A TIME
WHEN THE STATE HOUSE- HAD IN
ATTENDANCE BASED R. OR SOMETHING
OUTSIDE OF AN ATTEMPTED
STRUCTURE BUT ONE CHANGE THAT WE
DID MAKE IN THE MID NINETIES
WITH TO- WE USED TO ALLOW FOR
IT. EXCUSED ABSENCES THAN
DISTRICTS FOR GENERATE FUNDING
FOR OUR KIDS WE MOVED AWAY FROM
THAT- AND TOOK THE PARTS OF
JUSTICE STUDENTS ARE NOT ACROSS
FROM THERE ARE COMING I THINK.
THE REASON WE HAVE OUR SYSTEM IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS
THAT WE DO NOT COLLECT PAYMENT
DATA. BUT THERE IS THE THERE ARE
OFTEN TIMES WHERE THERE'S LESS
ATTENTION PLACED ON GETTING
STUDENTS. ARE PREDICTIONS ARE
OFTEN STRUGGLING AND MAYBE HAVE
BEHAVIORAL PROBLEMS OR OTHER
CHALLENGES AND THERE'S A LOT OF
COMMITMENTS CONSERVE OUR GATE
KEEPING IN THE CLASSROOM SO I
THINK THAT IS A- CONCERN THAT
THAT THAT IT. WE HAVE WE DON'T
HAVE SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON
WHETHER TO MOVE TO ENROLL BASED
MODEL BUT WE DO. HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT A LOT MORE MOVING
AWAY AND WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS
WOULD BE. THE OTHER THING THAT I
BELIEVE WAS MENTIONED- IT IN
THERE IT MIGHT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
FROM- PRESERVATIVES WORKS IF
THAT. ARE WE RIGHT NOW COLLECTS
CENSUS WE HAVE EIGHT ONE DAY
YEAR OCTOBER CENTERS BASED MODEL
AND SO WE DEFINITELY WOULD NOT
RECOMMEND THAT YOU MOVED TO AN
ENROLLMENT BASED MODEL THAT.
ONLY LOOKS AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR ENROLLMENT AND PROVIDE
FUNDING BASED ON MODERATE USE
THAT CREATES AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE. THERE MAY BE IS AN
INTEREST IN GETTING STUDENTS AND
ALL THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR
AND THEN NO INCENTIVEFOR THEM
TO MAINTAIN STAY IN ROLE
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR SO YOU WOULD
NEED TO MAKE CHANGES. IN HOW YOU
USE THAT ENROLLMENT DATA IN
ORDER TO HAVE A SYSTEM THAT
WOULD CONTINUE IT COULD NOT HAVE
THE ARE SORT OF. A POTENTIAL
THAT THERE'S CONCERN THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR NOW THEN AT SOME POINT
YOU HAVE TO HAVE MULTIPLE POINTS
OF COLLECTION AND- THAT WILL
BECOME MOREADMINISTRATIVELY.
THE REQUIREMENTS FOR COLLECTING
OVER THERE WILL BE A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER PERHAPS WHEN YOU HAVE
RIGHT NOW- BUT THAT WOULD HELP.
OKAY ISSUES BUT I THINK I'M
GONNA THE ISSUE- I- MISTER
FINANCIAL- DIDN'T JUST HELP WITH
THE WHO THE DISTRICTS WE HAVE
HAD CHALLENGE WITH- PERSISTENT.
AND ISSUES BY COULD HAVE BEEN
CHANGED A LOT AFTER THAT WORK
FIFTEEN IN WROTE ONE YOU USE THE
VIDEO ONLY SEEING IS A KIND OF
AND OF STUDENTS IN OUR SYSTEM.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MAYBE A-
DIRECTIVE YOU IS IF YOU COULD-
WHY IF YOU COULD GIVE US MORE
FOR ABOUT THAT NOW. EIGHTIES
POLICY TO IN WHAT THE ISSUES
BEHIND OR AND HAPPENED BUT I.
THINK ABOUT ANY RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU MAY WANT TO GIVE US RELATED
TO- THE- ACTUAL ADA AND ROMAN
GOING FORWARD SELF YOU CAN COME
BACKTO US IN THE FUTURE. THEN I
WANTED TO ASK I KNOW FIRST WHAT
WE'RE TALKING A LOT ABOUT
DISTRICTS AND FINANCES BUT I
DON'T WANNA LOSE TRACK ON. TRACK
AT WHAT THIS MEANS TO OUR- SO.
NO KIDS IN OUR SCHOOLS. IN WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS
PANDEMIC AND- YOU KNOW AS MR
O'DONNELL TALK ABOUT. I HAVE
HERE AND I'M CERTAIN THE SPOT
BONTA AS WELL WE HAVE KIDS WHO
ARE GOING THROUGH THIS- SOME
KIDS ARE DOING. BETTER THAN
OTHERS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA SO.
WE KNOW WE KNOW THIS AND WE HEAR
FROM OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SO
WE DID. PUT A LOT OF MONEY TWO
YEARS AGO. INTO A LEARNING LOS
BLOCK GRANT TO HELP THESE
STUDENTS WHETHER IT'S- GETTING
OVER THIS IN SEVERAL MONTHS OR
MAYBE SEVERAL YEARS FOR SUN.
KIDS TO REALLY- BOUNCE BACK. AND
SO WHAT ARE SOME OF THE BARRIERS
IN ALL THIS MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
ONE TIME MONEY WE'VE GIVEN TO
DISTRICTS FOR EXAMPLE WE HEAR A
LOT THAT DISTRICTS CAN'T USE ONE
TIME MONEY FOR ONGOING PERSONNEL
IS NOT GOOD BUDGETING TO HIRE
PEOPLE WHEN YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THE PEOPLE YOU'RE TWO DOWN
THE ROAD. BUT IF WE'RE TALKING
CPAS DOT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT LIKE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES- WHAT
BARRIERS ARE THERE TO HAVE A
DISTRICT LET'S SAY CONTRACT WITH
SUTTER HEALTH OR KAISER SOME
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONER TO
COME IN AND DO WORK FOR A PERIOD
OF TIME AS OPPOSED TO HIRING
MORE INDIVIDUALS- I I'M NOT SURE
THAT WERE. THAT WERE REALLY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF. THEIR
REVENUES THAT WE PUT ON THE
TABLE FOR DISTRICTS TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE WANTED TO DO TO
MOST IMPORTANTLY. MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR KIDS. YES I THINK
THAT OTHER IMPORTANT BECAUSE I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THAT
THAT IS NOT. A BIG ISSUE OVERALL
WHEN YOU SEE THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING IN THE SYSTEM THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY A
LOT OF IT IS ONE TIME FUNDING. I
THINK I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING IN PARTICULAR IS
HAS A THREE YEAR. WINDOW FOR
SPENDING SO I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT DISTRICTS WITH A
GUY THIS IS NOT WHICH ONE TIME
FUNDING THAT'S NOT WE'RE GONNA
USE ALL THIS MONEY IN ONE
PARTICULAR YEAR WE WANT TO.
SPREAD IT OUT TO THE DEGREE
POSSIBLE. I'M M. I THINK YOU
KNOW WE PUT A CLEAR PATH YEAR IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THOSE ARE THE
COMPANY BE PROVIDED. A LOT OF
STUDENTS WEREN'T EVEN IN THE
CLASSROOM SO IT MAKES SENSE FOR
YOU. FOR EXAMPLE. WE'RE GOING TO
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PLAN FOR HOW
TO. USE THAT FUNDING I THINK THE
ISSUE THAT YOU KNOW YOU READING-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY ABOUT
HOW TO SPEND ONE TIME FUNDING OF
THE CHALLENGING ONE THAT WE'VE
GOT THAT TYPICALLY ABOUT THE
GUIDANCE THE BEST PRACTICES DO
NOT USE- ONE TIME FUNDING FOR.
AMONG WORK PURPOSES DO NOT USE
IT TO HIR. NEW STAFF- AND THAT
DAVID DEFINITELY AN ISSUE WHERE
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
EITHER WHAT HAPPENED EXPIRES YOU
STOCK WHICH- MEANS THAT YOU HAVE
A DECLINE IN YOUR PROGRAM AND-
YOU MIGHT WANT TO. MAINTAIN THE
STAFF FROM OVER THE LONG RUN TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OR YOU CONTINUE
TO KEEP THAT STAFF ARE ON AND
YOU HAVE TO SCHOOL JONES IS THE
RESULT. WITH THE VOLUME OF
FEDERAL FUNDING AVAILABLE I
CAN'T IMAGINE THAT DISTRICTS ARE
FINDING TECHNOLOGY PURCHASES AND
OTHER ONE TIME WE WRITE CONCRETE
PIER ONE TIME ACTIVITY THAT CAN
BE SPENT WITH ALL THE FEDERAL
FUNDING. REALISTICALLY IF YOU
WANT THEM TO DO TO HELP THEIR
KIDS THEY'RE NEEDING TO HIRE-
STOP OR THE NEED TO CONTRACT OUT
WITH OTHERS SO THAT THE DOCTOR
CHANDRA DILEMMA THAT THEY'RE
FACING RIGHT NOW. I'M WE ARE IN
OUR FISCAL OUTLOOK- A REPORT
THAT WE PUT OUT WE DID MAKE A
NUMBER OF SUGGESTIONS FOR WHAT
THE LIST THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT MOVING FORWARD. ONE
THING THAT WE THOUGHT WE.
SUGGESTED IS- NEXT YEAR GIVE THE
AMOUNT OF I JUST. ON WHAT. TO
BUILD TO START SOME OF THAT.
FIVE IS. AN OP. TO YOUPROPERTY
. BUT CAN USED LATER ONE OF THE
- WE CAN THAT COULD BE DONE. IF
THAT. ON IF DISTRICTS IF YOU
WANT DISTRICTS TO SORT OF WRAP
THESE PROGRAM. A FELLOW. AFTER
THAT THEY- WILL FALL OFF A CLIFF
IN THEIR FIRST. RUNS YOU COULD
SAVE SOME OF THAT FOR TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY FIFTH. WHEN THAT
FEDERAL- WILL HAVE EXPIRED THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD BE USED TO
HELP THAT. THAT MIGHT- DISTRICTS
MORE CALM. THAT THEY SPEND SOME
MONEY ON. IN THE BE. R. SOME FUN
THERE. TO HELP. SORTS OFTEN
APPLY. MEAN THEY WOULD BE ABLE
ROUTE DOT TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS
A LOT OF MONEY IN THE SYSTEM
WOULD PROBABLY MCCARTY. WILL
MAINTAIN THAT. LARGE AMOUNT OF
LEVELS. RUBBER MOVING FORWARD
BUT- THAT THERE IS A WAY TO RAMP
DOWN WITHOUT IT HAVING A-
NEGATIVE. TO SCHOOL SACRAMENTO.
MCCARTY OKAY. ABSOLUTELY SURE.
AS WELL FOR YOUR- CARD. I YOUR
ABSOLUTE CORRECT ARE NORMAL
MESSAGE WHEN WE TRYOUR LOCAL
LEADERS IT YOU DON'T YOU ONE
TIME MONEY ON STAFF BECAUSE IT
ULTIMATELY ON HOW YOU NOT GONNA
BUT WHAT TO DO IT'S HOW FOR THE
PAST YEAR AND A HALF THAT TAX
NOT HONEST WITH REGARD YOU A
PANDEMIC WE FUNDING- SPECIFIC
AROUND LOSS MITIGATION
LITIGATION SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND SUPPORT OUR BELIEF-
BECAUSE WE DO- WE DO SPEND A LOT
OF TIME ON NON FISCAL MATTERS AS
WELL IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS BUT OUR
BELIEF IS THAT YOU ABSOLUTELY
NEED PEOPLE TO DELIVER SUPPORT.
OFFICE STUDENTS THAT'S HOW WE
MOST EFFECTIVELY THE RIVER THAT
THAT THAT SUPPORT AND SO OUR
ADVICE TO DISTRICTS USED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOUR EXIT
WILLIAMS- I'M NOT NOT DON'T USE
THAT ONE MILLION PEOPLE WHAT
WORK WEEK WEEK GUIDED AND THE
FACT DO THAT BUT WHAT IS YOUR
EXIT PLAN TWO YEARS THREE YEARS
IS A GOOD POINT OUT THE YOU KNOW
WHAT. SHE SAYS AND RIGHT NOW
WE'VE GOT MOST OF THE STATE
FUNDING ON A LONG TRIP. SHE'S
WELL ANSWER. YEAH SPOKE AFTER.
YEAH THANKS PLAYING KNOW. BE.
WILL BE CLEAR IN ORDER TO LOCAL
FOR EXCEPT FOR IT DOES NOT
MISTER NEED THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
LIMON THE PRO YOU JUST. OKAY LAS
VEGAS AND SO MUCH MORE IT MAY BE
DOES YOUR BEST PROGRAM ARE SO
YOU'RE AT PLAN MAY BE A PREVIOUS
FOR. R. YEAH ARE THAT YOU'D BE
TO TOLLCROSS FOR OUT SOME TYPE
OF SAN AND UP FOR OUR PHONE IN
THE WE BEEN DOING AND ONE NOT
THE ONLY ONES MESSAGES THAT WAY
WITHIN. WE COULDN'T GET- TO ME
THEM TO USE THAT- IT'S STAFF
THAT OTHERWISE WOULD LEAVE
BECAUSE OF DECLINING ENROLLMENT
DIRECT HATE MAP VERY QUALIFIED
STAFF. TO NOW. SERVE IN OTHER
ROLES. GREAT YOU- FOR THE SAYING
NO FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- THE MAX COMMENT
FOR EACH PERSON THE PUBLIC WILL
BE ONE MINUTE. I CAN HAS. THANK
YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
PHONE LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO EIGHTEEN HE OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER
OFFLINE IN THE PLACE YOU BACK
INTO THE QUEUE IN FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MODERATOR
PLEASE ONLY JUST READ THE NUMBER
HERE THE NUMBER THE FATHER TOLL
FREE NUMBERS ONE IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN BY THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO IT IS ONE MINUTE SO
MODERATOR AFTER ONE MINUTE
PLEASE TO CUT OFF AND IF THERE'S
ANY- IF ANYONE GOES OUT THE READ
. AND STARTS TALKING ABOUT- SUMS
OF SOME STUFF THAT WE PROBABLY
SHOULDN'T HERE TODAY PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO CUT THEM OFF AS WELL.
PLEASE STAY ON TOPIC. I DO THAT
I JUST LET ME KNOW IF YOU WANT
ME TO GO TO THAT NEXT QUESTION.
SO BUT I'LL DEFINITELY CUT
AMOUNTS OF TO GET OUT OF CONTROL
. AND OUR FIRST- PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY WILL COME FROM ONE THIRTY
NINE. PLEASE GO AHEAD THIRTY
NINE. THE NINE YEAR OPEN. OKAY
HI SORRY I'M MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE KRAUS I'M AN
ADMINISTRATOR AND CO FOUNDER OF
OUR CHARTER ACADMY LOCATED IN
TIMBRE TO DINO. AND WE DID BY
LIKE YOU KNOW THAT OUR SCHOOL IS
A BIT STRUGGLING WHEN IT COMES
TO MAINTAINING SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS DO THAT- COMING BACK
FROM COBIT THIS YEAR OUR
ATTENDANCE IS TRACKING
ATTENDANCE ABOUT 324% LOWER THAN
OUR AVERAGE ALONG WITH- A
DROPPING ABOUT TWENTY TO THIRTY
EIGHTY EIGHT- AND SO WE'RE JUST
ASKING THAT YOU CONSIDER CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO NOT- WE'RE BASICALLY
WE'RE NOT HELD HARMLESS FOR
THIS. HIGHLY UNPREDICTABLE ADA
LOST. AND SO WE'RE ASKING. THAT-
YOU GUYS CONSIDER SCHOOLS TO BE
A PART OF RECEIVING THAT ONE
YOUR PROTECTION LIKE DISTRICTS
DO WHEN IT COMES TO EIGHTY EIGHT
DECLINE. THANK YOU. DURING A
SCHOLAR. YOU ARE LINE THIRTY
SORROWS MUTED THERE FOR SECOND
LINE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY'RE NOT THE
REPUBLIC ADVOCATES IT
IMPLEMENTED WHILE THE THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WILL HAVE
PROFOUND SHORT AND LONG TERM
IMPACT THAT ADDRESS MANY OF THE
CONCERNS DISCUSSED TODAY.
CREATING COMMUNITY SCHOOLS IS
ABOUT MORE THAN EXPANDING
SERVICES IS ABOUT CULTIVATING A
RACIALLY JACK CULTURALLY
SUSTAINING RELATIONSHIPS
CENTERED EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT
BUILDS ON THE STRENGTHS AND ADDS
THAT THE STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
WHERE THEY ARE LEADERS IN SHARED
DECISION MAKING WITH EDUCATORS
ADMINISTRATORS AND COMMUNITY
PARTNERS. COMMUNITY SCHOOL CAN
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND ACCELERATE
LEARNING RECOVERY IN STUDENT
ENGAGEMENT THE STATE TO PROHIBIT
THE USE A COMMUNITY SCHOOL
RESOURCES FOR SCHOOL HARDENING
PRACTICES LIKE HARSH DISCIPLINE
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION BUT
HARM STUDENTS UNLIMITED SHE'D
SPENT. AND INSTEAD PRIORITIZE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WELL BEING
SUCH AS IMPLEMENTING RESTORATIVE
PRACTICES. A POSITIVE SCHOOL
CLIMATE CREATES THE CONDITIONS
FOR LEARNING BUT ARE FUNDAMENTAL
TO ACADEMIC SUCCESS. LASTLY TO
INCREASE STAFFING CAPACITY ON
CAMPUSES COMMUNITY FLUSHING
HIGHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS
INCLUDING PARENTS AND COMMUNITY
SCHOOL COORDINATOR AND SUPPORT
TEACHER RESIDENCIES AND GREGOR
ON PATHWAYS FOR STUDENTS
FAMILIES. CLASSIFIED AN AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAM STAFF TO BECOME
THE DIVERS PREPARED EDUCATORS WE
NEED THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU NEXT WEEK
GOING TO GO. ONE FOR YOUR-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY NINE
FORTY CAN YOU HARRIS. YES HI
THIS IS KRISTIN BROWN THE CFT
UNION OF EDUCATORS IN CLASS BUT
PROFESSIONALS THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR COMMENTS TODAY- WE ARE
EXTREMELY IN SUPPORT OF LOOKING
INTO ENROLLMENT BASED FUNDING
FOR THE NEAR AND LONG TERM TO
HELP RAISE THE- LEVEL OF FUNDING
TO RAISE ALL SHIPS IN OUR STATE.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WE
MUST INCENTIVIZE OUR FUNDING
TOWARDS ENDING OUR STAFFING
CRISIS HAVING ADEQUATE STAFF CAN
HELP WITH SMALLER COBIT COHORTS-
PROVIDE THE SPECIAL ATTENTION
THAT PRESIDENT BIRMINGHAM AND
WAS SPEAKING TO AND HELP PREVENT
SOME OF THE TRIP BURNOUT THAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS. SO TERROR DONALD BASE
INCREASES ARE SOMETHING THAT
THIS VEHICLE IS- INCREDIBLY
SUPPORTIVE OF MENTORSHIP AND
BONUSES ARE HELPFUL BUT WE NEED
TO MAKE THE EDUCATION
PROFESSION- INDUSTRY MORE
DESIRABLE SO WE HOPE THAT WE CAN
FOCUS ON THAT IN THE BUDGET TO
COME. THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU FOR. NEXT WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO LINE THIRTY FOR YOUR OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE MY
NAME'S JAMIE AND I'M CALLING IN
FROM THIS TEN STATE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT I AM A MOM OF TWO KIDS
A SOLE PROPRIETOR TO BUSINESSES.
AND I'M JOINED HERE ON THIS CALL
WITH MY FIFTH GRADER TODAY THIS
IS OUR CIVICS CLASS WHICH SO THE
THING I'M CALLING ABOUT IS THE
PARENT'S PERSPECTIVE ON THE
ISSUE OF ENROLLMENT. MEANING
THAT WE ARE ONE OF THOSE
FAMILIES WHO DECIDED TO DESCEND
ROLE FROM SCHOOLING AND GOING
INTO HOME SCHOOLING THIS YEAR SO
I JUST I APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S
SOME LOOKING OUT WHY ARE PARENTS
DECIDING TO PULL THEIR KIDS OUT
AND EDUCATING THEM AT HOME I'M
SEEING A SIGNIFICANT RISE IN MY
COMMUNITY. I HAVE PARENTS THAT
ARE JOINING ME IN THIS ENDEAVOR
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE REALLY
GOOD SHAPE ACTUALLY ASK SOME OF
THE PARENTS WHY THEY'RE CHOOSING
NOT TO SEND THEIR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL. AND CREATE A
HOMESCHOOLING ENVIRONMENT
INSTEAD I AM SEEING IT GROWING-
IN MY COMMUNITY LIKE I SAID AND
I'VE BEEN HOME SCHOOLING SINCE
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY ONE MY KIDS
ARE IN FIFTH AND SEVENTH GRADE.
AND PRIOR TO LAST SCHOOL YEAR
I'VE NEVER PLAN TO HOME SCHOOL
MY KIDS BUT DUE TO- THE MASKING
REQUIREMENTS THAT VACCINE
MANDATES AND MY MEANT THE MENTAL
HEALTH CONCERNS I DECIDED TO
BRING MY KIDS HOME TO SCHOOL AS
WAS MENTIONED BEFORE I FEEL LIKE
THERE WASN'T A POSITIVE
CONDITIONS FOR SENDING THEM TO
SCHOOL- AND SO EVEN THOUGH I RUN
TWO BUSINESSES I FELT LIKE I CAN
PROVIDE MORE. OF THE POSITIVE
CONDITIONS FOR LEARNING BETTER
AT HOME- THE REASON BEING FOR
THIS IS AT SCHOOL SO MUCH WAS
LOCKED DOWN CANCELED FIELD TRIPS
CANCEL COMMUNITY EVENTS
CANCELLED STILL. PLAYS MUSIC
PERFORMANCES THE LIMITATIONS ON
SPORTS AND ALL OF THAT AT HOME I
AM ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU KNOW- SHE
EVEN WITHOUT A MASK ON FIELD
TRIPS AND EXPERIENCE- PLAY
GROUPS AND ALL OF THAT KIND OF
STUFF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS
BEEN REQUIRING. STUDENTS TO MASK. AT ALL TIMES EVEN OUTDOORS
DURING SHE E. WHEN THEY WERE
GLASS. ON THE TRACK PLEASE SOME
NEED INCLUDES CAN PLACE. WAIT A
MATH. THANK YOUNG SHORT I AM.
WE'LL GO TO THE NAY OUR QUESTION
ARE IN NEXT COM AND- ONE THIRTY
TO YOUR OPEN. YOU TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY TWO ONE MORE
CHANCE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
YOUR COMMENT. THIS MAY TARA TOLD
NINE THIRTY TWO. I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD OKAY
GIVE ME THE WRONG NUMBER SORRY
ABOUT THAT- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRS MEMBERS JOHN WHEN YOU'RE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU OF HER TODAY CO THAT
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN AN
UNEXPECTED UNPREDICTABLE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE ACROSS THE STATE.
BACK IN JUNE WE ALL HOPE THAT
THE SCHOOLS WOULD EXPERIENCE A
MUCH MORE NORMAL YEAR BUT THE
FACT IS THAT MOST DELEGATES ARE
STRUGGLING WITH LOWER THAN
EXPECTED EIGHTY EIGHT DUE TO
CIRCUMSTANCES LARGELY BEYOND
THEIR CONTROL OUR PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE FACING THE SAME
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE HOWEVER UNLIKE
TRADITIONAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE NOT HELD
HARMLESS. FOR THIS HIGHLY
UNPREDICTABLE EIGHTY EIGHT LOST
A SIGNIFICANT DISPARITY IN THE
LAW FUNDS CHARTER SCHOOLS BASED
ONLY ON THEIR CURRENT ACTUAL
ADA- WHERE DISTRICTS ARE
PROTECTED FROM DECLINE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR- PROTECTIONS ARE
CRITICAL SO THAT ALL SCHOOLS MAY
HAVE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL OF SERVICE
THROUGH THIS UNCERTAIN TIME IN
THE STABILITY TO MAINTAIN THOSE
SERVICES WHEN OPERATIONS
STABILIZE. THIS INEQUITY IN THE
LAW MUST BE ADDRESSED WE
THEREFORE REQUEST THE CHARGE
WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE SAME
EIGHTY A LOST PROTECTIONS THAT
ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS CURRENTLY
RECEIVE DURING SOME. PRESIDENT
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY YOUR- ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
COUNTY TO CARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION-
I JUST WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET AS GOING FORWARD WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BUDGET AND
GIVEN THAT EDUCATION GROUPS ARE
CURRENTLY PLAYING CATCH UP.
REGARDING THE FOR. SIX BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS ALLOCATED TO
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY FOR THE YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVES.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER
GOING FORWARD WITH ANY PROJECTED
BUDGET SURPLUS DESIGNATED FOR
STUDENT BEHAVIORAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS. HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S A MUCH MORE
COLLABORATION COOPERATION AND A
COKE HERE AND GO HE SAID PLAN
FOR SPENDING THAT MONEY THAT HAS
ALL THE WORK GROUP MEMBERS. ON
THE SAME PAGE MOVING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN ON
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET AND
WE'RE- ADVOCATING THAT THAT BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU I
LINE EIGHTEEN YOUR OPEN. HELLO
LET ME. CORRECT CORRECT GO AHEAD
OKAY. OUR CATHOLIC BRIDE CLASS
YOU COUNTY RETIRED TEACHERS I'VE
BEEN TO MANY COLLEGES AND IN
NOTED INCREASING HEALTH CONCERNS
OF CHILDREN MY OPINION FOURTH
DUCTING THEY'RE HARMING THE
HEALTH INDEPENDENT OF OUR
CHILDREN KAMALA FOLKS AND THEN
BAD BILLS RELATING TO THE
PROBLEMS OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
FIRST COME IN NINETEEN THAT
VACCINE MANDATES THE PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. IS BAD
TEACHERS NEED TO HAVE ACTING
CHOICE SECOND COVERED NINETEEN
VACCINE MANDATES TO ATTEND. IN
PERSON K. TO TWELVE. PUBLIKUM
SCHOOL WITHOUT EXEMPTION IS THE
BILL WE NEED TO KEEP THE
PERSONABLE BECAUSE FOR ALL
VACCINES SEARCH HPV A MENINGITIS
VACCINE MANDATES AND HAND. IN
PERSON PUBLIC OR PRIVATE HIGH
SCHOOL. WITHOUT A EXEMPTIONS IS
A DANGEROUS BILL FOR ALLOWING
TWELVE AN OVER MINERS TO CONSENT
TO RECEIVE ACTED WITHOUT
PARENTAL CONSENT HORRIBLE IDEA
FOR MANY REASONS OKAY WHAT
PROJECTS ADVOCACY OF SEVERAL
GOOD BILLS WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO
GET OFF THEIR FIRST RELIGIOUS
CONSCIENTIOUS BELIEF EXEMPTIONS
BILL ADLER JUST CONSCIENTIOUSLY
CONVENTION- ALL THAT CLEAN PLACE
. PLEASE SOME. OKAY OKAY THE NEW
DEVELOP BAD. IS GOOD GOT IT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR ALL
TODAY PLEASE WE WILL BE. MY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THANK YOU
AND GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS
JENSEN GRASS I'M- IN THE
MINISTRY WITH IDA HIGH SCHOOL
LOCATED IN LONG BEACH- WE'RE A
HIGH PERFORMING CHARTER SCHOOL
AND OUR STUDENTS ARE PERFORMS
OUTPERFORMED LOCAL STATE AND
NATIONAL AVERAGES ON EVERY
TESTINGS ARE OPENING WE'VE DONE
THAT WHILE SERVING A LONG
BECAUSE MOST CHALLENGING BY A
COMMUNITY. DESPITE THE FACT
THAT- THE ATM AND ROMAN
CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT IT SMALLER CHARTER
SCHOOLS LIKE OURS PARTICULARLY
HARD- FOR THREE REASONS ONE-
WE'RE NOT LARGE AND TO OFFER
INDEPENDENT STUDY IN THE
DISTANCE LEARNING. THAT WE'VE
HEARD TODAY ARE OFFERED BY SOME
OF THE LARGER DISTRICTS. THAT'S
RESULTED BUT NOW THE MEDIA AT
SIX PERCENT- HITS ARMAMENT DAVE
FROM DAY ONE. AND THEN ARE YOU
GOING TO WE HAVE- WE DON'T HAVE
THE STAFFING TO ENSURE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE NEW
INDEPENDENT STUDY REQUIREMENTS
SPECIALLY FOR THE LONG TERM
INDEPENDENT STUDY. I THINK THE
ONE STUDENTS GOING TO QUARANTINE
FOR WHATEVER REASON- THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL WE CALCULATED BY
PERCENT. LOCK YEAH- AND SO WHEN
YOU LOOK AT ARMS. TOTAL FROM
EIGHTY EIGHT PRE CAN. HERE NOW
WHEN YOU INCLUDE WE CAN'T DO
THAT OUTRAGE THAT WOULD NORMALLY
HAPPEN WE HAVE FALLEN- 20% IN
TWO YEARS SO NOT THE 22% NOT THE
3% THE DISTRICTS ARE OKAY
APPEALING BUT THE TWENTY FIRST.
THANK YOU SO. WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
HE- HELD HARMLESS JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. GOOD AFTERNOON
NICOLE BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP
SCHOOL BASED MENTAL HEALTH
CENTERS ARE INTEGRAL TO THE
ACHIEVEMENT OF STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN PARTICULAR
PREVENTION AND EARLY IN FOR
INTERVENTION OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
STUDENT SUCCESS. STUDENTS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING SOCIO EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIORAL OR PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISTRESS. WILL STRUGGLE TO
ENGAGE WITH THE CURRICLUM AND
MAINTAIN POSITIVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH PEERS AND ADULTS. IN
SEVERAL STUDIES RESEARCHERS AND
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS SUCH AS
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY ARE
RELATED TO SCHOOL IMPORTANT
BEHAVIORS INCLUDING CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND CHILDREN
REFUSING TO ATTEND SCHOOL. THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IN BOTH THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE AND
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS INITIATIVE
WHICH SHOULD PROVIDE SCHOOLS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BUILD
THEIR OWN CAPACITY TO SERVE
STUDENTS WITH THE CLINICAL AND
NON CLINICAL RESOURCES. THEY
NEED TO LEARN AND CONTRIBUTE TO
A POSITIVE SCHOOL CLIMATE WE
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR APPROVING S. B.
TWO TWENTY FOUR THIS YEAR
ENSURING THAT HEALTH EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
THANK YOU MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOLS CONTAIN INFORMATION.
THANK YOU. THANKS MUCH FINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS TONY GOING OUT
EVERY SUPER KIND OF INSPIRE
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN THE CENTRAL
MODESTO MCCARTY MCCONNELL AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANKS FOR
LETTING ADDRESS YOU. J. AFFECT
THE- FINDS. ABOUT FISCAL CLIFF-
BEING PAID BY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ADDED HIGHLIGHT THAT THAT.
PUBLICLY FUNDED INDEPENDENT
CHARTERS ALREADY BEEN PUSHED OFF
THAT CLIFF. UNLIKE A LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE NOT PRESENTLY HELD HARMLESS
FOR EIGHTY LAW. AND SO THE
DISPARITY AS ALREADY BEGUN. WE
CURRENTLY ARE 5210% BELOW IN OR
ABA AS WELL AS LOWER IN
ENROLLMENT AND WE'VE EXPERIENCED
SIMILAR. LOSSES THERE WHICH IS
GOING DIRECTLY TO OUR BOTTOM
LINE CURRENTLY. BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE PREDICTABLE FUNDING IS
ESSENTIAL FOR US TO PROVIDE HIGH
LEVELS OF SERVICE IN THESE
UNCERTAIN TIMES SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND SOME OF THE OTHER
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THAT DR- GUN
CANNON MENTIONED. IS SOMETHING
THAT ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS DESERVE
AND SO WHAT WE ASK IS THAT WE
UTILIZE THE HOLD HARMLESS AND
ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY IN THE
LAW. AND MAKE SURE THAT PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
EQUALLY HELD HARMLESS. I
APPRECIATE A LOT OF THE SOLUTION
HERE TODAY AND I HOPE THAT.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE CONSIDERED-
FOR A DATA POINT YOU CAN
CONSIDER. 710% IS ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER SCHOOL WHICH WOULD
EQUATE TO ABOUT THREE TO FOUR
FULL TIME EMPLOYEES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT
CALLJUST TO CLARIFY- THAT'S NOT
. MY THIS BECAUSE AND I'M I'M A
CO ALMOST. WAS IT TO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE. RETURNERS CALLER PLEASE
MY APOLOGIES THERE I FIND THIS
ONE. BROKE IT. TWO VERY
DIFFERENT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LINE FORTY TWO YEP UP ONE FORTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE GOING AT ONE ZERO IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PUT YOURSELF IN Q. TWO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. FORTY TWO
GOING BACK. HI THIS IS ROBERT
MEMORIES FROM CHILDREN NOW- I
WANTED TO TALK JUST BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE UPSIDE OF DECLINING
ENROLLMENT. AND THAT'S MAINLY
THAT WITH PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BEING A TRICKS TOPIC
GROUPS WITH THE GENERAL FUND AND
LOCAL PROPERTY TAXES. AS WE HAVE
DECLINING ENROLLMENT THAT MEANS
THERE'S MORE MONEY AVAILABLE TO
INVEST IN THE KIDS THAT ARE
THERE. THAT MEANS THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME WE'RE SEEING
ACCELERATION IN THE GROWTH IN
PER PUPIL SPENDING. AND NOW WE
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
MONEY IS USED TO SUPPORT- BETTER
STAFFING RATIOS WE'VE HAD SOME
OF THE WORST STAFFING RATIOS IN
THE NATION. THIS OUR OPPORTUNITY
IMPROVE THAT. IN PARTICULAR WE
LIKE THIS MAKE SURE THAT THE
THAT THAT SAVINGS- WHICH WILL BE
UP TO ME TO BE AROUND SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. IS USED TO SUPPORT
BETTER STAFFING LEVELS AT HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS SCHOOLS WE THINK
YOU CAN BUILD ON. LINE YEAH- THE
LAST BUDGET ACTION THAT INVESTED
IN OUR IN STOPPING THE WILL TO
BE SCHOOLS. AND ENSURE THAT TE
KIDS WHO NEED IT MOST GET THE
ATTENTION THAT THEY DESERVE- ONE
OTHER AREA A RECOMMENDATION IS
GIVING DISTRICTS GREATER
FLEXIBILITY WITH. THEIR RESERVE
REQUIREMENTS IN CARRYING MONEY
OVER FROM ONE YEAR TO THE NEXT
WITH FORTY BILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME MONEY FLOATING AROUND
IN THE SYSTEM. PROVIDING SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO MOVE THAT MONEY
ACROSS YEARS. WOULD ALLOW
DISTRICTS TO USE THOSE FUNDS TO
HIRE STAFF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU AND I LISTEN I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS ABOUT
STAFFING LEVEL REALLY TO ME THAT
MEANS CLASS SIZES. ARE CLASS
SIZES ARE WAY TOO LARGE IN THIS
STATE- THEY'RE STARTING TO COME
DOWN A BIT- AND THERE'S NOTHING
MORE MAGICAL. MORE MAGICAL
CHANGE IN A CLASS AND THEN I
HAVE A SMALLER CLASS SIZE IT
JUST CREATES A MUCH MORE
POSITIVE ENVIRONMENT. FOR
STUDENT HEALTH AS WELL AS
STUDENT ACADEMICS. SO WITH THAT
TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANKS MUCH BETTER. ANNEX WE'RE
GONNA GO LINE FOR SIX YOU ARE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ALLOW US TO SPEAK I JUST WANTED
TO SHARE THAT AS A PARENT AND MY
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT I'VE TAKEN
OUT MY- THREE STUDENTS AT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT. DUE TO IT ALL
BEGAN WITH COLIN AND I ALSO
REALIZED AS ANOTHER PARENT
CALLER SAID THAT I CAN PROVIDE A
HIGHER QUALITY EDUCATION. AND MY
CHILDREN DON'T HAVE TO BE MASS
MY CHILDREN DON'T HAVE TO. AND
YOUR THIS TRAUMA THAT WE CALL
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. SO
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I'M
GLAD YOU GUYS ARE REVIEWING THE
BUDGET- IF THE BUDGET INCLUDES-
EMOTIONAL SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BECAUSE THAT'S HIGHLY
NEEDED TO KOBE. THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY I TOOK MY
CHILDREN OUT BECAUSE THE CODE
MANDATES AFFECTED THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH THAT SIGNIFICANTLY. AND
THAT'S IT THAT'S MY COMMENT
THANK YOU AGAIN HAVE A GOOD ONE
. THANK YOU TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
ARE THERE ANY MORE COLORS. I
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YES
THANK YOU MEMBERS MICHAEL WHOLE
SIZER ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY SIX
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN KERN COUNTY
REGISTER CALLING IN TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO HEADY CHANG
AND HER COMMENTS ON CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND PARTICULARLY FOR
HELPING THE COMMITTEE BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRANSPORTATION. AND TRANSPORTING
STUDENTS EVERY DAY TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION IS PROBABLY THE
BEST EXAMPLE OF FUNDING INEQUITY
CURRENTLY IN OUR FUNDING SYSTEM
AND- WITH CD THE ROBUST NEW
REVENUES THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THE GOVERNOR AND LEGISLATURE WE
HOPE YOU'LL GIVE FAVOURABLE
CONSIDERATION TO ADDRESSING THE
LONG STANDING FUNDING INEQUITY
AROUND TRANSPORTATION WE HAVE
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
FUNDED RIGHT NOW AT LESS THAN
10% OF THEIR ACTUAL COSTS. AND
THIS IS A GREAT YEAR TO ADDRESS
pTHANK YOU TO OUR NEXT CALLER.
PUBLISHED YOUR THAT NO OTHER
PARTISAN QUEUED UP THANK YOU I
WILL NOW GO TO I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE'S IN THE ON THE WEST
STEPS I DON'T BELIEVE SO IF WE
ARE WILL GO BACK TO THEM IF
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHICH IS SAID
TO OFFER PUBLIC TESTIMONY YOU
HAVE ONE MINUTE YOU MAY COME UP
TO THE MICROPHONE. WONDERFULLY
STICK TO THE TOPIC AT HAND. MARK
ABSTAINED CALIFORNIAN FIREMEN OF
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK- IS
THAT ONE AS FAR AS WITH THE NEW
FUNDING THAT IS AT LEAST ONE
TIME FUNDING MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION ABOUT SEVEN YEARS
AGO I STARTED RECOMMENDING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT THAT- DID
TO DEVELOP LIBRARIES OF- VIDEO
LESSONS ACROSS AS FAR LESSONS
ACROSS THE CURRICULUM AND I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WOULD BE ADVANTAGEOUS IN THE ONE
TIME FUNDING IS PROVIDED GRANTS
TO DISTRICTS TO CREATE LIBRARY
OF- LICENSED VIDEO TO BE
ACCESSED INTO A YOUTUBE CHANNEL
BY THE DISTRICTS THIS HAS THE
ADVANTAGE THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT STUDENTS THAT HAVE MULTIPLE
DAY- ABSENCES CAN ACCESS AND IT
HAS SECOND BENEFIT AS FAR AS
HAVING A STUDENTS WHO DON'T GET
SOMETHING IN THE CLASSROOM AS
FAR AS- REMEDIAL INSTRUCTION
THAT THEY CAN ACCESS THOSE
LESSONS AND BE ABLE TO. STOP AND
REWIND OF THINGS THAT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND ALSO AS FAR AS BEING
HERE- ON THIS HEARING TODAY A
LOT OF- ATTENTION WAS PLACED AS
FAR AS ON THE ATTENDANCE OF
STUDENTS IN SEATS AND TIME AND
THAT WAS ALSO DEFICIENCY IN JUNE
THE DISTANCE LEARNING WELL WE
NEED TO DO IS LOOK AS FAR AS
LEARNING ENGAGEMENT AND LOOKING
AT A LARGER VARIETY OF HOW WE
PROVIDE LEARNING ENGAGING FOR
THE STUDENTS THANKS. SEE NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT- THIS
HEARING WILL BE. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE WE CAN'T SPEAKER YOU
SEE. ONE IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
YOU MAY PROCEED ONE MINUTE
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU MY
NAME IS NICOLE YANG I AM TO
PLASTER COUNTY CHAPTER CHAIR OF
MOMS FOR LIBERTY. WE HAVE SIX
CHAPTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE GROWING EVERY DAY OUR MAIN
FOCUS AND MISSION RIGHT NOW. IS
TO HELP FAMILIES UNENROLLED FROM
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM AS IT
IS FAILING THEM WE ARE SETTING
UP HOME SCHOOL PODS AND EVEN
HAVE HAD MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE CREATE THEIR OWN SCHOOLS
FREE OF GOVERNMENT INTRUSION.
THE MANDATES THAT THESE HIGH AND
LEGISLATORS ARE PASSING RIGHT
NOW ARE CUTTING ENROLLMENT LOSS.
SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
ENROLLMENT CLIFF NOT HAPPEN AN
ENROLLMENT CLIFF NOT HAPPEN YOU
WILL WALK BACK SOME OF THESE
POLICIES. SUCH AS THE VACCINE
MANDATE AND PLASTER COUNTY WE
STAND TO LOSE A THIRD OF OUR
TEACHERS AND ABOUT 20% OF OUR
STUDENTS. THAT WILL DRASTICALLY
AFFECT FUNDING AND THAT WILL
DRASTICALLY AFFECT THE- LEVEL OF
SCHOOLING THESE CHILDREN ARE
GETTING. THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS SARAH AND I'M FROM
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY I'M GONNA
READ- I'VE BEEN KIND OF
SURPRISED THAT NOBODY'S TALKING
ABOUT THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM
WHICH IS THE REASON FOR THE LACK
OF ENROLLMENT. AND THAT IS THE
VACCINE MANDATES FOR STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS YOU KNOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TEACHER CRISIS.
AND A LOSS OF ENROLLMENT AND
IT'S REALLY JUST THAT SIMPLE- I
JUST BEEN SURPRISE BECAUSE I'VE
BEEN HEARING. DISCUSSION ABOUT
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL ISSUES AND
MENTAL HEALTH ASPECTS AND ALL
THAT BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD A
SINGLE ONE OF THE EXPERTS.
ADDRESS THE ACTUAL REASON NOT
EVEN THE OAKLAND SUPERINTENDENT
I MEAN IT'S KIND UNDERSTOOD THAT
THE BLACK POPULATION IT'S LIKE
6270% OF. BLACK AMERICANS
NATIONWIDE A REFUSING TO BE
VACCINATED AND SHOOTING BROACH
THAT SUBJECT WHEN IT CAME TO HER
KIDS. SO IT DOESN'T MAKE A LOT
OF SENSE TO ME SO I'M HOPING
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE. YOU KNOW I
REALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE BELIEVE
THAT OUR REPRESENTATIVES WISH TO
SOLVE EDUCATION IN OUR STATE-
BUT YOU'LL NEVER SOLVE THE
PROBLEM YOU DON'T CORRECTLY
IDENTIFY THANK YOU THANK YOU. TO
THE NEXT SPEAKER. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR PARTY DONALD. AND OTHERS
ARE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS SURE TO
LATCH ON MY MOM RETIRED HOME
SCHOOL TEACHER AND RETIRED LAB
PROFESSIONALS CAN HEAR
ADVOCATING. QUESTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE. HOW DO WE FIX IN
PERSON LEARNING WHEN THIS
COMMITTEE IS PUSHING. AND OTHERS
I SPOKE- FOR ONLINE LEARNING-
THAT THERE YOU'RE YOU'RE PUSHING
FOR ONLINE LEARNING VERSUS IN
PERSON LEARNING. HOW DOES THAT
HELP WE KNOW CHILDREN NEED
CONTACT I DO NOT NEED TO SHOW
YOU CHARTS OR GRAPHS THAT IT'S
EASY TO SEE OUR CHILDREN
SUFFERING IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS
NOW. THE UNCONSTITUTIONAL
MANDATES PLACED UPON US HIS
CRUSHER CHILDREN'S EDUCATION
PROVOKING EXTREME CHALLENGES.
THAT DIRECTLY AFFECT THEM ALL OF
THEM. IF YOU WANT FUNDING GET IT
FROM THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS BUT YOU GUYS HAVE PUT
ASIDE THAT WE DID NOT APPROVE.
ARE WITH THE GOVERNOR VACATIONS
ONCE YOU GET THE MONEY THERE.
SHAME ON YOU I'M OFFENDED. I'M
NOT A TERRORIST I'M A PARENT AND
I'D LOVE BY CHILDREN. THANK I'M
HERE. I'M HERE TO TELL YOU TO
STOP FIRING STAFF STOP IT STOP
THESE MANDATE YOU DON'TLIVE.
THERE ARE. DIGITAL. I'M TORN
DOWN THE BUILDING YEAH ALTHOUGH
I KNOW YOU HAVE A PLAN TO BUILD
A GLASS PALACE WITH OUR MONEY
BUT PATRICK O'DONNELL AT LEAST
YOU'RE TAKING COMMENT TODAY
UNLIKE THE PORK'S HEARING. MY
NAME IS SANDRA HAD STRONG YOU
KNOW ME WHILE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUILDING TWO HUNDRED TIMES I
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT
IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ANY LONGER
BECAUSE WE ARE DONE WITH YOU AND
YOUR POISON. THE PARENTS KNOW
WHAT THIS IS THEY WILL NOT STAND
FOR THESE MANDATES READING FROM
LA TIMES FORTY FOUR THOUSAND LA
STUDENTS MISSED THE FIRST
VACCINE DEADLINE 75% OF
SACRAMENTO SAC CITY. STUDENTS
HAVE NOT SHOWNPROOF OF THE
VACCINE. THE OTHER SPEAKER
CALLED IT THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF US
IN THIS BUILDING. DURING S. B.
TWO SEVEN SIX IN SEPTEMBER OF
NINETEEN YOU ARE ARRESTED SEVEN
PARENTS WHO JUST WANT TO HAVE
CHOICE OVER THEIR CHILDREN'S
MEDICAL DECISIONS THANK YOU WE
ARE NOT. WITH THAT- THANK YOU
FOR ALL THOSE WHO STAYED THROUGH
THE HEARING AND SHARED PUBLIC
COMMENT THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.